Charles à l'oncle, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Sinkerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Très succintement. Alors moi je j'ai le
plaisir d'être là. Merci infiniment pour
votre invitation. Cherl l'oncle, je suis
député depuis peu de temps. J'ai été élu
il y a un peu moins de 2 ans. Je viens
plutôt du milieu de l'entreprise et de
l'entrepreneuriat. J'ai peu d'heur de
vol politique à mon actif. J'ai 32 ans.
Qu'est-ce que je peux vous dire ? Je
suis membre de la commission des
affaires économiques. C'est un sujet qui
est important pour moi et j'ai été connu
sur les derniers mois en tant que
rapporteur de la commission d'enquête
sur le public. Je viens de remettre mon
rapport et j'ai le grand plaisir
quasiment en exclusivité de vous donner
les grandes recommandations de ce
rapport.
On suit cette commission depuis à peu
près 6 mois. On va en parler longuement.
On va parler de la presse, de
l'audiovisuel, de militarisation, de
budget public pour faire passer X ou Y
idé et et peut-être faire terire les
autres. Vous connaissez la chaîne
YouTube Seriew ?
Évidemment, je je vous avoue que c'est
une des chaînes que j'écoute le plus. Je
vais une fois par semaine au sport,
c'est un espèce de temps que je
sanctuarise et tous les lundis matins,
je vous écoute. J'essaie de rattraper
mon retard sur les dernières interviews
et c'est évidemment une chaîne. C'est
pour ça que c'est un grand honneur que
vous me faites de m'inviter et j'espère
être à la hauteur de toutes les
questions que vous allez me poser
évidemment.
Ce que vous avez pu regarder, vous avez
une interview à conseiller à notre
communauté.
Oui. Alors, vous allez m'accuser de
partialité mais je trouve que alors il y
a différentes interviews. Les premières
qui m'ont vraiment intéressé, c'est
celle de Laurent Alexandre que je trouve
fascinant. dans sa démarche, dans son
côté aussi un peu disruptif, même si la
disruption c'est un terme que je récuse
et qui qui veut un peu tout et rien
dire, mais je trouve qu'il arrive à
penser en dehors de la boîte, il arrive
à à donner de la matière à réflexion et
à débat et c'est aussi pour ça que
j'aime beaucoup l'écouter. Et après une
interview un peu récente, un peu plus
récente, c'est celle de Jean-Philippe
Tangi. Ah
oui,
j'ai trouvé fort. C'est un souverainiste
convaincu. On a pas forcément les mêmes
idées sur la dimension économique, mais
j'ai trouvé passionnant. J'ai trouvé
aussi des questions très intéressantes.
Donc voilà, ça fait partie des dernières
interviews qui ont pu être révélé sur
votre chaîne que j'ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'attention.
Avant de commencer, moi je vais
conseiller une interview à notre
communauté. C'est l'interview du général
Didier Castre et l'interview du
contreamiral
Loï Finas. Je vous le recommande ça
chaudement pour faire votre sport. En
plus, ça motive très bien pour courir
vite et fort. On rentre dans le vif du
sujet. Qu'est-ce qu' a qu'est-ce qui a
déclenché cette commission ? un certain
nombre de points. Déjà, ce qu'il faut
dire, c'est que chaque groupe
d'opposition à l'Assemblée nationale
dispose d'un droit de tirage annuel. Un
droit de tirage, c'est quoi ? C'est la
possibilité de faire une commission
d'enquête par an sur le thème de son
choix. Nous, on est un petit groupe, on
est le plus petit groupe à l'Assemblée
nationale. On a un peu plus 15 députés
avec Eric Seti. Et pour notre toute
première commission d'enquête annuelle,
on a décidé de la consacrer à l'audio
duel public. Alors pourquoi déjà la
première raison c'est parce que
l'Assemblée nationale n'avait jamais
réalisé la moindre commission d'enquête
sur ce thème-là. C'est un thème qui
pourtant est important, c'est 4
milliards d'euros d'argent public, c'est
la moitié du budget du ministère de la
culture. Il y avait trois axes qui nous
paraissaient essentiels. Le contrôle de
la garantie de pluralisme qui je pense
que les Français ont sont témoins mais
semaine après semaine, on voit un
certain nombre d'entors à ce principe
qui est pourtant fondamental. Le
deuxième point, ce sont les conflits
d'intérêt et d'une certaine d'une
certaine façon comment assaignir les
pratiques des dirigeants de l'audiovisal
public. Et le troisème point, c'était
aussi la gestion financière. Il y a eu
beaucoup de rapports de l'IGF, de la
Cour des comptes qui quasiment tous les
6 ou 7 ans révélait les turpitudes de
gestion financière de ces entreprises.
On voit qu'elles sont au bord de la fate
cour des comptes il y a quelques mois
seulement révélé que il y avait un
risque de dissolution qui posait sur
France Télévision. La trésorerie est
négative, les capitaux propres sont
inférieurs à la moitié du capital social
ce qui vaut quasiment risque de
dissolution dans le code de commerce. Et
on a aussi un déficit qui a été cumulé
de plus de 80 millions d'euros
simplement entre 2017 et 2024. Donc pour
ces trois points fondamentaux, le
respect du pluralisme, les atteintes
d'une certaine façon à la bonne gestion
financière et les conflits d'intérêt, on
s'est dit avec Ericil Sutilic, c'était
important de s'intéresser à ce sujet. Je
ne dis pas que c'est le sujet le plus
fondamental
qui concerne les Français.
Quelle était ma question ?
Pourquoi on avait convoqué cette
commission d'enquête ? Donc voilà, si je
devais retenir deux raisons. Première,
c'est la première fois que l'Assemblée
nationale réalise ce sujet de d'étude de
l'audiovisuel public. Et la deuxième
raison, c'est qu'à un moment où budget
après budget qu'on vote, on demande
toujours plus d'efforts aux Français. On
leur demande toujours plus de se serrer
la ceinture. C'est important aussi de
demander des comptes à ceux qui ont pour
profession de poser des questions
quasiment jamais d'y répondre. Et encore
une fois, demander des comptes à l'audis
public, sans en aucun cas régler ses
comptes. C'est au contraire faire preuve
de l'article 24 de la Constitution.
L'évaluation des politiques publiques,
on me l'a suffisamment reproché et je
pense que c'est sain aussi de
s'intéresser à l'ensemble des politiques
publiques. Que ça plaise ou ça déplaise
un petit système qui s'est très
longtemps protégé, il était temps une
bonne fois pour toutes d'ouvrir le
couvercle et de de lever ce sujet
important.
Avant de rentrer dans le détail parce
qu'on a un peu de temps sur Syerview et
avant de rentrer dans le détail, est-ce
qu'on a essayé de vous faire taire, de
vous impressionner, de vous mettre la
peur au ventre ? [grognement] ou de vous
faire passer des messages comme quoi si
vous continuez sur cette lancée, votre
avenir en politique était détruit, on
allait trouver X ou Y chose sur vous.
Est-ce que par exemple la plainte c'est
une plainte contre vous ? C'est une
plainte contre X
et quel est le motif de la plainte et
par qui ?
C'est c'est absolument ridieux et ça
était une éème tentative au fond
d'essayer de détourner le regard,
détourner l'attention médiatique, détour
détourner le regard des Français. On a
vu que il y a eu beaucoup d'articles de
façon coordonnée, de façon politique qui
ont été diffusés dans les heures qui ont
précédé la publication du rapport.
C'est peut-être une interprétation le
fait que ce soit coordonné. C'estàd
c'est un sujet qui est bon qui estable
pour vendre du papier faire perdre de
temps de cerveau disponible et c'est
surtout un bon canal pour faire passer
surfer sur votre buzz et en plus si on
peut vous mettre un petit coup derrière
la tête c'est bien. Mais ce que je n'ai
pas accepté, c'est que l'agence
France-press, qui est quand même un
organe qui euh contribue à la
restauration de la confiance, qui est un
repère pour la confiance des Français,
le journal Le Monde, France Interre,
France info qui ont diffusé allègrement
cette fausse information dans les heures
qui ont précédé la publication du
rapport. Donc c'était à partir de lundi
6h du matin. Donc on a le monde qui a
fait une alerte le monde diffusé sur des
millions de téléphones portables de
français. On a France Inter qui à partir
de 5h30 du matin toutes les demi-heures,
faisait un flash pour diffuser une
fausse information. On a France Info qui
sur son site a relayé cette fausse
information. Cette fausse information
c'était laquelle ? Même l'agence France
Press a diffusé cette fausse
information. La fausse information
c'était que j'étais visé par une plainte
pour prise illégale d'enterrêt. Quand on
regarde la plainte, c'est une plainte
qui est déposée contre. Cette plainte
n'est pas déposée contre moi. C'est une
plainte en plus qui a été déposée par
une association d'extrême gauche
militante dont le dirigeant est une
personne qui a été virée par anticorps
et qui en plus de ça a été condamné par
la justice il y a quelques mois. Donc
vous voyez aussi la perception et la
légitimité de la plainte qui a été
déposée. Mais ce que je regrette c'est
que
je me fais je me fais l'avocat du
diable. C'est un peu une association
d'extrême gauche qui fait bien son
boulot hein.
Absolument. Et vous avez raison. C'est
pas forcément le le prisme militant,
mais ce que je regrette, c'est pas tant
la plainte qui a été déposée. N'importe
quelle association peut déposer une
plainte, c'est le traitement qui a été
fait de façon parfaitement mensongère.
Le le l'alerte le monde indique que je
suis visé par une plainte. Sur le site
de France info, il y a même
explicitement indiqué dans l'article une
plainte est déposée contre Charles
Loncle. L'agence France Presse relée une
dépêche qui indique à peu près la même
teneur de l'information. Alors que la
plainte est déposée contre il la plainte
n'est pas déposée contre moi. Donc dans
les heures qui ont précédé la
publication du rapport, il y a une vaste
entreprise politique pour essayer de me
discréditer et d'une certaine façon,
c'est pas que moi parce que je m'en
fiche, ça ne ça porte atteinte
simplement à mes intérêts, à la limite
on pourrait s'en passer. Mais le
l'objectif, le dessin qui est derrière
proposé, c'est de discréditer les 400
pages de rapport que j'ai pourtant
rédiger, les 80 recommandations qui
étaient quasiment qui allaient quasiment
être révélées. Et donc voilà, j'ai j'ai
essayé de rétablir cette vérité dans une
conférence de presse. Je constate
quelques heures après que il y a
toujours des médias notamment de la
presse privée qui continuent à relayer
cette fausse information. Je ne suis pas
visé par cette plainte. Cette plainte
n'a pas été déposée contre moi, c'est
une plainte contre X. Donc j'attends que
le monde, que Franceerre, que France
info, que France Télévision d'une façon
générale et que l'agence France Press
rétablisse la vérité, rétablisse
[grognement]
aussi mon honneur parce que ça fait 48
he qu' fuse n'importe quoi. Ça fait 48
he que je me prends des centaines de
messages de mails de de d'articles sur
les réseaux sociaux qui indiquent que je
serai corrompu, qu'il rétablisse une
bonne fois pour toute la vérité. C'est
pas faute d'avoir passé du temps avec
eux. Il ne m'accorde aucune forme de
contradictoire. Je trouve que ça dit
aussi beaucoup de l'état de défiance
démocratique qui est en train de
s'installer. Quand on ne peut plus avoir
confiance dans les médias principaux qui
nous alimentent en information, ça dit
aussi beaucoup du système qui se protège
et qui essaie de déformer la vérité et
le rapport au réel.
Cool. Ça ça vous avez déposé plainte ?
Je prépare effectivement je l'ai
absolument pas dit. C'est la première
fois que que je le révèle. Je prépare
avec mes avocats euh un des pot de
plainte pour dénonciation calomnieuse
parce que cette association, même si
elle ne me vise pas, même si elle n'a
pas porté plainte contre moi mais contre
ils dénonciation calomnieuse qui a été
en plus de ça, vous voyez ce qui est
très étonnant c'est que je suis contacté
par le monde le dimanche après-midi.
Ils ont fait l'effort de vous contacter
déjà
veille de la publication du rapport il
ils essayent de me de m'appeler. Je ne
réponds pas parce que je me dis c'est
encore un éème média qui essaie
d'obtenir mon rapport sous embargot
alors que j'ai expliqué que je ne
révélerai pas mon mon rapport tant qu'il
n'était pas publié. Je ne leur réponds
pas. Quelques minutes ou quelques
dizaines de minutes après, je reçois un
message. Voilà, bonjour monsieur machin,
journaliste du monde, vous avez euh vous
êtes objet vous êtes ciblé par un dépôt
de plante pour prise illégale d'intérêt,
pacte de corruption. Nous souhaiterions
avoir votre votre réponse et si vous
nous répondez pas sous x temps et bien
on publiera l'article sans votre
contradictoire. Donc je suis très
étonné. Évidemment, je vois un tel
message, je rappelle immédiatement le
journaliste du monde. Je dis bon, vous
m'apprenez qu'il y a une plainte qui est
déposée contre moi. Est-ce que vous
pouvez m' m'en dire plus ? Là, la
personne est très évasive, me dit "Non,
je peux pas vous en dire plus. Euh je
peux simplement vous dire que c'est de
la prise illégale d'intérêt. Il y a un
soupçon de corruption." Je vous dis
"Mais dites-moi, qui vous a transmis
l'information ? Quel est le motif exact
de la plainte qui est déposée ?" Je ne
suis pas au courant. On a quelques
heures de la publication du rapport. Je
vais avoir besoin de vous parce que vous
me demandez une réaction sur une plainte
que vous connaissez mais vous ne voulez
pas me révéler le fond exact de cette
plainte. Donc je vais vous demander
d'être un peu plus locasse parce que
sinon la conversation risque d'être
assez stérile.
Locas ou Prolix ?
Les deux. [rires]
Et euh au bout de quelques minutes, la
personne finit par me dire "Bon
effectivement, j'ai accès à la plainte."
Ça montre aussi la collusion entre ces
associations qui attaquent des
politiques et certains médias qu'ils
choisissent avec une forme d'efficacité.
une suputation. Ça
c'est peut-être une suppation mais
c'est sûrement parce que les
journalistes ont des copains
chez chez dans la dans la police
et il y a une violation souvent du
secret de l'instruction qui est tout
aussi scandaleuse. Et moi, j'ai subi une
violation notamment du du rapport qui a
été publié qui ne devait pas être révélé
avant la publication de ce rapport.
Pourtant, les journalistes sont donnés à
cœur joie, ont révélé des
recommandations, n'ont même pas demandé
mon avis et ma vérification sur est-ce
que ces recommandations figuraient bien
dans le rapport et ont déformé un
certain nombre de recommandations qui
étaient en plus des fausses
informations. Mais pour revenir à ce
point, le journaliste du monde finit au
bout de quelques minutes de de
conversation téléphonique par me dire
"Bon, je vais vous en dire plus, j'ai eu
la plainte que je n'avais pas eu à
l'évidence que j'étais pas visé par la
plainte." Il me dit "Bon voilà, vous
êtes soupçonné de prise illégale
intérêt, de pactes de corruption parce
que vous auriez reçu sur votre boîte
mail publique des questions envoyées par
la garde question que le président de la
commission d'enquête a aussi reçu, que
d'autres députés ont reçu, sachant que
j'ai reçu depuis le début de cette
commission d'enquête des centaines de
contributions sur ma boîte mail
publique. C'est d'ailleurs tout le rôle
des députés. Euh j'ai reçu des
contributions de syndicalistes, de
représentants de salariés, de
producteurs indépendants, même de
directeur actuels de l'audiovisuel
public, d'ancien directeur de France
Télévision. Voilà, c'est aussi le rôle
d'un député de recevoir sur sa boîte
publique un certain nombre de
contributions. Donc il m'a dit voilà,
vous auriez reçu ça et donc il y a une
plainte qui vous concerne, qui est
déposée contre vous pour pris illégale
d'intérêt et pacte de corruption. Je dis
ben je suis très étonné, j'ai pas reçu
cette plainte.
Le mail vous l'avez ouvert en question ?
Alors, c'est un texto, un SMS. Euh le le
mail des questions, vous voulez dire ?
Alors, c'est mes collaborateurs qui euh
gèrent ma boîte mail. Ils ont reçu
effectivement, je crois, trois mails que
le président aussi de la commission,
enfin le président de la commission a
reçu un certain nombre de questions.
Comment vous le savez
que que ces mails ont été reçus ?
Parce que après coup, quand le monde a
révélé ces informations, j'ai demandé à
à mes collaborateurs, je leur ai dit
mais vérifiez, on m'accuse de ça. Est-ce
que effectivement sur ma boîte mail
publique, on a reçu ses contributions ?
Donc il y a eu un petit temps parce que
je je reçois des milliers de
contributions de messages et de mails
sur ma boîte publique pendant ces 6 mois
de commission d'enquête. Donc il a fallu
un petit temps pour pour retrouver tout
ça et pour faire acte d'archéologie. Et
mes collaborateurs juste après m'ont dit
"Oui effectivement à l'évidence il y a
trois mails, deux ou trois mails qui ont
été reçus envoyés visiblement le
président de la commission d'enquête et
d'autres députés les ont reçus." Donc
voilà j'ai évidemment simplement c'estàd
que c'est un mail avec plusieurs noms
plusieurs destinataires. Vous avez
appelé votre président, vous avez dit
"Tu as reçu le même mail". Comment ça se
passe ? C'est ça. Je suis tout de suite
retourné vers le président en disant
"Mais tu vois, à l'évidence, on a reçu
ce mail là." Mais vous voyez, en prenant
un peu de recul, ce sont des activités
d'affaires publique. Chaque entreprise,
chaque institution a un département
d'affaires publique et met à profit ce
département d'affaires publique pour
envoyer des contributions aux députés.
La période la plus intense, c'est
notamment la période du budget où vous
recevez des centaines voire des des
plusieurs centaines de mails notamment
d'entreprises qu'elle soit publique ou
privé qui vous disent attention il y a
cet amendement qui risque de mettre en
péril notre secteur et notre domaine.
Est-ce que vous pouvez défendre
l'intérêt ? Il y a même des entreprises
qui vous prérédigent des amendements en
vous disant voilà vous pouvez déposer
cet amendement, il est tout fait, vous
apparaîtrez comme techniquement au
point, vous avez juste qu'à le déposer,
on s'est occupé de tout. C'est vieux
comme l'Assemblée nationale, je le
déplore parce que je pense qu'il faut
tenir le plus éloigné possible des
parlementaires et des représentants des
Français ces activités de lobbing. Il
faut réguler tout ça. Je pense qu'il
faut empêcher ces pratiques-là. Mais à
l'évidence, recevoir un mail sur sa
boîte publique à l'Assemblée nationale
n'est en rien une infraction pénale.
Donc je voudrais simplement finir cette
ce sujet-ls au monde et je leur dis
"Mais vous m'apprenez cette nouvelle.
C'est quoi cette histoire de SMS ?
Alors ce SMS c'est le SMS du journaliste
du monde qui a essayé de me contacter
dans les heures qui ont précédé la
publication du rapport. J'ai pas répondu
parce que j'étais persuadé qu'il voulait
que je lui envoie le rapport sans
embargot alors que je ne l'ai envoyé à
personne et il finit par me dire il y a
une plainte qui a été déposée contre
vous. Je l'appelle, je lui dis "Mais
c'est très étonnant, j'ai pas reçu cette
plainte, vous en êtes sûr ?" Il me dit
"Oui oui, j'en suis sûr. Dans la foulée,
j'ai France Interre, dans la foulée,
j'ai l'agence France-presse. Donc on est
le dimanche veille de la publication du
rapport. J'avais autre chose à faire que
de répondre à ces gens-là. Et je leur
réponds, je leur dis "Je suis très
étonné, j'ai pas reçu la plainte. Euh,
on est plusieurs dont le président de la
commission d'enquête avoir reçu ces
questions. Évidemment, vous l'avez
vérifié, je les ai pas utilisé. Vous
avez très bien vu les questions qui
m'ont été envoyé, les questions que j'ai
posé, vous voyez que je les ai pas
utilisé. Vous voyez que j'ai pas été
conciliant avec Vivindi parce que je me
suis attaqué d'une certaine façon. En
tout cas, j'ai posé des questions assez
compliquées à Nagi qui est coactionnaire
de Biget, don Vivandy et coactionnaire.
J'ai posé des questions sur le cas de
Takiscandiste qui a fait des navettes
entre France Tévision et Panigé. J'ai
posé des questions aux dirigeants de
Banigé. Donc si j'avais été un pion de
Vivandi, j'aurais préservé les intérêts
de Banigé. Donc je vous apporte la
preuve évidente que ces questions qui
m'ont été envoyées sur ma boîte
publique, comme elles ont été envoyées
sur la boîte publique du président et
d'autres députés, ben n'ont influent
rien dans ma capacité de décision de
cette commission enquête. Bon voilà, je
leur réponds je leur réponds à tout ça.
Je leur donne ces éléments factuels. Un,
c'est bizarre, j'ai pas reçu de dépôt de
plainte. Et de ces questions ont été
envoyé à d'autres députés que moi, au
président.
On me dit demain matin à l'aube, on
publiera cet article. L'agence
France-press me dit "La dépêche sera
publiée à 6h du matin." Bizarrement,
c'était le jour où était censé se tenir
la publication du rapport. Je leur dis
"Mais vous êtes sûr d'en faire un fait
d'actualité ? Moi, je trouve ça assez
louche. J'ai toujours pas la moindre
information. Est-ce que vous êtes sûr
vraiment que ça doit venir parasiter les
conclusions du rapport que je rends et
qui a fait l'objet de 6 mois de travail
? Il me disent bah vous savez on est
souverain, c'est à nous de décider. Je
le dis très bien. Le lendemain matin, 6h
du matin, j'étais réveillé, je vois
Alerte Le Monde diffusé sur des millions
de téléphone portable avec Charles à
l'oncle, rapporteur de la commission
d'enquête visé par une plainte pour
prise illégale d'intérêt, dépêche de la
FP qui s'en alimente nombre de médias
qui ne font preuve d'aucune déontologie,
qui ne m'appellent même pas pour avoir
un droit au contradictoire, qui ne
vérifient même pas cette information. se
disent c'est la FP, c'est un totem,
c'est un socle et un pilier de la
démocratie donc on ne peut pas la
remettre en question et la FP diffuse
exactement la même chose. France interre
des 5h30 du matin, le lundi de la
publication du rapport, toutes les
demi-heures faisait un flash. J'étais
quasiment mis en examen. J'étais aux
portes de la prison de la santé.
Pablo Escobar
et j'étais Pablo Escobar pour pacte de
corruption, prise illégale d'intérêt. Ça
y est, on avait découvert, on avait
retiré le masque du rapporteur de la
commission d'enquête. Toutes les
révélations qu'il avait faites en fait
étaient fausses parce que il était
soi-disant euh ses ficelles étaient
tirées par des intérêts privés externes.
Je me prends cette vague là, je constate
qu'en fait la plainte n'est pas déposée
contre moi, c'est une plainte contre X
et donc je passe quasiment l'intégralité
de mon lundi que j'aurais dû plutôt
consacrer à la justification de mes
recommandations, au service après-vente
de mon rapport, à la réponse de
journalistes et de français qui
voulaient en savoir plus sur ce que
contenaient les révélations de ce
rapport. Je le consacre pendant près
d'une journée aller répondre et éteindre
des incendies fallacieux de la part de
journalistes qui n'ont aucune
déontologie, qui ne vérifient rien sur
l'information qui est donnée pour dire
simplement une chose, non, la plainte
n'est pas déposée contre moi, elle est
déposée contrips et aujourd'hui 48 heur
après, vous pourrez vérifier sur le site
de France info, il y a toujours un
article avec un titre explicite :
plainte déposée contre Charlalonque pour
prise illégale d'intérêt. Bah, c'est une
fausse information. et de voir que le
service public de l'information payé par
l'ensemble des Français se permet de
relayer une telle information qui me
diffamme, qui salue, qui salie mon
honneur, qui discrédite les 6 mois de
commission d'enquête au moment le plus
crucial, celui de la révélation du
rapport. Je vous avoue que ça me
conforte dans une chose, c'est qu'il y a
beaucoup de ménages à faire dans
l'audiovisuel public et qu'il faut
arrêter aussi de financer ces
entreprises dans une logique purement
militant. que ces gens-là et des
désaccords sur les recommandations que
je peux proposer qui ne sont que matière
à débat et à réflexion, ce ne sont pas
des injonction, c'est pas force de loi.
C'est simplement là pour éclairer d'une
certaine façon le débat démocratique.
Qu'il soit en désaccord, j'en suis
parfaitement conscient et je l'admets,
c'est d'ailleurs le sens de la
démocratie, mais qui viennent me
diffamer, qui viennent me calomnier, qui
viennent révéler sur leur site en
mettant les moyens publics à leur
disposition pour raconter n'importe quoi
au prétexte que ça salira mon travail.
Je vous avoue qu'avec un peu de recul,
le peu de recul et le peu d'heur que
j'ai par rapport à la diffusion de ces
fausses informations, j'ai beaucoup de
ranqueurs, d'igreur et j'espère qu'un
jour ils ils reconnaîtront leur leurs
erreurs, ils demanderont pardon.
Euh qui demande pardon, c'est bien, mais
que le rédacteur en chef, le média en
question se fasse condamner à des
sanctions pécunières,
c'est envisageable. Autre que des
sanctions de diffamation, c'est-à-dire
un média qui a été pris la main dans le
sac d'une fake news, on lui inflige une
amende systématique, une amende
dissuasive. Vous êtes pour ou contre ?
Et je suis pour parce que le rôle des
médias dans un moment en plus
d'archipélisation totale de la société
et encore plus du paysage audiovisuel.
Je suis un très grand fan de Jérôme
Fourquet. Je trouve que c'est la
personne la plus intéressante. Vous
parlez de Laurent Alexandre qui est
fascinant dans ses propositions
notamment à caractère scientifique.
Jérôme Fourquet est peut-être le
sociologue, je sais pas si se définit
comme un sociologue, mais la personne
l'une des personnes les plus
intéressantes de France, celui qui
décrype le mieux les enjeux profonds de
de de fragmentation de la société
française. Bon, il définit parfaitement
cette archipélisation et à l'issue de
ces 6 mois de commission d'enquête, je
perçois qu'il y a une archipélisation
qui est aussi en cours sur le paysage
audiovisuel. C'est-à-dire que euh en
fait, vous allez avoir tendance à
consommer du contenu médiatique en
fonction de ce que vous votez. Donc vous
allez vous conforter c espèce de cercle
vicieux, vous allez regarder des chaînes
d'information, vous allez consommer du
contenu qui va vous conforter dans vos
choix politiques. Et tout le mérite de
l'audiuel public, c'est au contraire
d'être une forme d'agora qui permet de
continuer de confronter des opinions
divergentes qui donne une expression à
une pluralité d'opinion d'expression de
ligne éditoriale. C'est là tout le
mérite de l'audovisuel public.
dispatoire pour défendre ses ses
opinions, la pluralité d'opinion normal
non
c'est ça et de voir que il y a certains
politiques qui boycottent des chaînes
d'information parce que ces politiques
considèrent que la chaîne d'information
est par exemple trop à droite. Ces news
est boycotté par un certain nombre de de
politiques de gauche. Il y a d'autres
chaînes d'information
et inversement. et inversement.
Exactement. Donc il y a une
archipélisation qui concerne la gauche,
la droite où on ne va plus s'exprimer
que sur des chaînes qui viennent
retranscrire exactement les intentions
et les valeurs de notre parti politique
qui contribue à une archipélisation, qui
contribue à mettre des œillères aussi
sur les les Français. La presse
notamment écrite est de plus en plus
désertée. Donc les Français ne sont plus
abonnés
de façon payante un certain nombre de
titres de presse.
Les compagnies aériennes sont toujours
abonnées. Ça fait toujours vendre des
titres. passer pas une vente, je sais
pas comment on va appeler ça
mais il y a il y a de moins en moins de
rendez-vous pluraliste et donc c'est
aussi tout le mérite et l'honneur de
l'autel public de sanctuariser ça et par
exemple de dire le lundi matin on a une
chronique d'un journaliste de
libération, le mardi c'est le Figaro, le
mercredi c'est les échos, le jeudi c'est
le monde, enfin voilà et donc de voir
que sur ce service public de
l'audiovisuel qui pourtant doit avoir
une mission fondamentale, celle de
vérifier la sincérité de l'information
délivrée parce que le jour où une
information est fausse, le jour où on a
par exemple une personne responsable du
fact shaking sur France 5 et France info
qui s'appelle Linlan Dao qui est tête
d'affiche d'un meeting de la France
insoumise il y a quelques mois à
Toulouse avec le député François Picmal,
ça a été l'une des révélations de cette
commission d'enquête. Cette personne est
chargée du facting quand même, donc de
la vérification de la sincérité de
l'information donnée sur le service
public. Mais c'est une militante qui est
tête d'affiche d'un meeting de la France
insommise. Le jour où le service public
ce de l'information se compromet à ce
type de de d'agenda politique, le jour
où le service public de l'information se
compromet à la diffusion de telles
fausses informations pour discréditer
des partis ou des représentants
politiques, c'est une rupture
fondamentale de confiance à l'égard de
la contribution des français.
Ouvre une parenthèse qui soit de gauche
tête de militant, il est peut-être
totalement intègre.
Non,
la responsable du f shaking. Non, mais
que que la personne soit gauche l'avocat
du diable.
Non, mais vous avez raison. Que la
personne soit de gauche ou que la
personne soit de droite. Et d'ailleurs
vous le verrez dans mon rapport, quand
je dénonce les entors au pluralisme, je
dénonce la sous-représentation chronique
du Rassemblement national et ce qu'on
peut appeler la droite nationale d'un
point de vue général. Par exemple, aux
dernières élections législatives, ce
sont les chiffres de l'Arcom, le temps
de parole consacré à ce qu'on appelle la
droite nationale, en gros le
Rassemblement national. Sur France en
terre, on est à 10 %. Sur France
culture, on est à 11 %. Sur France info,
on est à 15 %.
Mais à quelle heure ? Entre 3 et 5h du
matin.
Non, sur le temps de parole, sur la
période des élections législatives.
Donc, période en plus sanctuarisée
électorale où on doit faire encore plus
attention sur l'attribution du temps de
parole. L'ARCOM euh définit le temps de
parole en fonction de trois critères. Le
résultat, le dernier résultat que vous
avez fait dans les urnes, la place que
vous avez au Parlement, c'est-à-dire la
taille de votre groupe parlementaire et
les sondages qui vous projettent. Ce
sont ces trois critères qui permettent
de définir la bonne affectation de votre
temps de parole. Bon, à l'évidence 10 %
de temps de parole sur France Interre en
pleine période électorale en 2022, c'est
largement insuffisant par rapport à la
nécessité de de l'ARCOM. Donc quand on
voit cette sous-représentation
chronique, c'est en période électorale,
c'est aussi hors période électorale. Le
dernier trimestre 2025, il y a des
chiffres aussi qui sont sortis. On voit
que sur la matinale de France en Terre,
on a que près un peu moins de 15 % de
temps de parole attribué à cette droite
nationale alors que les dernières
élections les ont mis à plus de 33 %,
qu'on a 1/3 de groupes parlementaires à
l'Assemblée et que les prochains
sondages pour l'édition présidentielle
donnent le Rassemblement national à un
peu plus de 35 % au premier tour. Donc
ils sont très loin derrière leurs
obligations de respect des temps de
parole et du pluralisme. et je le
dénonce pour la droite nationale et je
le dis ouvertement, j'appartiens à ce
groupe politique. Mais c'est aussi le
cas pour la France insoumise. La France
insoumise est sousreés de façon
chronique sur bon nombre d'antennes du
service public, en particulier France 2.
Euh alors moi, j'ai essayé de mettre ces
chiffres sur la table. Je vois que la
France enise aussi essaie de se débattre
en réclamant davantage de pluralisme.
J'entends Patrick Cohen et Thomas
Logrand nous expliquer que France inter
par exemple représente le maré centre
droit centre gauche et que ça représente
une forme de social déémocratie même de
progressisme. C'est la directrice
l'ancienne directrice de Franceer Adelle
Vendrette qui est en rupture totale avec
le principe de pluralisme et de
neutralité explique France interre est
une radio résolument progressiste. Donc
je constate, ça ne concerne pas que le
Rassemblement national ou que la droite
nationale. Je constate qu'un certain
nombre de parties quand ils sortent de
la ligne, quand ils déplaisent au
système, quand ils s'attaquent à un
certain nombre d'intérêts de ces gens
qui sont très protégés depuis des années
et qu'on a jamais voulu d'une certaine
façon démasquer, quand on s'éloigne de
la ligne officielle, le fameux maré
centre droit, centre gauche, on est
ostracisé. Et c'est le cas du
Rassemblement national, c'est le cas de
la France insoumise. Moi, j'essaie de
faire toute la lumière de façon la plus
indépendante possible dans le cadre de
mes travaux. Et vous verrez dans le
rapport que j'ai rendu, je ne me fais
pas que l'avocat de cette droite
nationale, je me fais aussi l'avocat de
ces partis de gauche qui sont
sous-représentés et qui en dépit de leur
poids, parce que la France insoumise
aujourd'hui est un parti qui est
important, on voit dans les sondages, on
voit dans les dernières élections, c'est
inadmissible et c'est absolument pas
acceptable que sur les antennes du
service public, il soit autant
sous-représenté. Donc, on voit qu'il y a
un gros problème du pluralisme et de
voir que au-delà du manque de respect du
temps de parole, il y a des fausses
informations qui sont diffusées
allègrement sur le service public pour
discréditer des parlementaires qui
contreviendraient à leurs propres
intérêts. Ça, de la même façon, c'est
indigne aussi du fonctionnement
démocratique.
Survie, on essaie d'être à l'équilibre
parfait, c'est-à-dire qu'on essaie
d'avoir autant de droite, d'extrême
droite, de gauche, d'extrême gauche, de
centre, d'extrême centre. On essaie de
proposer à notre communauté une
diversité d'opinions, même si sur des
opinions qu'il n'aiment pas ou qu'ils
n'entendent pas, pour qu'ils puissent se
faire leur opinion en leur âme et
conscience sur un temps long, en direct,
fact checké en direct.
La question qu'on nous objecte souvent
ou qu'on nous reproche souvent, c'est
attention, toutes les paroles ne se
valent pas. Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
cette phrase souvent brandit en étant
d'art de la vertu par une petite caste
journalistique qui est toutes les
paroles ne se valent pas. On ne donne
pas la parole, on va dire, un mangeur
d'enfant dictateur avec quelqu'un de de
bonton de gauche au centre. Comment ça
se fait que nous on observe le service
public
ne pas représenter en fait tous les
Français ? Est-ce que toutes les paroles
se valent ? Est-ce qu'il faut donner la
parole à tout le monde ?
C'est une très bonne question. C'est une
question qui en plus est délicate et
périlleuse qu'on a essayé de traiter
dans le cadre de cette commission
d'enquête.
En fait, je trouve que répondre non à
cette question, c'est donner un argument
et une justification à une forme de
censure à une forme de déséquilibre à
une forme de rupture très grave
vis-à-vis du pacte démocratique qui est
celle de l'occultation d'un certain
nombre de courants d'opinion.
Moi, je serai toujours dans le camp de
ceux qui refuseront la censure, dans le
camp de la liberté, dans le camp de la
liberté d'expression, de la démocratie
directe, de donner la parole aux gens,
de donner la parole au peuple, de ne de
nostraiser et de ne mettre de côté
aucune parole et aucune proposition. Je
je suis un libéral, mais libéral au sens
pas simplement
défense de certains intérêts économiques
sans contrôle de l'État et et sans
contrôle parlementaire, mais libéral au
sens où je pense que la liberté
d'expression est quelque chose que l'on
doit sacraliser parce que la grande
différence entre une dictature et une
démocratie tient à la place que l'on
peut accorder à des voix, à des paroles,
à des thèses dissonnantes, discordantes
et dissidentes.
Donc à partir du moment où on
sanctuarise ça, d'arriver à une forme
non pas de d'absence de relativisme mais
de condamnation d'une parole dissidente,
c'est déjà dangereux pour le pacte
démocratique. Et on a pu le voir dans le
casadre de cette commission d'enquête.
J'ai interrogé notamment le représentant
du syndicat national des journalistes,
de la société des des journalistes sur
le le cordon sanitaire qui qui était
appliqué en Belgique. Le cordon
sanitaire, c'est quoi en Belgique ? de
ne pas donner les moyens d'expression
sur les chaînes publiques en Belgique à
des représentants de parti qualifié
d'extrême droite. Donc en Belgique, si
vous êtes un représentant d'un parti
qualifié d'extrême droite, vous ne
pouvez pas intervenir sur une antenne du
service public.
L'extrême droite est à combien en
Belgique déjà ?
C'est une bonne question. Je vous avoue
que je suis pas un spécialiste de la
politique belge, mais c'est c'est en
tout cas des partis qui sont importants
mais qui sont ostracisé à hauteur
évidemment de de plus de 10 % mais qui
sont ostracisés par le schéma notamment
d'audiovisuel public. Et c'est une
tentation qui est en train de s'emparer
euh en France alors qu'elle est
absolument illégale. Il y a une loi, la
fameuse loi Léotard dont on a parlé
allègrement qui consacre des principes
d'honnêteté, d'indépendance, de
pluralisme et on voit même que ce sont
devenus des objectifs à valeur
constitutionnels. Le pluralisme euh de
donner la parole à une diversité
d'opinions est devenu un objectif à
valeur constitutionnelle. Donc le devoir
des syndicats de journalistes qui ne
s'en cachent pas, des syndicats même de
journalistes de France Télévision qui
expliquent qu'on ne doit pas donner la
parole à l'extrême droite de voir des
représentants de société de journalistes
expliquer que le modèle belge qui est un
modèle de censure qui est un modèle
illibéral qui est un modèle de rupture
totale démocratique qui assume de plus
en plus qu'il faudrait changer la loi en
France pour éviter de donner la parole à
des partis qui pourtant représentent
plus de de d'un tiers des Français. Moi
ça me dépasse. Est-ce que c'est un
couvercle de cocotte minute sur une
guerre civile latente ?
Ah ben je je crois de façon certaine que
plus on bayonnera les Français, plus on
limitera la liberté d'expression, plus
on imposera aux gens de détourner le
regard d'un certain nombre de sujets. Ce
sera les meilleurs ingrédients, les
meilleurs nutriments pour accélérer ce
qui peut s'apparenter à un face-àface.
Ce que Gérard Colomb expliquait en
quittant le ministère de l'intérieur.
Aujourd'hui, on peut être ensemble.
Demain, on sera face-à face et je vois
aussi aujourd'hui cette archipélisation
française s'exprimer de façon la plus la
plus
la plus exacerbée possible. Donc je
pense au contraire que de libérer la
parole, d'accorder vraiment la place une
pluralité d'opinion, de confronter les
points de vue, de sanctuariser
l'audiovisuel public comme une agora où
toutes les opinions notamment politiques
peuvent s'exprimer, c'est le meilleur
garant de l'unité de la cohésion
nationale. Il y a rien de pire que la
sclérose de pensée, il y a rien de pire
que la censure. Il y a rien de pire que
la disqualification politique. Et même
vous voyez dans les quelques jours qui
ont précédé le vote du rapport, même
dans les quelques minutes qui ont
précédé ce vote, il y avait une majorité
qui était défavorable à la publication
du rapport, ce qui aurait été un
précédent dans l'histoire de la vie
parlementaire. Parce que censurer un
rapport parlementaire, c'était aussi
condamné et censurer l'intégralité des
vidéos, l'intégralité des compte-rendus,
l'intégralité des 70 auditions qu'on a
mené et de voir que des macronistes à la
gauche, ils se sont d'une certa d'une
certaine façon concertés pour empêcher
la publication de ce rapport, il a fallu
4h30 de délibération, de négociation, de
chantage pour réussir à publier ce
rapport. Je trouve que déjà ça pose
question sur la capacité des
représentants à l'Assemblée nationale de
défendre les intérêts des Français. Donc
on le voit que même cette tentative de
censure, cette tentative illibérale et
antidémocratique est même représentée
dans le temple même républicain et de la
démocratie que doit être l'Assemblée
nationale. Donc cette tentative de
censure, cette tentative de
délégitimation et d'attaquer la
démocratie est même aujourd'hui présente
dans l'institution même qui est censée
défendre les intérêts des Français.
l'Assemblée nationale.
Quel type de NGO il y a eu ? Quel type
de d'arrangement il y a eu pour que ça
sorte ? des chantages aussi ridicules
que qu' trancier. Je vais vous donner
trois exemples de sur la forme. J'ai eu
le président de la commission d'enquête
qui donc Jérémy Patrieletus député
macroniste qui pendant 45 minutes a
caparer la parole pour expliquer que il
voyait soi-disant un certain nombre de
calomnie et de mise en cause personnelle
que j'avais pu proférer dans le cadre du
rapport comme des attaques indignes de
l'institution républicaine de
l'Assemblée nationale.
Vous avez proféré des calomnies. Alors,
je lui ai dit, je lui ai dit sur 400
pages de rapport, éclairz-moi, j'ai on
peut je peux encore supprimer des choses
avant la publication de ce rapport.
Dites-moi s'il y a des calomnie, s'il y
a des des des insultes, s'il y a des
mensonges, il faut me dire, je serai
totalement en mesure de de les
supprimer. Donc dit dites-moi. Et donc
le président de Macronisme m'a dit "Bah
oui, dès l'introduçon par exemple, vous
m'attaquez, vous me calomniez et vous me
mettez en cause personnellement."
l'introduction,
on fait pas ça ici hein. Attention,
on fait pas ça. L'introduction, je
l'assume du premier au dernier mot. Je
l'ai rédigé. Elle elle fait 10 pages,
vous l'avez, elle est publique depuis
depuis ce matin. Et donc je creuse, il
me dit "Mais par exemple, vous avez pu
dire que dans l'introduction, j'étais
actuel administrateur de France Méia,
France Méia, CRFI et France 24 que
j'avais été administrateur de Radio
France et de LCP jusqu'en 2024." Et à ce
titre-là, vous me mettez en cause
personnellement.
C'est plutôt une qualité dans le sens ça
montre qu'il connait il connaît le
boulot, qui connaît la profession.
Alors effectivement, il a une expertise
que je ne lui enlève pas mais je lui dis
mais vous voyez très bien que c'est
vrai, c'est factuellement la vérité.
Vous êtes aujourd'hui administrateur de
France Médiamond, vous l'avez été de
Radio France et de LCP jusqu'en 2024.
Quel est le problème ? Il m'a dit "Oui,
mais vous voyez ça met ça me met en
cause dans mon rôle d'impartialité et de
mettre ça dans une introduction de
rapport parlementaire. discrédite la
fonction de président et met en doute
l'impartialité des travaux de
l'Assemblée nationale. J'étais très
surpris dans le jeudi. Donc votre
rapport à la vérité est tel que on
devrait supprimer des éléments factuels
parce qu'ils vous déplaisent. Donc ça a
été le premier chantage engagé par le
président Macronist de la commission qui
a eu le soutien d'une partie de la
totalité même du bloc central qui
représente quand même 1/3 des forces de
l'Assemblée donc 1/3 des forces de cette
commission d'enquête. Donc sans ce tiers
là et si ce tiers s'était opposé à la
publication du rapport, il n'aurait
jamais été publié. Premier chantage.
Deuxème chantage, les mêmes députés
macronistes, le président Macronist de
la commission me dit "Vous avez attaqué
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale."
Encore une fois, je dis "En quoi
aurais-je Bron Pivé macroniste ? En quoi
aurais-je attaqué Yel Brun Pivé ?" Il me
disent "Mais si toujours dans la même
introduction qui est scandaleuse, vous
tapez sous la ceinture, c'est indigne
d'un rapport parlementaire, vous
n'écrivez pas comme un député. Vous ne
respectez pas les codes d'une
institution qui vous dépasse. Vous
diffamez, c'est scandaleux. Vous n'êtes
pas un représentant digne du peuple.
Bon, je leur dis d'accord, qu'est-ce que
j'ai dit de mal sur Yel Bron Piivé ? Il
disent "Bah, vous avez expliqué que le
matin de l'audition de la présidente de
Radio France, elle est allée au micro de
France en Terre dans la matinale de
Benjamin Damel pour vous mettre en
garde, pour vous rappeler à l'ordre et
pour vous dire que vous n'assumiez pas
un rôle correct de rapporteur." C'est
exactement ce que j'ai fait parce que
elle l'a dit au micro de France Inter
Benjamin Damel le matin de l'audition de
la présidente de Radio France, ce qui
est déjà
un affaiblissement total. un hasard,
ce qui est un hasard, mais ce qui
affaiblit considérablement le rôle
d'enquête d'une commission d'enquête de
l'Assemblée nationale et ce qui
outredépasse totalement les prérogatives
d'une présente de l'Assemblée nationale.
Une présence de l'Assemblée nationale,
elle est pas simplement la porte-parole
d'un parti, elle est élue par l'ensemble
des députés. Et à ce titre-là, selon la
Constitution, elle doit garantir les
pouvoirs des parlementaires et notamment
le pouvoir très important d'enquête
d'une commission et d'évaluation des
politiques publiques. Et le fait qu'elle
se compromette sur une antenne objet
même de cette commission d'enquête le
matin de l'audition de la présente de
Radio France sur une antenne de Radio
France pour venir me discréditer et
jeter aussi un trouble, un discrédit sur
l'ensemble des travaux qu'on pouvait
mener. Pour moi, je considérais à
l'évidence comme une entrave et une
entrave inédite. Jamais Philippe Séin,
jamais d'autres président
de l'Assemblée nationale auraient fait
une chose pareille. Bien au contraire,
ils auraient préservé nos pouvoirs
d'enquête, ils auraient pris du recul,
ils auraient appelé les responsables de
ces entreprises publiques Delphin Airnut
et CILV à une forme de neutralité de
devoir de réserve et de coopération avec
ce qu'on pouvait leur demander au titre
de la commission d'enquête. Elle a fait
tout l'inverse donc et j'ai eu le
malheur de le spécifier très
factuellement, très froidement dans
cette introduction de commission
d'enquête de rappeler simplement que
elle était allée au micro de France
interre le matin de l'audition de la
présidente de Radio France et ça a déplu
aux députés macronistes qui ont vécu ça
comme une mise en cause de leur probité,
comme une mise en cause de leur capacité
de défendre les intérêts des Français et
d'assumer leur rôle de parlementaire
d'évaluation des politiques publiques.
Donc je me suis insurgé contre ça. Je
leur ai dit "Mais je n'ai fait que
rappeler la stricte vérité. Vous avez un
problème avec le rapport au réel. Vous
avez un problème avec la vérité mais ils
en ont fait un chantage. Ils m'ont dit
"Si tu ne supprimes pas ces deux
éléments, on votera contre et donc ton
rapport ne sera pas publié et
l'intégralité des travaux de la
commission d'enquête seront censuré."
Donc j'ai fini même si ça m'a dépit plus
et je me suis dit "OK, je vais le
supprimer même si tout ce que j'ai mis
est vrai, mais au moins j'irai en parler
dans les médias et j'irai dénoncer leur
tentative scandaleuses de chantage parce
que pour moi, ce n'est pas digne d'un
fonctionnement parlementaire sain." Donc
voilà, il y a eu ça et puis après donc
ça c'est les deux les deux éléments
qu'on m'a demandé de supprimer et le
troisème et dernier porté sur le fond et
j'étais très ouvert sur le fond. J'ai
présenté pendant près d'une heure
l'ensemble de mes recommandations, il y
en a près de 80. Et j'ai dit à tout le
monde, on a le temps qu'il faut. S'il y
a des recommandations qui ne vous
plaisent pas, s'il y a des contrevérité,
s'il y a des mensonges que vous
identifiez dans les 400 pages,
évidemment je les supprimerai. On a
encore le temps pour ça, le rapport
n'est pas publié, vous me le dites.
Et le seul mensonge qui sont trouvés,
parce que les députés socialistes se
sont agités, m'ont dit "Votre rapport
est truffé de fake news, de diffamation
et de mensonge." Je je leur ai dit,
"Mais dites-moi, dites-moi quels sont
les mensonges sur ces 400 pages.
Peut-être qu'effectivement il y a une ou
deux controyérités qui ont pu passer. Le
président, Macronic de la commission ne
m'a accordé que 10 jours pour rédiger
mon rapport, ce qui est inédit.
D'habitude, on accorde 1 mois et demi au
rapporteur en fin de commission sans
audition pour rédiger son rapport. Moi,
je n'ai eu que 10 jours. Je leur ai dit
peut-être qu'il y a quelques contre
vérité, montrez-les moi et si jamais
évidemment je les supprime, je m'y
engage. Et donc là, une député, madame
Adizadé, député socialiste, me dit "J'ai
relevé un mensonge mais qui est
grossier, c'est que vous osez citer un
sondage toujours dans l'introduction de
ce rapport." Je vous invite à lire les
10 pages d'introduction parce que
visiblement, elles ont beaucoup fait
parler. Il me dit "Il a un mensonge, je
dis "D'accord, lequel me dit "Vous citez
un sondage." Effectivement, je cite un
sondage. J'explique que 60 % des
Français selon un sondage de novembre
2025 par qui ? Comment ? Payer, comment
? Quelle méthodologie ?
Alors voilà, mais c'est là tout le
point, vous avez raison, fait par le
CSA. Je cite sondage du CSA novembre
2025 60 % des Français considèrent
l'information délivrée sur le service
public deel comme une information qui
n'est pas impartiale. Et donc elle me
dit voilà vous avez cité profonge. Je
dis bah oui j'ai cité ce sondage je l'ai
sourcé figure en note de bas de page je
me suis pas trompé c'est la bonne date.
Elle me dit mais le CSA appartient à
Avas. Est-ce que vous savez à qui
appartient Avas ? Je dis bah non je je
honnêtement je ne savais pas à qui
appartenait à Vas. Vous avez une Rolex ?
Non, j'ai une lip en plus. Ah France,
bien vu. Celle du général,
c'est une lipe Himalaya à laquelle je
tiens énormément. C'est une magnifique
entreprise française.
Et vous avez le droit de dire on
embrasse Besançon.
On embrasse Besançon parce que c'est
effectivement là où où le redressement
de cette entreprise a eu lieu et vous
voyez en plus elle s'est arrêté. Non,
elle donne plus l'heure, elle s'est
arrêté en pleine commission d'enquête.
J'ai toujours pas eu le temps d'aller la
réparer mais j'adore cette marque et si
on peut faire un peu de publicité pour
cette marque française et
toutes les autres marques françaises de
montre
monde mais celle-ci pas
comme de penselles ou quelque chose
d'autre.
Alors ça je ne la connais pas. Je vous
avoue que je suis pas un je suis pas un
fanatique de de montrer d'horlogerie
mais celle-là me convient très bien et
je la trouve très fanatique de la
France. C'est le principal.
C'est le principal effectivement. Euh et
donc effectivement euh à ce moment-là,
j'ignore que le CSA appartient au groupe
Avas et que le groupe Avas était tenu
visiblement, alors je sais pas si c'est
en minorité ou en majorité par le groupe
Bolloré. Et donc j'ai eu le malheur de
citer un sondage du CSA parce que en
fait monsieur Bolloré était actionnaire
du CSA, je ne pouvais pas diffuser ce
sondage et c considéré comme un mensonge
et comme une fake news. Donc ça vous dit
aussi le rapport à la vérité de ces
députés-là. Comme j'ai évidemment explic
n'allait pas supprimé
où la probité des instituts de sondage.
Alors, il faudrait je crois qu'il y a
une commission d'enquête d'ailleurs qui
a été réalisé sur et c'est d'ailleurs un
sujet important le sujet des sondages
dans l'altération de l'opinion notamment
à mesure qu'on s'approche de grandes
échanges électorales. C'est un vrai
sujet. Je crois que c'est la France
insoumise qui avait décidé de de
provoquer une commission d'enquête pour
vérifier la sincérité des méthodes de
sondage faites et je crois que c'est une
bonne idée de la France insommise. Je
crois que c'est très important d'aller
vérifier parce que il peut y avoir aussi
une manipulation de l'opinion sur un
certain nombre de sondages d' se
qualifier certaines opinions politiques,
certains candidats, en mettre en
évidence d'autres qui ne reposent sur
aucune adhésion populaire. Donc
effectivement, je je ne pas le caractère
important d'aller vérifier aussi les
méthodes de cet institut de sondage,
mais j'avais pour seul tort de relayer
un sondage du CSA et voilà, ça a été vu
comme le seul mensonge de ce rapport qui
fait 400 pages. J'ai décidé évidemment
de le maintenir parce que pour moi c'est
je je ne faisais que que rappeler un
fait. Et le tout dernier point sur
lequel on m'a attaqué et pour le coup,
j'ai aussi fait preuve d'ouverture sur
les 80 recommandations que j'ai
présenté. Il y en a une qui a déplu à
quelques parlementaires. C'est alors
c'est un peu technique, c'est un levier
fiscal, la C2I qui permet au réalisateur
de cinéma étranger de venir en France et
à ce titre-là pour faire un certain
nombre de films de fiction en France et
de bénéficier d'un crédit d'impôt. Quand
vous êtes réalisateur étranger, que vous
venez filmer vos réalisations en France,
vous bénéficiez d'un crime d'impôt, je
considérais que la France est un pays
tellement magnifique, inépuisable de
richesse, de paysage touristique,
culturel, qu'on se suffisait, qu'on
avait pas besoin d'activer un leusier
fiscal pour attirer des grands
réalisateurs étrangers. Donc, je
proposais pour des motifs d'économie, ça
pouvit représenter 125 millions d'euros
d'économie par an, de supprimer ce
levier fiscal. Il y a un certain nombre
de députés qui me disaient "On est
membre de la commission des finances, ça
pourrait avoir plus d'impact que ce seul
levier fiscal. Vous avez pas vraiment
compris tous les tenants et les
aboutissants de cette réduction d'impôt
?" Et voilà, j'ai dont j'ai expliqué que
j'étais pas membre de la commission des
finances, que j'avais peur peu d'heur de
vol politiqu à mon actif, que
probablement qu'ils étaient plus
techniques et compétents que moi sur ce
sujet. Je leur ai dit donc j'en ai
appelé à la sagesse des groupes
parlementaires. Il y a plusieurs groupes
parlementaires qui m'ont dit non
effectivement c'est une mesure qui est
périeuse et qui serait nuisible aussi
pour l'écosystème de de l'audiovisuel.
Et donc j'ai accepté de retirer cette
recommandation. Mais voilà tout ça pour
vous dire sur ces 4h30 de longues
discussions et débats pour savoir si on
allait voter ou pas pour le rapport de
pour la publication du rapport. J'ai
consenti à ces deux modifications de
forme qui étaient pour moi des chantages
parce qu'il disaient strictement la
vérité et à cette modification de fond
qui avait l'air d'être étayé et qui
traduisait probablement une mesure
technique que j'avais mise dans le
rapport qui était pas forcément la plus
appropriée. Donc c'était normal aussi
que je revienne sur cette mesure.
J'ouvre une parenthèse sur le dispositif
fiscal pour attirer des grands
réalisateurs pour mettre la France à
l'image un peu partout dans le monde.
Regardez, on a tourné mission impossible
sur l'éliiport de Bery. Euh l'éliiport
qui ne sert strictement à rien parce que
il était mal fait, on peut jamais se
poser, ainsi de suite. C'est pas
extraordinaire. Et à Mission Impossible,
Tom Cruise qui arrive, euh Légion
d'honneur, ça fait de la bonne pub. Ça
fait un budget de 128 millions d'euros
pour rayonner à l'étranger. C'est une
bonne idée.
Oui. Alors, initialement, je considérais
que on avait tellement de capacités,
notamment d'attraction culturelle,
patrimoniale, de paysage. En France, on
a Paris, on a la Clo d'Azur, on a la
Bourgogne, on a Je sais que vous êtes
attaché à la Bourgogne, on a bien
d'autres, on a la Bretagne, on a
beaucoup d'autres régions magnifiques
qui pour moi se suffisaient pour attirer
des réalisateurs étrangers. Après voilà,
c'est un logique official, c'est une
réduction d'impôts. Si demain ça peut
contribuer à attirer encore plus de
réalisateurs que Emiline Paris, Restin
Paris et que d'autres séries à gros
budget notamment Netflix et bien
d'autres plateformes puissent
s'implanter en France si elle profite
d'un lie. Voilà, moi j'étais pas
forcément très aligné avec ça. Je
pensais que on était un pays totalement
autosuffisant sur la question. Il y a
plusieurs parlementaires qui m'ont
indiqué que ça pouvait risquer un
déséquilibre sur l'écosystème
audiovisuel. Encore une fois, ça a été
une condition qui a été posée pour la
publication du rapport. J'entendais
leurs arguments. Je voulais absolument
pas être sourd parce que le but d'un
rapport, il est approuvé par l'ensemble
des membres de la commission d'enquête.
C'est aussi qu'il traduisent les
aspirations de plusieurs groupes
politiques. C'est pas simplement mon
rapport, c'est le rapport de l'ensemble
de la commission d'enquête et donc
d'entendre aussi les remarques, les
critiques et les propositions
d'amendement de l'ensemble des groupes
politiques. Pour moi, c'était la moindre
des choses.
Vous connaissez les Liport de Bercy ?
Je le vois. Je vois parfois quand je
passe sur la ligne 6 et que je vais gard
pour rentrer chez moi. Mais euh non, j'y
suis jamais allé. Ouais,
le point de vue est magnifique.
C'est vrai, j'imagine.
On a eu la chance de visiter le point de
vue magnifique. Mais il y a pas beaucoup
d'hélicoptères qui se posent. Euh, je
suis désolé, il y a ma grand-mère de 103
ans qui m'appelle. Mamie, je te rappelle
après. Désolé.
C'était son anniversaire ?
C'était son anniversaire. Vous pouvez
lui souhaiter son anniversaire 103 ans.
Quel chose
? Magnifique. Mamie. Je t'aime. On a
tous envie d'arriver à cet âge là.
Revenons, revenons à la commission
d'enquête. Donc nous, on vous suit
depuis à peu près 6 mois. Comme vous le
savez, on a été je pense le premier à
s'intéresser à vous.
On s'est mis en retrait pour pas
interférer
dans la commission. Donc, on a refusé de
on a accepté de de pas vous prendre tout
de suite en émission. Mais vous vous
nous avez dit qu'on vous a conseillé ou
qu'on vous a interdit de venir vous
exprimer dans les formats longs qui
rentrent dans dans le détail. C'était
quand ? C'était par qui ?
Alors, c'était une forme de censure
évidente qui ne respectait en rien le
règlement et la loi qui régit
commissions d'enquête. Et c'est une
mesure qui a été imposée par le
président de la commission d'enquête
Jérémy Patrilus qui je crois souffrait
beaucoup d'une transparence des travaux
que j'avais souhaité dès le premier jour
de cette commission d'enquête. Parce que
je considère que la France aujourd'hui,
notre vie démocratique souffre d'une
absence de démocratie directe. On a
confié la parole, la décision,
l'expression souveraine des Français aux
mains de quelques-uns qui parce qu'ils
ont été élus, parce qu'ils sont nommés à
la tête d'institution ou d'entreprise
publiques, s'arroge une légitimité par
le diplôme, par le portefeuille, par un
certain nombre de d'attributs purement
sociaux. Il s'accorde une légitimité
supérieure à l'expression populaire.
Moi, c'est quelque chose que je récuse
et si j'entends une chose, si j'entends
poursuivre un destin et un objectif dans
le cadre de l'exercice de mon mandat,
c'est celui de rendre la souveraineté de
la décision aux français. C'est la
première fois que je menais une
commission d'enquête. C'est d'ailleurs
la première fois tout court que je
participais à une commission d'enquête.
Et pour moi, c'était la moindre des
choses de faire la transparence et de
prendre à témoin les Français dès la
toute première audition parce que tous
les Français contribuent à le public par
le biais de la TVA depuis la suppression
de la redevance. Tous les Français
contribuent qu'ils disposent d'une
télévision, d'une radio, qu'ils
consomment des contenus de l'audiel
public ou non. Et donc à ce titre-là,
ils sont tous coactionnaires, ils
doivent tous être codécisionnaires de
cette audiel publique. Donc, j'ai fait
ce choix de la totale transparence de
mettre davantage de démocratie directe.
Ça m'a été reproché parce que
instantanément, c'était la première fois
à l'Assemblée nationale qu'on faisait
une commission d'enquête sur le dos deel
public sur les réseaux sociaux. Ça a été
fulgurant. dès la première audition du
patron de l'ARCOM, monsieur Heddari, que
personne n'avait vraiment vu à qui
beaucoup de personnes de gens avaient
des questions. Pourquoi par exemple
Daniel Conbendit, ERC Dupon Moretti,
Rosine Bachelot, Matthieu Pigas se sont
pas considérés comme des personnalités
politiques ? Pourquoi Philippe Deviler
mais il y en a d'autres sont considérés
comme des personnalités politiques ?
Pourquoi il y a des militants qui sont
nommés à l'Arcom comme par exemple
monsieur Foued Berou qui demande sur ses
réseaux sociaux public à l'été 2024 une
mobilisation indigéniste antifasciste
contre l'Empire Bolloré et qui un an
après est nommé à Larcom. C'est un
certain nombre de questions et je vous
cite des questions peut-être orientées.
Il y a d'autres questions aussi sur le
pluralisme et sur le respect des temps
de parole d'un certain nombre de groupes
de gauche comme de droite. Tous les
Français voulaient poser ces questions.
Donc dès cette première audition, le
fait de publier ses travaux sur les
réseaux sociaux, le fait de publier les
questions, de publier les réponses,
l'intérêt a été fulgurant. Tout de
suite, j'étais pas connu. J'avais, je
crois, sur Twitter 5000 followers. Sur
Instagram, c'était peut-être 8000 ou
9000. C'était quand même assez
insignifiant sur TikTok. Je vous raconte
même pas. Je comprends rien de TikTok.
Mon équipe non plus. Je pense que je
suis déjà catégorisé dans dans dans la
catégorie boomer parce que je je ne
comprends pas ce ce réseau social. Mais
du jour au lendemain, en publiant
simplement les questions et les
réponses, en faisant la transparence sur
nos travaux, l'intérêt a été fulgurant.
Il y a eu beaucoup plus d'aponnés. Et
donc quelques semaines après, le
président macroniste, il a pris ombrage,
a considéré que c'était une entrave
scandaleuse à l'exercice de la vie
parlementaire, à la probité et
l'indépendance des travaux d'une
commission d'enquête. Et donc ça lui a
pas plu parce que évidemment ça mettait
en difficulté les intérêts de
quelques-uns, les intérêts de société de
production qui profitaient de centaines
de millions d'euros de contrats passés
avec France Télévision depuis des
années. Ça mettait en cause des intérêts
de dirigeants de l'audis public qui
étaient assis de façon confortable dans
leur petite prébande et prérogative
depuis des années. Ça mettait en cause
des animateurs producteurs aussi qui
n'avaient jamais été inquiétés depuis
les années 90, depuis la fameuse affaire
des animateurs producteurs révélé par
une mission parlementaire qui avait mené
à la démission de Jean-Pierre Elk
Cabache, qui avait mené à la
condamnation pour favoritisme de France
Télévision et de la société de Nagi.
Donc il a fallu attendre 35 ans pour
rebraquer un projecteur sur ses dérives
et ses conflits d'intérêt. Donc le
président de la commission d'enquête
macroniste qui visiblement voulait aussi
défendre les intérêts de ces gens-là a
pris ombrage et c'est
ça c'est de la supputation.
Bon vous savez quand on est
administrateur de Radio France
administrateur de LCP jusqu'en 2024
qu'on est actuel administrateur de
France Méia monde et qu'on met autant de
ailes à vouloir mettre le couvercle sur
des travaux qui passionnent et qui
intéressent les Français alors que c'est
totalement autorisé de le diffuser sur
les réseaux sociaux. Quand on met autant
de ziles à vouloir censurer les travaux
d'un rapporteur, c'est à penser en tout
cas qu'on peut être jugé parti. Ça ne
regarde que moi. CP qui est une très
bonne chaîne qu'on regarde assidument
et le CP en plus qui diffusait, vous
avez raison, qui diffusait les travaux
depuis le premier jour. Il y a d'autres
chaînes YouTube qui les a diffusé.
C'était évidemment pas interdit au
contraire de faire la publicité de ces
travaux. Moi j'assume de l'avoir fait.
Et donc début janvier, même fin
décembre, le président explique que ça
va trop loin, que d'une certaine façon
les Français sont trop intéressés à ces
travaux, que c'est en train de dépasser
le cadre d'une commission d'enquête et
qu'il faut restreindre la publicité de
ces travaux. Donc il suspend les
auditions. C'est la première fois dans
l'histoire d'une commission d'enquête à
l'Assemblée qu'un président sans
convoquer le bureau de la commission
d'enquête, sans obtenir un vote, décide
de lui-même en rupture totale de ses
prérogatifs. Pour ne pas dire en abus de
pouvoir, c'est la première fois qu'il
décide unilatéralement de suspendre les
auditions pendant plus d'un mois. Alors
qu'une commission d'enquête, comme
toutes les commissions d'enquête, euh
n'ont que 6 mois d'existence. vous ne
pouvez pas aller plus loin, il y a aucun
motif qui justifie une prolongation de
commission d'enquête. Donc il décide de
mettre en place cette restriction, la
suspension sinédié des de la convocation
et des auditions et il nous réunit, il
explique si vous voulez qu'on reprenne
les auditions, il faudra qu'on fasse une
diète médiatique. Le rapporteur le
premier qu'il arrête de raconter, de
parler des révélations dans la presse,
qu'il arrête de mettre en lumière ses
travaux et qu'on interdise le live
tweet. Voilà, ça c'est été une autre
condition du président de la commission
d'enquête. Le live tweet, c'est quoi en
direct ?
C'est le tweet en direct. C'est dans le
cadre d'une audition qui est diffusé
pourtant sur LCP qui est diffusé sur
nombre de chaînes YouTube que mes
équipes, c'était évidemment pas moi, je
m'occupais de poser les questions, je
suis rapporteur, j'avais autre chose à
faire en pleine audition que d'aller
diffuser les extraits sur les réseaux
sociaux. C'était mon équipe qui le
faisait dans ce souci de transparence et
pour aussi engager les Français. Et donc
il explique que c'est un dévoiement
d'une commission d'enquête de live
tweeté. J'étais pas le seul à le faire.
Il y avait d'autres députés de la
commission d'enquête de gauche comme de
droite qui le faisaient avec leurs
équipes. C'est assez courant à
l'assemblée quand vous posez une
question au gouvernement.
Vos équipes sont là pour publier votre
question en direct que vous posez dans
l'hémicycle. Quand vous participez à un
débat budgétaire, vous défendez un
amendement, votre équipe va publier en
direct. La question que vous posez,
c'est la moindre des choses.
Est-ce que je peux me faire l'avocat du
diable ? Allez-y, allez-y.
Merci bien.
Ça peut être aussi pris pour influence
sur la [grognement] la commission. Vous
connaissez les réseaux sociaux, ça peut
monter hors de contexte une question, on
met pas la réponse ou on met juste la
réponse de la question. Ça peut être
considéré aussi comme une démarche
consciente ou inconsciente d'influencer
l'opinion publique sur la question ou
sur la réponse.
Vous avez raison. Et c'est aussi pour ça
que il faut toujours s'astreindre à
publier la question. à publier la
réponse et même les médias quand vous
posez une question au gouvernement le
mardi ou le mercredi, vous avez 2
minutes de temps de question et le
gouvernement a 2 minutes pour vous
répondre. Si c'est le premier ministre,
il peut répondre autant qu'il le
souhaite. Ça dépasse généralement 2
minutes. Et à la fin, les médias vont
pas publier dans le journal de 20h,
c'est une question intéressante, ils
vont pas publier les 2 minutes de
questions et les 2 minutes de réponse.
Ils vont faire des coupes. Ils vont
publier le moment le plus important dans
la question et le moment le plus
important dans la réponse. Ce qui
compte, c'est que il y a un
contradictoire. Donc moi, mes équipes
depuis le début, contrairement à ce que
j'ai pu lire, contrairement à beaucoup
de fausses informations qui ont circulé
pour me discréditer, ont toujours
publier les réponses aux questions que
je posais sur une vingtaine de questions
que je pouvais poser pour chaque
audition. Évidemment qu'ils ont pas
publié les 20 questions parce que
humainement c'est impossible de faire
autant de travail sur les réseaux
sociaux. Ils ont publié sur une
vingtaine, ils ont publié peut-être 10
ou 12 avec à chaque fois les réponses
qui étaient publiées. Mais bon, ça ça
n'a pas plu au président de la
commission d'enquête qui voyait que
l'intérêt des Français était fulgurant,
que le nombre de retweet était massif.
Moi aussi, je vous avoue que je vous
l'ai dit, j'étais inconnu euh totalement
du grand public. Je venais d'être élu.
J'avais pas l'habitude de cette
exposition sur les réseaux sociaux. Mais
j'ai tout de suite vu que les questions
que je pouvais poser intéressaient les
Français, que les réponses aussi qui a
été diffusées intéressaient les
Français. Et je me suis dit mais de voir
un tel intérêt, il faut continuer, il
faut continuer à faire la publicité de
ces travaux. Bon, on nous a un peu coupé
les ailes. Quelques semaines seulement
après le début de la commission, le
président nous a convoqué, a suspendu
l'envoi des auditions convocation, nous
a dit "Si vous voulez qu'on reprenne les
travaux alors qu'il n'en avait pas le
droit, on arrête les live tweet alors
que il le faisait lui-même et d'autres
députés le le faisaient aussi eux-mêmes.
Vous ne pourrez tweeter qu'une fois les
auditions terminées et on s'impose une
diète médiatique."
médiatique, c'est on fait moins de
médias, on vient moins parler de la
commission d'enquête, on vient moins
exposer les révélations.
Aucun règlement, aucune loi euh
n'autorise ce genre de de de censure et
d'inter. N'importe quel député qui soit
rapporteur, président ou membre d'une
commission d'enquête a le droit d'aller
s'exprimer dans les médias et a le droit
d'exposer sur ses réseaux sociaux. Je je
n'ai contrevenu à aucune loi ou aucun
règlement de l'Assemblée nationale. Mais
pourtant le président a imposé ça et je
me suis dit au nom quand même du du fond
des travaux pour poursuivre aussi cette
mission importante d'aller braquer le
projecteur sur les dérives et les
défaillances de l'audiovisuel public
pour proposer des recommandations et
pour mieux les résoudre parce que c'est
tout le but que j'ai poursuivi depuis le
début. Je n'ai jamais été l'agent de la
privatisation que le président a voulu
me prêter depuis le début de la
commission cas. Depuis le premier jour,
j'ai toujours dit que je tenais aux
missions importantes de l'audis public
et que pour moi la seule façon de les
résoudre, la seule façon de redresser
les comptes, la seule façon de garantir
davantage de pluralisme, la seule façon
d'assaignir les pratiques de ces
entreprises, c'était de mettre en
lumière d'une certa d'une certaine façon
leur leur turpitude, de les mettre en
lumière de façon inédite. Bon, pour moi,
je trouvais ça assez regrettable qu'on
ne puisse pas faire preuve d'une grande
transparence. Donc, j'ai consenti à ces
interdictions au nom de la reprise des
travaux de la commission d'enquête, mais
je regrette et je le déplore, je vois
que le président ne s'est pas imposé
lui-même ces objectifs là. Moi, vous
voyez, depuis le mois de janvier, début
janvier où on nous a imposé cette diète
médiatique, jusqu'à la fin de la
commission d'enquête, en tout cas
jusqu'à la remise du rapport, j'ai fait
une télé, c'était les grandes gueules,
si on peut dire que c'est une télé. J'ai
fait une matinale
RMC, c'est ça ? RMC, j'ai fait une
matinale, c'était la matinale d'Europin
et j'ai dû participer à une autre télé,
pardon, c'était BFM face à Consignie sur
la commission d'enquête. Donc en
l'espace de plus de 3 mois, j'ai dû
faire trois interventions médiatiques
télé et radio alors qu'on expliqué que
j'étais matin, midi et soir sur ces
news. Ces news, je ne l'ai fait qu'une
seule fois de toute la commission
d'enquête et pourtant il y a une espèce
de fausse information qui a circulé. il
est sur C News matin, midi et soir. Je
n'ai répondu qu'à une seule invitation
de C News. Au moment où le rapport est
voté, je réserve euh ma première
intervention médiatique, c'était la
semaine dernière, non pas à C News mais
à BFM.
Alors que normalement c'était chez nous
d'ailleurs hein.
Alors c'était évidemment alors je vous
avais dit que je vous révélerai mes
recommandations au moment de la
publication du rapport. Le rapport a été
publié ce matin. On est cet après-midi
chez vous, chez Tinkerview. Il y a une
semaine quand le vote a été fait, je
pouvais pas m'exprimer sur le contenu du
rapport. Je devais attendre la
publication. C'est aussi pour ça que je
suis pas venu aussi rapidement chez
vous.
J'ouvre une parenthèse. Rendons à César.
Ce qui est à César. Je tiens à à
remercier personnellement Sarah Nafo qui
m'a indiqué qu'il y avait une commission
sur l'audiovisuel qui se lançait et
comme elle sait que je suis très frant
médias et comment les médias sont nous
scultés de la charte de Munique et de
tout un tas de choses, je tiens à la
remercier parce que ça a été meilleur
que la série Netflix le la diplomate que
je vous je recommande d'ailleurs à tout
le monde qui rentre simplement
en surface sur le le boulot de diplomat
et des renseignements, mais très très
bien pour se sensibiliser ce genre de
choses. Donc merci Sarah Knafo de
d'avoir éclairé Charles à l'oncle auprès
de nos oreilles et nos yeux. On a passé
de très très bons moments. 70 auditions.
Combien ?
70 250 heures d'audition et à peu près
230 personnes qui ont été auditionnées.
Vous nous avez bien fatigué Charles.
J'ai vu qu'on vous avait attaqué parce
que Charles c'est pas votre prénom
entier. C'est quoi votre Charles ?
Mon vrai prénom c'est Charles Henry.
Et ben c'est un très beau prénom.
Pourquoi vous l'utilisez pas ?
Et alors je je l'assume totalement. Je
crois que Nagi et Xavien Nielal ont
voulu me mettre en défaut. Alors c'était
une grande révélation qu'ils ont faite
parce que j'avoue que j'ai eu beaucoup
de médias notamment de Monsieur Niel qui
ont été à mes basques pendant l'ensemble
de la commission d'enquête. Par exemple,
j'ai eu une enquête sur mes
collaborateurs. Je vous vois raconter
ça, je jamais raconté. Donc on s'est
intéressé à ma vie privée, on s'est
intéressé à mon prénom. Alors, on a
trouvé des scandales. Un petit peu de
fesse, un peu de drogue, un peu de
détournement de fond, de fraude fiscale
ou
alors on a trouvé des scandales. Ou on a
trouvé des scandales. Bon, le premier
scandale, c'est je m'appelle pas
Charles, je m'appelle Charles Henri.
Bon, c'est des fins liés, c'est vraiment
des bons enquêteurs parce que ils ont
raison. Je m'appelle pas Charles, je
m'appelle Charles Henri. Euh ma famille
m'appelle Charles, mes amis m'appellent
Charles Henry. Et le jour où il a fallu
choisir, je j'ai plutôt préféré Charles
mais j'assume totalement ce prénom là,
mais Nagi sur le plateau de quotidien le
lendemain de son audition
a estimé que c'était croustillant de
d'expliquer que je m'appelais Charles
Henry, mais il a totalement raison. Et
après, j'ai eu d'autres d'autres
enquêtes et d'autres révélations. C'est
celle sur mes collaborateurs parce qu'on
s'en est pris à défaut d'avoir des
casseroles sur moi. Ils ont cherché, ils
ont fouillé hein pendant à peu près 3
mois. Ils ont remué beaucoup de choses.
Mes réseaux sociaux, ils sont allés voir
sur mon compte Facebook si j'avais pas
des commentaires, des publications, des
likes qui pouvaient remonter à il y a 15
ans. Voilà. Bon, ils ont rien trouvé. Et
euh ils sont allés voir mes
collaborateurs. Donc un jour, je reçois
un appel [grognement] de Street Press.
Je sais pas si vous connaissez. en
street press, c'est ça pour très
objectivement hein, je pense qu'on peut
tous le définir comme un média en ligne
d'extrême gauche. Et donc, il me
contacte en me disant "On a des
révélations à faire sur vos
collaborateurs. Notre enquête très
étayée qui fera une dizaine de pages
sera publiée demain à la première heure.
Vous avez 2 heures pour nous répondre.
Il y a des faits à Cablon, il faut nous
rappeler."
J'étais en pleine commission d'enquête,
je vois ce message, ça devait être
pareil un dimanche de la même façon. Je
rappelle la personne de Street Press. Je
rappelle euh là, on a 1 heure de
conversation, je leur dis "Bon bah,
expliquez-moi qu'est-ce que vous avez
trouvé sur mes collaborateurs ?" J'avais
l'impression d'être Raphaël Arnaud au
lendemain de de l'assassinat de de du
pauvre Quentin. Euh, j'avais vraiment
l'impression de de de en tout cas d'être
dans la même peau de quelqu'un qui avait
quelque chose de grave à se reprocher
notamment du point de vue de ses
collaborateurs. Enfin, vraiment
honnêtement, j'étais mis sur le grill et
bon, je je j'avais toute confiance en
mes collaborateurs, mais parfois vous
dites peut-être quelque chose qui qui
un vendredi soir un peu bourré
et vous dites peut-être qu'il y a un
vrai truc. Et donc Street Press,
journaliste de Street Press m'appelle,
il disent il m'explique "Oui, alors
effectivement c'est c'est quand même
quelque chose de grave. Je vais vous
demander la plus grande sincérité et la
plus grande vérité. De toute façon, je
retranscrirai tout ce que vous
m'expliquez dans ce dans ce dans cette
enquête qui sera publiée demain."
C'est honnête, c'est honnête.
C'est honnête. Et je dis "Bon, allez-y,
expliquez-moi, j'ai trois
collaborateurs, dites-moi." Et la
personne me dit "Bon, est-ce que vous
confirmez que monsieur Intel est votre
collaborateur ?" Je dis bah oui, c'est
mon collaborateur. Est-ce que vous
confirmez qu'il travaille avec vous
depuis un an ? Je dis oui, il travaille
avec moi depuis un an. Est-ce que vous
confirmez, c'était ça la grande
révélation, qu'il a été au scout
d'Europe ?
Quoi ?
Au scoutot d'Europe ? Voilà.
Scoutot unitaire, euh je
non, c'est scout d'Europe. Alors, il y a
différents types de scout. Alors en
plus, elle s'est trompé parce que j'ai
vérifié avec lui. Je l'ai rappelé juste
après, je lui dit "Tu étais au scout
d'Europe ?" Il me dis "Ouais, j'étais au
scout mais c'est pas le scoot d'Europe.
Je crois qu'il était au scout unitaire
de France ou au scout de France. Je
jamais été le scoot mais je j'aurais
aimé d'ailleurs scoot, ça m'aurait rendu
un peu plus débrouillard et un peu plus
manuel.
J'aurais plus vu Loufto mais non, je je
suis pas très manuel et je pense que mes
parents ont eu tort de pas me mettre au
scout. Ça m'aurait un peu déniaisé un
peu plus tôt si je puis m'exprimer
ainsi. Et donc grande révélation, on
m'explique voilà est-ce que votre
collaborateur a bien été au scoot
d'Europe ? Je dis bon je le connais, il
est plutôt câau. Je crois qu'il a été
chez les scout de là à vous dire que
c'était les scoot d'Europe. Oui,
probablement que c'était SC. Dit mais
vous vous rendez compte, vous avez
embauché un collaborateur qui a été au
scoot d'Europe ? Je dis bah oui, pardon.
Est-ce que c'est une une organisation
terroriste ? Est-ce que c'est une
organisation interdite par la loi ? Elle
me dit "Mais non, mais c'est grave quand
même, c'est une organisation catholique
et identitaire." Je dis "Bon bah, ça
c'est votre appréciation." Mais oui,
effectivement, est-ce que vous avez
d'autres révélations ? Oui, j'ai une
autre révélation sur votre autre
collaboratrice. Elle me cite le nom de
la personne. C'est une collaboratrice
qui n'a fait que 3 mois auprès de moi
parce que pour un certain nombre de
raisons, on s'est séparé avant la la
période à la Rodol et elle travaillait
pour moi à mi-temps et là on me dit il
paraît qu'elle a rédigé pour la revue
alors de mémoire j'ai essayé de vous
dire pour la revue ictus
c'est quoi ? Elle a elle a rédigé alors
je connaissais pas la revue, je dis donc
là ictus en plus vous dites merde ça ça
sonne pas très bon ictus j'espère que
c'est pas un truc et en plus j'avais
tout toute confiance en elle donc je je
suis dit bah je j'en sais rien mais
dites-moi qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
revue euh si elle a rédigé bon bah si
vous avez la preuve elle a dû rédiger
dans cette revue je vais pas vous le
nier me dit bah c'est une revue qui se
présente comme une revue catholique et
fière d'être française. Bon je crois que
c'est ça. Puis bon d'accord. Oui,
probablement qu'elle a enfin j'en sais
rien mais elle a peut-être rédigé dans
cette revue là. Bon, j'ai appelé
elle a rédigé quoi ?
Bah, elle a rédigé des articles pour
cette ou mais c'était des des articles
de quoi ? C'était des recettes de
cuisine, c'était des recettes
politiques, c'était des articles
géopolitiques d'économie ou c'était des
articles, des tribunes ?
Je crois que c'est des articles
d'actualité. Mais donc du coup, parce
que je vous avoue que je lui ai dit,
bon, vous m'apprenez cette nouvelle.
Après avoir accroché, j'ai appelé cette
collaboratrice qui ne travaillait plus
pour moi, qui a travaillé que 3 mois
pour moi, qui était une étudiante qui
faisait ça en plus à mi-temps, qui était
étudiante, je crois elle était à la
Sorbonne ou elle était droit combien
mal payé. Mal payé parce que alors mal
payé pardon, mais à l'Assemblée
nationale pour être tout à fait
transparent, vous disposez d'une
enveloppe pour vos collaborateurs de
8500 € net par mois. Vous pouvez monter
jusqu'à 5 collaborateurs et vous devez
diviser évidemment c'est pas c'est
jusqu'à 5 collaborateurs mais une
enveloppe totale. 16000 balles c'est ça
?
Non, j'ai 8500.
Ouais. Mais chargé ou pas chargé ?
Cotisé ou pas cotisé ?
Net. Moi, je compte en net.
Donc vous c'est chargé à combien
assistant de
C'est une bonne question mais en tout
cas c'est 8500 € qui revient sur leur
fiche de paix net. Donc en fait moi ça
m'aide à y voir clair pour savoir
exactement combien il touche à la fin.
J'ai toujours eu du mal avec le brut
puisque le brut et le brut chargé pour
les entreprises sur le jeu.
C'est simple, vous divisez par deux à
peu près.
Donc 8500 € donc vous voyez quand vous
avez moi j'ai quatre collaborateurs dont
une qui était à mi-temps, vous divisez
8500 par allez 3 et demi à peu près. Ça
vous donne le montant exact qui perçoiv
chaque mois. Donc on peut pas dire
contrairement à ce que Lavien nous
explique en expliquant que le coût de
parlementaires est scandaleux, qu'il
faudrait baisser leur dotation. Vous
gagnez combien ?
Moi je gagne, je vais vous dire très
précisément. Sur mon compte bancaire
chaque mois, je perçois 4700 €.
Le compte bancaire français ?
Non, suisse.
Ah, je le savais. Le
Suisse, mais qui est caché et que je
n'ai jamais révélé au fil. Non,
français. Et et euh vous vous occupez de
d'implantation capillaire ? Euh oui euh
ma femme.
Ma femme et je vous le dis droit dans
les yeux d'ailleurs euh comme un certain
ancien ministre qui avait lutté contre
la fraude fiscale et qui droit dans les
yeux vous disait qu'il ait pas de
content suisse.
C'est votre femme
euh qui s'occupe de l'importantation
capillaire effectivement.
Euh donc oui. Non.
Croyez en Dieu.
Je crois en Dieu.
Depuis combien de temps ? Euh
j'ai j'ai un vrai doute évidemment, mais
je pense que le doute, je vais vous
enfoncer une porte ouverte qui va être
catastrophique pour ceux tous ceux qui
ont la foi et qui vont penser que que je
suis un mécréant en enfonçant une telle
porte ouverte. Mais je pense que le
doute est constitutif. Non mais je pense
que
posta Non non mais je je me je me sens
catholique, je crois en Dieu.
J'ai un doute fondamental mais je vous
avoue notamment dans des moments de
tempête personnelle,
de tempête aussi métaphysique de moment
où on a envie de se remettre à une
cause, à un instinct, à une présence, à
un esprit qui nous dépasse. Je vous
avoue qu'il y a une dimension
extrêmement rassurante et au contraire
très rationnelle de s'en remettre à
quelqu'un qui ordonne l'ordre l'ordre
des choses. Et moi, j'ai été baigné dans
une culture catholique. J'ai fait une
bonne partie de ma scolarité dans le
privé. J'étais chez les odistes
chez qui ?
Les pères odistes.
Donc euh c'est c'était un un font
de la bière.
Non, ils font pas de la bière.
C'est peut-être pour ça qu'on les
connaît pas. Ils font pas de la bière
mais ils m'ont inculqué un certain
nombre de de principes et de précepts
que je ne renie pas qui ont été je pense
que je leur doit aussi le fait d'être
devant vous aujourd'hui. Je pense que je
le dois à cette éducation, je le dois à
ces principes peut-être un peu qu'on
peut considérer comme rigide.
Aime ton prochain ?
Ouais. Et puis de faire du catéchisme,
d'aller à la messe, de faire des
pèlerinages, de s'intéresser de
Saint-Paul, c'est quoi
l'ancien de Saint-Paul ? Je sais pas.
Pas fait pas été au courant. pasiez pas
très assu hein donc
la messe elle est en latin chez vous
elle est en français
elle est pas en latin [grognement]
bon ça va alors
elle est pas en latin
en latin en latin c'est pas mal hein
il y a il y a un magnifique livre que je
conseille de de Patrice Buisson je suis
pas d'accord avec toutes ces thèses
notamment ces dernières dans son dans
son dernier livre mais qui explique
notamment que la fin des rites et des
mythes de l'église avec le tournant de
Vatican I a aussi été une sorte de de
rupture et aussi été une explication de
la perte de la foi, de la perte de la
pratique. Si les églises courant enfin
en tout cas à l'oré des années 60 et 70
ont commencé à être vidé parce queon a
perdu ces rites populaires et même ces
pratiques qui pouvaient apparaître
mystérieuses pour bon nombre de croyants
notamment en France qui pouvaient se
confondre avec un certain nombre de de
faites aussi populaires qui pouvaient se
confondre avec du paganisme. Le fait
d'avoir fait disparaître ces rites peu
compréhensibles, mystérieux et assez
occulte d'une certaine façon, c'est ce
qui aussi a perdu nombre de croyants.
Donc je ne crois pas à
l'intellectualisation pure de la foi. Je
pense que la foi repose aussi sur ses
rites, sur cette part de mystère. Et
plus on tendra à l'intellectualisation,
plus on tendra à la volonté de
rationalisation, plus on tendra à la
volonté d'essayer d'exprimer de la façon
la plus factuelle possible pourquoi on
croit. plus les églises seront
désertées. Donc je j'en reviens à votre
question. J'ai une vraie part de doute
en moi, mais je pense que ce doute est
aussi constitutif d'un mystère qui fait
qu'à la fin, je vais être davantage
pratiquant, je vais davantage douter, je
vais davantage trembler [grognement]
quand je serai devant une église et
devant ce mystère de la foi. Donc je
pense pas que ce soit incompatible de
pas être aussi pratiquant et de pas
aller à la messe tous les dimanches.
Parfois, d'avoir des doutes en même
temps de me remettre à quelque chose qui
me qui me dépasse.
Si je vous dis les gens qui se réfugient
dans la religion, c'est les gens qui ont
peur et qui ont besoin de se rassurer
avec un ami imaginaire.
Il y a une part de vrai. Il y a une part
de vrai. Je pense que la religion, le
mystère, la transcendance, c'est aussi
le royaume de ceux qui doutent, le
royaume de ceux qui n'ont pas toutes les
explications, le royaume de ceux qui
pensent qu'ils ne sont pas omnipotents,
omniscients, qu'ils n'ont pas tous les
pouvoirs et qu'à ce titre-là, ils
doivent aussi faire preuve d'humilité de
ces gens qui estiment que le centre du
monde n'est pas le centre de leur
nombril et que à ce titre-là, ils
doivent aussi faire de la place, euh
souvent s'excuser euh essayer aussi de
se remettre en question pour
s'améliorer,
de tendre l'autre joue,
de tendre l'autre jour, enfin juste de
faire preuve d'humilité, de laisser la
place aux doutes et aux autres. Donc euh
oui, vous avez raison. Je je pense que
la foi et le mystère de la religion est
aussi euh
le fondement de ceux qui doutent et qui
ont pas forcément confiance en eux. Mais
je pense que c'est sain de pas avoir
confiance en soi. Je pense que c'est
aussi ce qui permet à une société de
s'améliorer. C'est une quête de progrès
et c'est aussi une aspiration attendre
vers la meilleure version de soi-même.
Il y a une grande différence avec ceux
qui ont beaucoup de certitude.
Revenons à notre commission. Petite
parenthèse fermée. Vous inquiétez pas,
on pose ce type de question pratiquement
tous nos invités et on a eu un peu plus
de respect pour vous. C'est-à-dire que
on a pas commencé la question par est-ce
que vous avez un ami imaginaire ? Mais
passons.
Vous vous dites que vous avez vous avez
ressenti ou subi des attaques
coordonnées de médias qui était selon
vous sous emprise de ou contrôlé par un
peu ce que on vous a objecté un peu
avant. Vous pensez que c'était fait à
dessin ou c'était simplement parce que
c'était très banquable ?
En fait, quand vous avez des sociétés de
production qui bénéficient de près d'un
milliard d'euros de contrat passés par
France Télévision chaque année, que les
actionnaires et fondateurs de ces
sociétés de production sont aussi des
fondateurs et actionnaires de médias
importants. On pense à monsieur Niel qui
est actionnaire et fondateur de la
première société de production Media One
qui bénéficie des contrats avec France
Lévision à hauteur de 11 millions
d'euros qui est aussi fondateur ou
actionnaire de nombre de groupes de
médias importants comme l'OPS, comme le
monde comme le Finton Post comme les
jours. Je pense à monsieur Pigas qui est
lui aussi fondateur et actionnaire de
Media One qui bénéficie en tout cas qui
a à la tête d'un certain nombre de
groupes de médias et de de de groupes
culturels. Quand vous avez ces gens-là
que vous vous inquiétez, le le rôle
c'est pas de les inquiéter, c'est de
leur poser des questions sur les
conditions d'attribution de ces contrats
parce que ces contrats échappent à toute
règle de marché public et c'est
regrettable, c'est une recommandation
que je mets dans le rapport de respecter
les règles de marché public jusqu'à
présent ça y est échapper parce qu'on
considère que un karaokeé comme
n'oubliez pas les paroles que un plateau
comme c'est dans l'air ou c'est à vous
se sont considérés comme des œuvres et
de la création et qu'à ce titre-là ça
doit pas faire l'objet
d'un contrôle et d'un marché public en
monnaie du forme. Donc ça a donné lieu
depuis des années voir des décennies à
du favoritisme, à de la prise illégale
d'intérêt, à du détournement aussi
d'argent public et donc le seul fait de
faire la lumière sur la passation et les
conditions de passation de ces contrats,
c'est inquiéter ces gens qui se disaient
"Mince, on prend 110 millions d'euros
par an, on fournit des émissions qui
nous assurent un taux de marge quand
même assez confortable." Et
vous avez eu le taux de marge ? Ouais,
j'ai eu le taux de marge.
Comment ?
Parce que donc c'est l'un des pouvoirs
d'une commission d'enquête. Euh je
pouvais euh exiger les documents
notamment auprès de France Vision. Et
j'ai même révélé, vous le pourrez lire
euh dans le rapport que par exemple pour
une émission comme c'est à vous, la
marge réalisée infin dépasse de 10
points celle qui est convenue
initialement dans le devis. Et pourtant,
il y a une clause qui figure
spécifiquement dans les contrats qui
indique que quand la marge excède de cin
points ce qui est convenu initialement
dans le devis, c'est à la société de
production privée de rembourser l'audit
de production. Pardon, c'est un peu
technique mais c'est un point qui est
très important. J'ai vu donc dans le
contrat qu'il y avait une marche qui est
excédait de 10 points ce qui était
contenu dans le convenu dans le devis
pour l'émission. C'est à vous émission
de Mediawan et j'ai pu voir que ce
n'était pas Media One qui avait
remboursé l'audit de production mais
c'était France Télévision qui l'avait
payé. Donc pour avoir eu le malheur de
dire "Mais attendez, pourquoi vous
respectez pas cette clause qui s'impose
pourtant à toutes les sociétés de
production ? Pourquoi Media One n'a pas
remboursé le dit de production alors que
réglementairement ils auraient dû ? Ce
qui peut s'apparenter à du favoritisme.
Bon je je me suis pas fait des amis. la
direction de France Télévision à Beauté
en touche. Les dirigeants de Mediawan
ont pas souhaité me répondre mais c'est
un exemple parmi d'autres notamment sur
les conditions de passation des contrats
sur les marges réalisées sur des
documents que j'ai pu demander qui
viennent contrarier les intérêts de ces
personnes-là qui sont des personnes
puissantes, des personnes qui disposent
d'un certain nombre de médias, des
personnes qui veulent d'ailleurs limiter
les moyens de l'Assemblée nationale.
Zavel ne s'en est pas caché. Je vais je
vais prendre la la défense je vais me
faire l'avoquer du diable. Vous êtes pas
dit voilà Xavier Niel il a Courchevil,
il y a peut-être autre chose à
que envoyer euh ses journalistes euh
vous tailler des croupières. Euh c'est
peut-être des journalistes qui avaient
envie de surfer sur votre buzz ou c'est
peut-être des journalistes qui se
connaissent entre eux qui font partie du
même réseau, qu'on fait la même école et
que bah ça tourne dans leur groupe privé
et ils ont décidé de se faire Charles
Henri parce que Charles Henry papa était
préfet ça ?
Oui, mon père effectivement est préfet
et Nagy d'ailleurs le lendemain de son
audition est allé sur le plateau
quotidien devant Yan Bartes expliquant
donc révélant que je m'appelais Charles
Henri. Bon ça pour le coup il avait
raison. Et ensuite il explique, je vais
même vous en dire plus sur qui est
vraiment Charles Henry à l'oncle. Son
père avait soutenu ou travaillé pour
Charles Pasquis et il avait fait voter
des lois contre les Algériens. Moi, je
vois ça. Il réalise en plus une audience
considérable ce soir-là. Ils font plus
de 2 millions de téléspectateurs et donc
devant 2 millions de Français qui
écoutent quotidien, mon père est
diffamé. On explique que mon père a fait
passer des lois contre les Algériens.
C'est parfaitement faux. Mon père n'a
jamais travaillé euh ou soutenu Charles
Pasquis. À la limite, s'il l'avait fait,
ça m'aurait pas dérangé parce que
Charles Pasquis est issu d'une grande
famille de résistants et je pense ça
fait beaucoup de bien aussi notre
famille politique. Mais c'est même pas
vrai. Mon père n'a jamais travaillé pour
lui, ne l'a pas soutenu et mon père a
encore moins fait passer ou fait voter
des lois contre les Algériens. Donc de
voir Nagi qui vient me diffamer, qui
vient me discréditer sur une émission
suivie par 2 millions de français le
lendemain de son édition en expliquant
mais si en fait il m'a posé ces
questions, s'il m'a demandé combien
coûtait mon karaokeé, n'oubliez pas les
paroles. S'il m'a expliqué, s'il m'a
demandé pourquoi je prenais des dizaines
voir des centaines de millions d'euros
de contrat depuis des années, c'est
parce que son père en fait est un
raciste, que son père a passé des lois
contre les Algériens. Il a pas dit
raciste.
Alors, il l'a fortement sous-entendu. Il
avait fait un post sur les réseaux
sociaux qui m'a jeté en pâure devant son
demi million d'abonnés pour expliquer
que si je le convoquais alors que j'ai
convoqué Laurent de Laousse, j'ai
convoqué Léa Salamé, j'ai convoqué
Samuel Étienne, j'ai convoqué Michel
Drucker, j'ai convoqué Patrice
Sébastien, Elise Lu Tristan W énormément
d'animateurs. Mais si je convoquais
Nagi, c'est parce qu'il était d'origine
égyptienne et c'est parce qu'il était
végan. Il met ça premier degré noir sur
blanc dans son poste sur les réseaux
sociaux qui m'a valu mais des centaines
de messages d'insultes où je on m'a
passé on m'a fait passer pour un
raciste. On m'a dit "Mais si tu
t'intéresses à Nagis parce qu'il est
d'origine égyptienne et végane." Enfin
comme si moi j'étais un carnivore
effronté et que je je j'en voulais à la
terre entière à tous ceux qui pouvaient
préférer les graines à la viande. Enfin
tout ça est complètement ridicule. Il y
a pas que des graines. Oh
non mais pardon mais de voir ce poste là
sur ces réseaux sociaux qui m'a jeté en
pâure devant un demi million de
personnes de voir aussi ces allégations
mensongères que j'attaquerai d'ailleurs
sur le plateau de quotidien contre mon
père qui a été un serviteur de l'État
impeccable depuis des années qui n'a
jamais fait passer la moindre loi
discriminatoire et encore moins contre
des Algériens de voir ce type de
d'attaque sous la ceinture qui a été
proférée à quelques semaines d'ailleurs
du vote du rapport. Je vous avoue que je
l'ai vraiment mauvaise. J'ai une forme
d'aigreur et j'espère qu'un jour on
rétablirait à la fois mon honneur et que
ces gens-là s'excuseront et expliqueront
que ils sont peut-être allés trop loin
dans leurs accusations et que la moindre
des choses c'était pour eux de rendre
des comptes parce que c'était tout
l'objet aussi de cette commission
d'enquête.
Le le journaliste ou la personne qui
était en face de Nigi quand il a balancé
ça, est-ce que il y a une contradiction
en face du genre c'est quoi la source ?
Vous avez enquêté ? Vous avez appelé un
cabinet pour enquêter ? Comment ça se
passe ?
La contradiction c'était Yan Bart. qui a
ricané en apprenant ça, qui a fait
l'ofusqué. D'ailleurs, je me souviens
cette séquence m'a marqué, elle a marqué
mon père, elle a marqué aussi une bonne
partie de ma famille qui s'appelle à
l'oncle qui ont été aussi contactés sur
les réseaux sociaux où on les a accusé
de de racisme en disant "Ah ouais, toi
aussi ton père c'est un gros raciste qui
a fait passer des lois contre les
Algériens." Donc je me souviens à peu
près de ces moments, tout le plateau sur
Charles Henry machin Rican euh c'est
assez saisissant, vous voyez et il y a
un effet assez immédiable. Je crois que
le score d'audience ce soir-là était
considérable. Vous voyez très bien
l'opinion notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux, particulièrement sur Twitter,
vous voyez l'opinion se retourner des
gens. Vous voyez même des messages
disant "Mais je l'aimais bien le
rapporteur." Il posait des questions qui
étaient pertinentes. Je croyais en lui
mais en fait c'est bon, j'ai compris.
Son père est un raciste. Il aime pas
Nagi parce qu'il est d'origine
égyptienne. Il a un problème avec les
végan. En fait, j'ai tout compris.
D'ailleurs, il s'appelle pas Charles, il
s'appelle Charles Henri. Donc il y a une
présomption de bourgeoisie, une
présomption de d'être soi-disant bien né
et donc à ce titre-là de ne pas être
suffisamment représentatif des Français
parce que c'était ça le procès qui
m'était fait, que j'étais pas digne
aussi de mener cette enquête parce que
j'appartenais soi-disant, ce qui est
parfaitement faux. Moi, j'ai des
grands-parents qui n'ont pas eu le bac.
Enfin, je je je sais aussi d'où je viens
et je sais le mérite de mon prê de mon
père qui est un pur produit de la
méritocratie républicaine, qui est le
premier d'ailleurs à voulu le bac de sa
famille. Donc je je sais aussi d'où je
viens et j'ai une immense fierté pour ce
qu'il a pu accomplir grâce à l'école de
la République. de de voir du jour au
lendemain ce type d'accusation, ce type
d'insulte me jeter en pâure sur les
réseaux sociaux et de voir aucune forme
de contradiction et contradictoire de la
peine de la part de Yan Bartes qui
depuis le début de cette commission
d'enquête avec Jean-Michel Apat avec un
certain nombre aussi de journalistes se
sont dit on va essayer de le
discréditer, on va essayer aussi de
montrer à quel point soi-disant cette
commission d'enquête est un circoue que
j'ai beau avoir le cuir un peu plus
épais maintenant que la commission
d'enquête est terminée à ce moment-là il
était pas suffisamment épais pour ne pas
m'attendre.
Vous avez l'impression que c'est une
gestion de la politique à l'américaine,
c'est-à-dire utiliser les grands médias
pour mettre des petites balayettes,
mettre des couteaux dans le dos, mettre
des cibles. Euh est-ce que c'est un un
astrurfing à la papa pour influencer
l'opinion publique ? Ouais, je je pense
je pense et quand on voit euh parfois la
dimension coordonnée de repost
médiatique, je vous en parlais euh au
premil en introduction de de cet
entretien, notamment dans les heures qui
ont précédé le vote et dans les heures
qui ont précédé la publication du
rapport sur notamment cette fausse
information d'une soi-disant plainte qui
a été déposée contre moi pour prise
légale d'intérêt quand vous voyez à quel
point ces informations sont relayées de
façon coordonnée par l'agence France
Press par le monde qu'il révèle
par France Inter qui ont fait des flash
toutes les demi-heures sur leur matinal
par le site de France info quand vous
voyez la dimension coordonnée
d'alignement d'intérêts privés parce que
derrière le monde il y a aussi des
intérêts privés de gens qui sont à la
tête de société de production qui
profitent de contrats importants du
service public et d'intérêt public quand
vous voyez un tel alignement des
planètes publiques privées un tel
dévoiement et une telle altération de la
sincérité de l'information vous pouvez
vous dire d'une certaine façon que oui
il y a un petit système qui se défend et
qui use de tous les moyens, y compris
l'argent du contribuable pour aller
dénigérer le travail d'un parlementaire.
Euh, [raclement de gorge] comment on dit
alignement des planètes ?
Apprenez-le moi.
Cig
Mais dans quelle langue ?
En français.
En français,
vous parliez on aime on aime les mots.
Euh vous parliez d'assaignissement,
cet effet à dessin
assignir.
Oui.
Vous savez ce qu'on a saigni ? On
assaignit les égouts. On assaignit c'est
c'est fait exprès d'utiliser ce champ
lexical.
C'est fait exprès, je le revendique. Et
d'ailleurs,
quoi ? Et c'est c'est pourquoi
et même pour vous dire hier euh hier
soir, je reçois un un message sur
WhatsApp de du responsable des
administrateurs de l'Assemblée nationale
à qui j'avais transmis mon rapport 10
jours auparavant parce que je devais le
remettre donc 4 jours avant le vote du
rapport parce qu'il fallait que les
députés membres de la commission
d'enquête puissent le consulter dans une
salle fermée pendant 3 jours. Tout ça
est très mais bon ça faisait à peu près
de semaines que le rapport ne
m'appartenait plus. Je ne pouvais plus
en faire la moindre modification. Il
appartenait à l'assemblée, enfin il
appartenait en tout cas à
l'administration de l'Assemblée
nationale. Et donc hier dans les heures
qui ont précédé la publication de ce
rapport, je reçois un WhatsApp du chef
des administrateurs me disant "Monsieur
le rapporteur, on vous a pas demandé, il
faudrait donner un titre à ce rapport."
Et je vous avoue, chose qui me
paraissait évidente, j'avais pas
vraiment réfléchi au titre de ces 400
pages qui, sachant que le rapport avait
déjà été voté, ça resterait, je dis pas
que ça fera l'histoire, que ça fera
l'histoire parlementaire, long de moi
ces prétentions là, mais quand vous avez
ce choix-là qui peut paraître
complètement anecdotique, donner un
titre à ces 400 pages, à ces 6 mois de
travaux, à ces nuits blanches, à ces
weekends atrophier, à ces journées
stressante que vous avez consacré.
Chaque mot compte. Donc c'est pour ça
que je suis intéressé par votre question
parce que j'ai longtemps hésité. J'ai
demandé un peu le le l'avis de mes
collaborateurs et donc je me suis
arrêté. J'espère que je vous et vous
pourrez le vérifier d'ailleurs sur le
site de l'Assemblée. J'espère que vous
je vous traduira exactement le le bon
titre. Le titre je me suis dit il faut
que ça commence par le titre principal
audiovisuel public commun des Français
parce que pour moi c'est important. Tous
les Français ils contribuent. Tous les
Français sont coactionnaires, doivent
être codécisionnaires et en plus
majoritairement ils tiennent à cette
audiovisuel publique et ça traduit aussi
l'attachement que je peux avoir parce
que je dois beaucoup de choses notamment
mon éveil politique, mon éveil culturel
à des belles émissions et des beaux
programmes de service public. Je voulais
rappeler cet attachement par ce premier
titre comme
la cuisine de Maité.
Alors non, je suis trop jeune. Pardon,
je suis trop jeune. Je sais qu' est
Maité, je la connais aussi à travers le
sketch des inconnus euh
sur J'ai beau tr matinal, j'ai mal. Mais
mais c'est un peu le ma connaissance de
maité s'arrête aussi aux parodies qui
ont été faites et qui sont très drôles.
Mais bon voilà, titre principal,
l'audiuel public, deux points bien
commun des français. Après, le
sous-titre pour moi était le plus
important et c'est là où c'est
intéressant. J'ai longtemps hésité dans
le choix des mots et j'ai retenu,
j'espère ne pas dire de de bêtises et
vous pourrez vérifier sur le titre exact
du rapport, j'ai retenu
garantir le pluralisme,
redresser les comptes et assaignir les
pratiques. Pour moi, c'est le triptique
essentiel, je m'exc plus vite
f checking que vous pouvez faire mais
pour moi, c'était ça. pour moi le
triptique essentiel du redressement
indispensable de ces entreprises de
l'audiel public pour garantir un service
public qui rassemble et qui ressemble au
français et qui dans un an ne souffrera
tellement d'aucune contestation que on
ne parlera plus de privatisation, que la
présidentielle ne tournera plus autour
de ce sujet parce qu'il y a bien
d'autres sujets encore plus
indispensables et nécessaires pour
l'avenir des Français et pour notre
souveraineté. Je voudrais pas qu'on
braque un projecteur trop important sur
une campagne présidentielle sur ces
seuls 4000ards. Il y a bien d'autres
sujets qui sont fondamentaux, mais je
pense que pour garantir une bonne
mission au service du public, il y a à
la fois la garantie du pluralisme, le
redressement des comptes pour qu'on
arrête d'éponger les gabgis et
l'irresponsabilité voire même l'impunité
de ces dirigeants qui sont subsédés qui
ont cramé la caisse en disant c'est pas
mon argent, c'est les Français qui
payent. Donc on s'en fout. Et
l'assaignissement des pratiques parce
que de ce que j'ai pu voir.
Vous auriez pu employer un autre
champical encore plus dur.
Ouais. Alors l'assainissement, vous avez
raison. Je pense que c'est un c'est un
terme qui est cru qui indique le travail
de de purge. Il y a curé. Non pas purge.
Il y a curé aussi qui qui marche bien
ou mais qui est qui est moins moins
délicat. Mais effectivement il
s'assimile à peu près à ça à
l'assainissement des pratiles. Vous avez
raison. curer les comptes publics. Non,
c'est pas ça.
Oui, mais j'ai j'ai effectivement
préféré ce ce terme et je je revendique
totalement ce terme. Quand on voit l'
C'était vraiment un bourbier
et c'est un bourbier énorme. Quand vous
voyez l'ampleur des conflits d'intérêt,
je vous citer deux exemples que
vous avez déclenché des articles 40,
un premier effectivement les
sur les indemnisations pour tu te tais
parce que tu as eu des Ouais, on on va
on va en parler un peu après.
Euh j'ai j'ai perdu le fil, vous m'avez
déconcentré les gars. Désolé. Je vais
vous poser une blague et puis on va
rebondir sur ce que vous étiez en train
de dire. Si je vous dis une boutade,
vous allez me trouver l'auteur de la
boutade qui d'ailleurs a été peut-être
pas une boutade mais peut-être une
boutade. Quand les journalistes
m'emmerdent, je prends une participation
dans leur canard et ensuite ils me
foutent la paix.
Alors je l'ai c'est pas un humoriste. On
aimerait que ce soit un humoriste parce
que ce serait très drôle.
Un humoriste François Hollande
par exemple. Ça pourrait être ce type de
d'humour mais je préférais d'ailleurs
que ça vienne de d'un humorist.
Malheureusement non, ça vient d'un d'un
patron de presse important. Ça vient
d'un fondateur et actionnaire d'une
société de production importante.
La première société de production qui
bénéficie des contrats de France
Télévision. Ça bénéfie ça vient de
Xavieral si je me trompe pas et c'est
dommage. Vous
vous trompez pas
et ça fait peur d'ailleurs sur fait
toujours je vais prendre je vais prendre
la défense je vais je pas la défense je
vais me faire l'avocat du diable.
C'est un entrepreneur.
Vous suivez son compte Twitter, il fait
des blagues à longueur de journée.
Et vous pensez que c'est une blague ?
Vous pensez quand je quand un journal
des journalistes m'emmerdent, je prends
une participation dans leur canard et en
fait ils se taisent. Vous pensez
vraiment que venant de Xavieral ? Alors
on a le droit à l'humour, on a le droit
à l'ironie, à la dérision mais quelque
chose me dit malgré tout que c'est pas
forcément une blague.
Ouais. C'est toujours
d'ailleurs, ça a été en fait cette
citation a été allègrement discutée.
Il l'a nié, il a expliqué, j'ai jamais
dit ça sans ou sa biographe a expliqué
si je vous assure, je vous affirme que
j'ai bien entendu cette donc on voit que
même lui n'est pas à l'aise avec cette
citation. Donc
check news non on a parlé. Comment c'est
c'est quoi le
doit être l'IB là. Ouais.
continue, excusez-moi.
Non mais et en fait euh bon, il il a le
droit de de revenir sur ses propos. s'il
ne les assume pas et qu'il convient que
ça peut faire peur, ça peut faire froid
dans le dos à nombre de citoyens sur la
qualité de l'information qui leur est
délivrée, sur la sincérité de
l'information qui est délivrée, qui est
peut-être le premier mur porteur d'une
démocratie saine, euh je comprends que
ça puisse faire froid dans le dos aux
français et qu'il se disent "J'ai pas
envie de jeter un voile de suspicion sur
mes participations médiatiques et donc
je vais ni avoir tenu ses propos."
Ça montre d'une certaine façon qu'il a
un recul aussi sur l'engagement qu'il
doit avoir. Mais moi, je vous avoue que
ça me fait encore plus froid dans le dos
que tous ceux qui peuvent éprouver des
des craintes sur ce type de phrase.
C'est d'ailleurs une question que je lui
ai posé dans le cadre de de la
commission d'enquête. C'est une question
qu'il a pas vraiment apprécié. Peut-être
l'une des raisons d'ailleurs qu'il a mis
dans un état de fureur difficilement
compréhensible, assez inquiétant
d'ailleurs. Il était comme survolté, les
yeux orbités, tremblant aussi de tout
son corps. Et je me suis dit à ce
moment-là d'une violence d'ailleurs
notamment verbale assez inouie que je
n'attendais pas, qui était d'ailleurs
assez inédite dans le cadre de cette
commission d'enquête. On a vu pourtant
défiler beaucoup de patrons
d'entreprise, beaucoup de producteurs,
beaucoup de dirigeants de l'audovel
public qui pour certains étaient
stressés parce que il y avait des
questions compliquées compromettantes
qu'on allait leur poser mais se sont
toujours très bien comportés. Là,
c'était la première fois qu'on voyait
quelqu'un quasiment dans un état second.
Et je vous avoue que pour l'avoir vécu,
pour avoir
accueilli cette forme de violence et
d'outrance verbale et physique, euh je
me suis inquiété pour les dizaines voire
les centaines d'entrepreneurs qui ont
cette personnelà à leur bord et à leur
conseil d'administration. et je me suis
dit d'avoir une personne aussi centrale
qui a de telles participations dans des
entreprises notamment françaises ou
internationales fondamental de voir une
telle perte de moyens dans un moment
aussi important. Ça m'a un peu ça m'a un
peu inquiété en tout cas ça m'a un peu
interpellé. Peut-être pas ces boîtes
comme ça. Il y a peut-être passer une
mauvaise nuit
et ça peut arriver à tout le monde. Et
ça peut arriver à tout le monde.
Effectivement
il avait des sué Vous nous dites qu'il
avait des sué. Il était peut-être
constipé ou inversement.
des choses comme ça, il y a peut-être
mal au ventre, il a peut-être envie de
faire pipi,
ça peut arriver à tout le monde. Je vous
invite à à regarder les les 45 premières
minutes de cette commission d'enquête ou
d'ailleurs c'est pas contre moi qu'il a
déversé ses outrances, c'est contre le
président de la commission d'enquête,
président Macronils, qui a eu pour seul
tort, je le défends totalement sur ce
coup, de lui avoir demandé en toute
première question avant même que
monsieur Nial prête serment, vous avez
eu une convocation pour une précédente
audition à laquelle vous n'avez pas
déféré, vous n'êtes pas présenté alors
que c'est une obligation légale qui est
importante.
Vous n'avez pas voulu vous présenter à
cette première audition pour laquelle
vous étiez convoqué et même pour vous
dire, il nous avait demandé une
exemption. Il nous avait dit "Je suis à
l'étranger pour des raisons
professionnelles, j'aimerais pouvoir
participer à cette audition en
visoconférence".
Bon, ce qui est assez rare, c'est
la commission sur les plateformes, il y
en avait deux qui étaient il y en avait
un YouTube, il était en vidéo
conference. Vous avez raison. Euh ça
arrive mais c'est assez rare et
généralement on prend cette décision
pour un motif exceptionnel et je
considéris on demande au rapporteur son
approbation et je considéris que Xavier
Niel étant un entrepreneur reconnu,
chevroné, ayant un vrai impact quand
même sur le tissu entrepreneurial
français. Bon ben c'est important lui
accorder des facilités. s'il a à
l'étranger pour aller euh aider euh des
entreprises, pour aller participer en
tout cas à son agenda professionnel,
c'était euh tout à fait normal de lui
permettre de s'adapter aussi et de
pouvoir répondre à cette audition. Donc,
j'avais accepté qu'il soit en
visoconférence et 30 minutes avant le
démarrage de cette audition qui mobilise
des équipes, qui mobilise
l'administration, qui mobilise une
salle, qui nécessite une vraie
préparation, qui mobilise aussi des
journalistes, il y a quand même tout un
tout un cadre qui est quand même assez
lourd à l'Assemblée nationale et qui a
un coup 30 minutes avant le début de
cette audition, on reçoit un mail le
président et moi du secrétariat de
monsieur Nial 30 minutes avant. Vraiment
l'audition commencé à 14h30 à 13h59 on
reçoit un mail nous disant "Monsieur
Niel finalement ne se présentera pas euh
à l'audition pour aucune justification,
aucun motif, aucune excuse."
Il était peut-être aux urgences, il
voulait pas vous en parler parce qu'il
s'était peut-être tordu une couille.
Non,
ce motif médical aurait été justifié, je
vous l'accorde. C'est la raison pour
laquelle on lui a envoyé un mail pour
dire "Mais d'accord, mais on aimerait
avoir un motif."
nous a jamais répondu et donc il est
venu un mois et demi après parce qu'on
lui a renvoyé une convocation. Donc
l'audition a été annulée. On a dû
congédier le personnel de l'Assemblée
nationale qui s'était mobilisé, les
députés, les journalistes. Tout ça a été
remis un mois et demi après. Donc un
mois et demi après, il se présente enfin
devant la commission d'enquête et le
président avant même que Xavier Niel
prête serment lui pose cette simple
question évidente.
Alors la neige était bonne
alors pas encore et ça dépend quelle
neige. Mais
oh non ça ça c'est gratuit ça.
Non non mais mais monsieur Niel pourquoi
vous ne vous êtes pas présenté à cette à
cette audition ? Et la fureur de
monsieur Niel qu'on a absolument pas
comprise qui explique au président
directement qu'il attaque en disant vous
n'êtes pas un procureur, vous n'avez pas
à me demander ce que je faisais à ce
moment-là, ce n'est pas votre rôle d'une
certaine façon, vous violez mais non
parce que quand vous ne répondez pas à
la loi, quand vous ne déférez pas une
convocation d'une commission d'enquête,
vous devez à minimal justifier. Déjà,
c'est une rupture légale et vous devez
le justifier. Et donc la question du
président de la commission d'enquête
était parfaitement légitime. Monsieur
Niel est rentré dans une colère
incompréhensible ce qui fait que le
président était totalement désarmé. N'a
pas voulu euh reposer une deuxième fois
sa question. Monsieur Niel quelques
minutes après, a simulé un départ de
commission d'enquête de de l'audition en
expliquant de toute façon vous voulez
pas m'entendre. Si c'est ça, en fait, je
me casse. Donc il il prend sa veste, il
se lève, le président l'appelle en
disant "Non, non, monsieur Niel, surtout
pas, venez, en fait, on va être un peu
plus sympa." Enfin, c'est je traduis le
sous-texte mais venez monsieur Niel, on
vous attend, vous inquiétez pas en fait,
on va être on va être gentil. Euh et
donc monsieur Niel se rassier, moi je
soupçonne une mise en scène qui était
longuement préparée et mise en scène qui
était tellement préparée qu'à la fin de
cette audition qui a duré assez
longtemps, monsieur Niel assez courtois,
assez poli est venu me voir, m'a salué,
m' dit "Monsieur le rapporteur, j'ai un
cadeau pour vous. Je vous remets mon
dernier livre, vous allez voir, c'est
dit beaucoup de choses. J'espère que
vous aurez le l'occasion de le lire.
Je regarde son livre. Donc
effectivement, il m'a offert son livre
et son livre écrit noir sur blanc, c'est
sa couverture, une sacrée envie de
le bordel. Donc il m'offre ce
livre à la fin de son édition qui
traduit d'une certaine façon l'attitude
qu'il a eu devant la la représentation
nationale et c'était une forme de
signature, une sacrée envie de le
bordel. Ça montré aussi que ce cowboy
des télécom, ce mania d'une certaine
façon ce sérial entrepreneur qui a
beaucoup de mérite, qui a beaucoup
d'intelligence, qui a aussi une vraie
compétence notamment entrepreneuriale,
voulait montrer qu'il était un peu
au-dessus de tout ça, que ces outrances
ont peut-être été enfin peut-être été
d'une certaine façon un peu coordonné et
obéissez à une stratégie, celle de
suputation pure,
celle de le bordel. Et donc tout
ça pour dire parce que pardon je suis en
train de vous mettre un tunnel euh on a
appris quelques jours après, c'est off
investigation qui a diffusé ça, qui a
révélé ça, que monsieur Niel en fait
lors de sa première audition à laquelle
il devait euh déférer en fait était pas
du tout à l'étranger. Il était pas du
tout en train de sauver une entreprise
comme il a pu nous le faire entendre
parce qu'il nous a dit voyez vous me
convoquez, j'aurais pu être un conseil
d'administration d'une entreprise
importante française que j'aurais pu
sauver. Moi, votre cirque de l'Assemblée
nationale et de demander des comptes à
des gens, ça me dépasse complètement. Je
pourrais être beaucoup plus utile
ailleurs. Et d'ailleurs, vous êtes trop
payé. D'ailleurs, à l'Assemblée
nationale, c'est pas normal qu'on mette
autant d'argent. En limite, on devrait
baisser le salaire des députés, on
devrait baisser le salaire des équipes
qui vous aident pour d'une certaine
façon aussi. C'est pas du tout ses
propos, mais il y a il y a une tentation
de corruption. Moins vous payez des
représentants du peuple.
Suputé. C'est suputé.
C'est pas du tout ce qu'il a dit. C'est
pas du tout ce qu'il a dit. C'est
probablement pas son intention, mais la
conséquence directe d'une telle
intention qui est dire vous êtes trop
payé, une commission d'enquête coûte
trop d'argent, c'est celle de dire bah
demain OK, en fait si on met pas de
moyens, si l'Assemblée arrête d'évaluer
les politiques publiques, si l'Assemblée
nationale arrête d'enquêter, si les
collaborateurs des députés ne sont plus
payés 1500 € ou 2000 € par mois mais 800
ou 900 € par mois, c'est la porte
ouverte à toutes les formes de
corruption. Donc je ne comprends pas
comment on peut justifier un tel message
parce que ce serait aussi l'honneur
d'une démocratie de renforcer le pouvoir
des parlementaires, de renforcer le
pouvoir des représentants du peuple qui
seront demain encore plus imperméables à
ces tentatives d'ingérence, d'influence
notamment financière et économique. Donc
on a pu apprendre qu'il était non pas à
l'étranger en train de sauver une
entreprise mais qu'il était à Courchevel
en train de faire du ski. Donc c'est
la neige était bonne.
La neige était bonne visiblement il en a
profité. allègrement. Off investigation
lui a posé la question, il ne l'a pas
nié. Il n'a pas voulu répondre aux
questions des journalistes. Il y a
plusieurs sources de journalistes
concordantes qui expliquent qu'il était
effectivement à Courchevel. Et à
nouveau, je pense que son intention, une
sacrée envie de le bordel
témoigne un mépris considérable de cet
homme pour simplement les principes et
les murs porteurs d'une démocratie qui
se porte bien.
Courchevel, c'est surfait. Il faut aller
à M tabi beaucoup plus familial. Le
fromage est délicieux. Les gens sont
absolument magnifiques et gentils. Mais
habillé dans le doux.
Je connais pas.
On les embrasse fort et on on revient à
notre interview. Est-ce qu'on vous a
entravé les auditions ?
Oui. Euh oui oui, je peux vous citer
quelques exemples. Je vous ai cité
l'interruption de des auditions de la
commission d'enquête. Donc une
interruption d'un peu plus d'un mois
décidée arbitrairement en outrepassant
ses pouvoirs par le président de la
commission d'enquête.
Il y a des auditions qu'on m'a refusé
aussi. Une audition c'est celle de
Caroline Lang. Caroline Lang enfin vous
savezstein
c'est exactement c'est la fille de Jack
Lang et Caroline Lang est une une pièce
maîtresse du paysage de l'audiovisuel
français.
Pourquoi elle a faitin d'ailleurs ? euh
pour Caroline Lang parce que je crois
que elle était à la tête d'une société
ici on n'est pas là pour croire hein
avec alors non mais je je j'ai je je
veux pas vous dire de bêtises mais euh
monsieur Epstein avait confié ou avait
créé une société en lien avec Caroline
Lang euh dans les derniers jours de
monsieur Epstein, il y avait un
testament qui avait été je crois établi
pour
que madame Lang hérite d'une somme quand
même extrêmement importante de plusieurs
dizaines 2 millions d'euros euh
[grognement] bon
plusieurs millions d'euros
plusieurs millions d'euros je préfère
être précautionneux précautionneux
pardon donc Caroline Lang était une
pièce maîtresse du paysage de l'audiuel
pourquoi parce qu'elle était présidente
directrice générale présidente ou en
tout cas elle était à la tête du
syndicat des producteurs indépendants.
syndicat qu'on a entendu dans le cadre
de la commission d'enquête parce que
l'ADN du service public, c'est aussi de
financer et de soutenir la création et
la production indépendante française et
parce que madame Lang était à la tête de
la Warner en France et l'entreprise
Warner est une des entreprises qui
bénéficient le plus de contrat de France
Télévision. Au même titre que Media One,
Biger, ces sociétés-là, la Warner
bénéficie de contrats très importants
chaque année de plusieurs dizaines de
millions d'euros de la part de France
Télévision. Donc madame Langue était une
personnalité très importante. C'était
parfaitement légitime qu'on l'entende.
Moi je réclame son audition depuis le
début de la commission d'enquête et
honnêtement je n'ai pas compris
l'opposition du président de la
commission d'enquête, monsieur Patrick
Lettus. L'opposition de la gauche et des
macronistes qui m'ont regardé avec
d'habill comme ça en me disant "Mais
attendez, qu'est-ce que vous demandez ?
Vous demandez l'audition de Caroline
Lang ?" Alors là, ça a pas du tout être
possible. comme si j'avais demandé
l'audition d'une personne qui n'avait
rien à voir avec le sujet de la
commission d'enquête, même l'audition
d'une personne qu'il fallait à tout prix
protéger parce que
supputation ça
alors non c'est pas une supputation
parce que c'est l'une des seules
auditions qu'on m'a refusé. Si on
m'avait refusé une quinzaine.
François Hollande François Hollande, on
l'a entendu.
Alors François Hollande, on l'a pas
entendu.
François Hollande pendant longtemps,
pendant longtemps, la le bureau de la
commission d'enquête voulait pas trop
que je le convoque. Alors que pourtant
le président du CSA de l'époque avait
dit que François Hollande avait influé
sur la nomination de Delphine Arnut en
rupture totale de la loi alors que c'est
lui-même qui avait fait passer une loi
pour que l'Élysée ne se mêle plus à la
nomination de des présidents de de Grub.
Mais à la fin, il faut dire la vérité,
le bureau n'avait donné raison, le
président aussi. Et le président avait
fini par envoyer une convocation à
François-Hollande qu'il a lui-même
refusé. Il n'en avait pas le droit.
D'autant plus qu'il avait participé déjà
à des commissions d'enquête, notamment
sur le nucléaire, notamment sur un
certain nombre de sujets important. Donc
euh quand vous dites c'est une suppation
comme quoi Caroline Lang était une
personne à protéger,
c'est plus qu'une suppitation parce que
c'est l'un des seuls noms euh proposés
qui a été refusé.
Gérard Larch
Gérard Larch France insoumise voulait
l'auditionner. Monsieur Saintoule et
d'autres de ses collègues de la France
insoumise ont voulu l'auditionner. Moi
depuis le début, j'ai toujours dit parce
que
c'est un Tou, il bose bien hein,
il travaille bien. Il travaille bien. Je
trouve qu'il est intéressant. J'ai
beaucoup de désaccord sur le fond avec
lui mais il a été très présent dans le
cadre de la commission dans lequat. Il a
participé à beaucoup d'éditions avec un
certain sérieux, avec une vraie
sincérité et un vrai rapport euh à la
vérité, pardon, pour cette totologie. Et
je vous avoue que dans l'ensemble des
députés membres de la commission
d'enquête qui ont participé à la
commission d'enquête, euh monsieur
Saint-Toule est l'un de ceux qui m'a le
plus euh impressionné. Oui, je je peux
le dire, je peux le dire. En tout cas,
il a fait un un gros travail. À nouveau,
il me charge allègrement euh parce que
je pense qu'il est pas d'accord avec moi
sur un certain nombre de de propositions
et c'est parfaitement normal. C'est le
sens de la démocratie. Et je lui
reconnais une certaine compétence et je
lu reconnais une certaine et je lui
reconnais aussi une certaine honnêteté.
Vous pouvez rajouter une certaine
pugnacité,
une certaine publicnacité qui est une
qualité quand on est parlementaire.
L'insistance, la publicité, l'envie de
ne rien lâcher qui m'a été allégègrement
reproché. Parce que pour beaucoup par
qui ? part bon nombre de de députés, le
président de la commission d'enquête qui
s'étonnait que je puisse poser à deux ou
trois reprises des questions pour
lesquelles je n'avais pas de réponse.
Soit-disant, c'était une rupture
fondamentale avec les principes de
l'Assemblée nationale que d'être
insistant, que de faire preuve
d'insistance avec des personnes qui
prêtaient serment et qui passaient en
audition devant notre commission
d'enquête. Je n'avais pas le droit quand
je n'obtenais pas une réponse. Je vous
donner un exemple. C'est le président de
la 3e chambre de la Cour des comptes. Il
est au magistrat, personne a sermenté.
Il est payé par nos impôts pour une
vraie sincérité, un audit transparent
d'un certain nombre de politiques
publiques. Et je lui pose une question
simple dans le cadre de son audition. On
était au début de la commission
d'enquête. Est-ce que oui ou non vous
avez reçu un mail du secrétaire général
de France Tévision pour vous demander de
décaler la publication du rapport de la
Cour des comptes sur France Tévision
après la décision de reconduire Delphin
Arnut ? question assez simple parce
qu'on était très surpris de voir que
France Télévision entreprise de 3
milliards d'euros de budget de 9000
salariés la Cour des comptes avait
attendu plus de 9 ans pour revenir faire
un audit de France Télévision là où des
entreprises de quelques centaines de
millions d'euros de budget d'entreprises
publiques subissent des contrôles tous
les 3 ou 4 ans. Là c'est étonnant France
Tévision on a attendu 9 ans pour avoir
la Cour des comptes qui revient. Donc je
me suis étonné de ce calendrier. J'ai
plusieurs sources qui m'ont avéré le
fait que le secrétaire général de France
Livision avait envoyer un mail à la Cour
des comptes pour demander le décalage du
rapport qui m'ont lu le verbat exact du
mail qui aurait été envoyé par monsieur
Tardieu à monsieur Mda 3e président de
de la Cour des comptes et donc j'ai ce
président de la Cour des comptes en face
de moi qui a prêté serment. question
très légitime. Je dis mais monsieur le
président, vous avez sorti votre rapport
quelques jours après la nomination de
Delphine Arnut. Il aurait été plus
opportun de publier ce rapport de la
Cour des comptes avant sa nomination
pour éclairer l'ARCOM sur cette décision
de reconduction pour savoir si elle
avait fait un bon travail sur la partie
financière. Ça aurait été beaucoup plus
pertinent que d'attendre sa
reconduction. Est-ce que oui ou non vous
avez reçu un mail du secrétaire général
de Franceision vous demandant de décaler
la sortie du rapport ? Question fermée,
simple, oui ou non ? Est-ce que vous
avez reçu un mail ?
à quatre reprises, il refuse de répondre
et je vous invite vraiment parce que le
moment est confondant
est un témoin éclairant de l'affessement
de nos institutions et de la perte de
confiance aussi que les français
légitimement peuvent éprouver à l'égard
de nos élites, à l'égard de nos corps de
contrôle, à l'égard d'un certain nombre
de haut fonctionnaires qui sont pourtant
payés par nos impôts pour défendre les
intérêts des français et pour faire
toute la transparence. Je vous invite à
revoir ces 10 minutes de de espèce de de
dérobade. Le terme est pas du tout
français mais je l'emploie. On a un haut
magistrat qui prête serment qui par tous
les moyens essaie de se dérober à la
vérité, essaie de trouver des espèces de
de d'arguments ou de pirouettes
linguistiques et et lexical pour essayer
de ne pas répondre oui ou non à la
question pourtant très simple que je lui
pose. Donc on a on a ça qui est quand
même assez assez dingue. On a quand même
un haut magistrat qui se dérobe qui se
dérobe à cette question pourtant simple.
Donc je vous avoue que cette pugnacité,
cette insistance, j'ai posé quatre fois
la question et pourtant à quatre
reprises, je n'ai pas obtenu la réponse
de voir qu'on me le reproche après coup
en me disant mais le rapporteur ça était
un inquisiteur, ça a étit un procureur
comme si d'ailleurs le terme de
procureur était une insulte pour
beaucoup de personnes. Oui, j'assume,
c'est une commission d'enquête. On est
là pour mettre le doigt sur un certain
nombre de dérives de dysfonctionnements.
C'est pas une mission d'information,
c'est pas une table ronde. On est là
pour enquêter, on est là pour émettre
des recommandations, pour résoudre ces
dérives. Donc d'être insistant pour
essayer dans un esprit un peu de
maillotique, essayer d'accoucher un peu
de la vérité, je pense que c'est la
meilleure des solutions plutôt que de
poser une question, d'obtenir une
réponse. Cette réponse ne répond rien à
la question qu'on a posé mais on fait
semblant. Ça a été le cadre de beaucoup
de commissions d'enquête à l'Assemblée
nationale. J'ai posé ma question, j'ai
pas obtenu de réponse mais au moins les
Français pourront pas se dire que je
suis partial. Je continue, j'avance, je
pose d'autres questions, mais au moins
ça ne mettra en difficulté personne et
ça ne contreviendra aucun intérêt que je
pourrais que je risquerai de de
d'inquiéter ou de bousculer. Donc moi,
c'est pas l'intention et c'est pas la
méthode que j'ai euh que que j'ai voulu
euh appliquer. Et je pense honnêtement
que par cette méthode, demain, au-delà
même de l'audiovisuel public, n'importe
quel responsable public, n'importe quel
dirigeant d'entreprise publique,
n'importe quel haut fonctionnaire en
charge d'un budget payé par les Français
aura d'une certaine façon peut-être
davantage de précaution, de sentiment de
responsabilité, de vigilance dans
l'utilisation de l'argent des Français
parce qu'il se dira dans 2 ans, 3 ans ou
10 ans, "J'ai pas envie de me retrouver
devant une commission enquête, j'ai pas
envie d'avoir à répondre de
l'utilisation que j'ai faite de l'argent
des Français quand j'étais aux manettes
à ce moment-là. Et donc, je vais
utiliser de la plus grande probité et
précaution dans l'affectation de cet
argent aujourd'hui au moment où je suis
au responsabilité. Donc si au moins
cette insistance qui a été perçue comme
une forme de rôle de procureur ou
d'inquisiteur par certains peut mener à
davantage de probité à en finir avec
cette culture de l'impunité de
fin lié
ou de fin limier et en finir avec cette
culture de l'impunité que ces haut
fonctionnaires et ses dirigeants publics
se disent mince demain on aura peut-être
un all à l'oncle à la tête d'une
commission d'enquête qui nous demandera
des comptes donc on doit faire attention
dans la façon de dépenser l'argent des
français honnêtement ça peut dépasser
l'audis public ce sera une grande
réussite de cette commission d'enquête
et j'assume totalement toutes les
critiques, toutes les insultes, toutes
les outrances que j'ai pu subir et qui
auront je crois été plus que fécondes.
Vous avez terminé sur Caroline Lang ?
Euh Lang
pardon et je fais beaucoup de détours.
Mais bon, sur Caroline Lang c'est ça.
Euh sur Caroline Lang, je c'est pas une
suputation, c'est
probablement la seule proposition que
j'ai réclamé qui m'a été refusée et il y
a eu aucun motif légitime qui m'a été
opposé. La gauche et les Macronistes
dans leur immense majorité en bureau de
commission d'enquête ont fait pour
éviter à tout prix que madame Langue
soit additionné, que je lui pose des
questions probablement peut-être parce
qu'il se disait que j'allais avoir une
tentation de poser des questions qui
pouvaient dépasser le seul cadre de ces
fonctions chez Warner et et au sein de
la société de enfin du syndicat de de
producteurs indépendants. la tentation
aurait été grande parce que je pense
qu'il y a un certain nombre de questions
que les Français se posent notamment sur
la FEPstein. La présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale a refusé la
création d'une commission d'enquête sur
ce sujet. Ça c'est étonnant, elle ne
l'assume même pas. Et d'ailleurs là
encore, vous voyez que c'est pas gauche,
c'est pas droite. Je crois que c'est la
France insoumise qui réclamait
l'ouverture d'une commission d'enquête
sur ce sujet de la de la faire. Non mais
encore, je suis détesté par la par les
représentants de la France insoumiste
qui considèrent qu'à la droite de
Mélenchon, on est forcément un fasciste.
Voyez, moi j'ai un peu plus de tolérance
et d'esprit d'ouverture. Je sais leur
accorder des bons points comme j'en ai
accordé à monsieur Saintou dans la
commission d'enquête. Je sais leur
accorder des bons points quand ils
mettent le doigt sur des sujets
légitimes. Donc moi, j'ai pas compris
pourquoi Yel Bron Pivet avait refusé une
telle commission d'enquête et je n'ai
pas compris pourquoi la gauche comme les
macronistes s'était opposé comme un seul
homme à l'audition de Caroline Langue
alors que elle était présidente du
syndicat des producteurs indépendants et
elle était à la tête de la Warner en
France l'une des principales sociétés à
bénéficier des contrats avec France
Lévision. C'est inadmissible qu'on m'est
opposé un tel refus et ça dit, je crois
aussi beaucoup, parfois la préservation
de certains intérêts qui pensent plus
euh de de représentants du peuple qui
pensent plus à la défense de certains
intérêts plutôt qu'à la défense des
intérêts des Français.
Euh dans votre assaignissement,
vous avez trouvé d'autres trucs un peu
bizarres ou qui sentaient un peu le pâté
ou qui était caché ou qui était genre
des emplois fictifs ? qui pourrait être
considéré comme emploi fictif des
quelques articles 40 des indemnisations,
on sait pas d'où ça sort, pour quel
motif,
des suites d'hôtel.
La liste est tellement longue.
Je peux vous donner deux exemples. Un
premier sur les conflits d'intérêt,
c'est celui de Bernard Henry Lévi
qui a été peu documenté mais Bernard
Henry Lévi, je
jeise pas à attaquer Bernard.
Bon, ça fait je démoncerai ça comme une
pression. Bernard, il a besoin qu'on
finance ses documentaires.
Voilà. Et euh et sauf que les Français
n'ont pas à financer la rénovation de la
villa à Tanger de Bernard Henry Lévi.
Ça, il faut
Vous avez les contrats vous avez les
factures.
Oui, effectivement,
ce qui m'a valu bien des ennemis.
Non, mais vous avez les vous avez de
quoi prouver ce que vous racontez. Ah
oui oui oui.
Et ça figure d'ailleurs dans le rapport
que je vous invite vraiment même si je
sais que vous avez pas eu le temps parce
que il date d'il y a à peine quelques
heures mais vous pourrez retrouver ça
dans le
Je peux vous couper la parole ?
Allez-y. Bien sûr.
Quand vous publiez vos rapports publiés
le soir qu'on est toute la nuit pour le
lire, regardez il y a il y a un truc qui
s'appelle lire SEM.
Ouais.
qui publie des rapports. Bon, de temps
en temps des grosses dobes mal faites,
mais de temps en temps des pures pépites
d'or, des œuvres d'art. Le le rapport
sur la Chine, il doit faire peut-être 3
ou 400 pages, on l'a éclaté dans la nuit
et le lendemain, on a fait l'on a fait
l'ambassadeur de Chine.
La prochaine fois, votre rapport vous
publiez le soir comme ça, on a toute la
nuit pour le lire.
Quand vous le publiez le matin,
regardez, on a comment il s'appelle là
notre premier ministre le corn
le cornu.
Il s'est exprimé sur votre rapport, il
l'a lu en une heure.
S'est exprimé, je crois 50 minutes après
la publication de
et ben il lit très vite, il est premier
ministre. Et Delphine Ernot s'est même
exprimé à 7h58 par un communiqué de
presse sur son compte Twitter qu'elle
n'avait pas utilisé depuis 2 ans.
D'ailleurs en censurant, supprimant la
possibilité de commenter son poste. Ce
qui dit beaucoup aussi de la perception
du pluralisme, la démocratie d'une
présidente de France Télévision. 7h58,
je crois qu'à cette heurelà le rapport
n'était pas encore publié. Donc il a été
publié, je crois, aux alentours de 8h.
Donc il faudra m'expliquer comment
Delphin en 2 ou 3 minutes, alors même
que je crois que le rapport n'était pas
encore publié, a réussi à assimiler 400
pages de rapport qui n'avaient pas
fuité, 80 recommandations pour ne vous
expliquer à quel point mon rapport était
une dube, à quel point c'était une
atteinte à l'état de droit, à la
démocratie et à tout ce qui pouvait
constituer le sel de la démocratie. Ce
serait pas aussiible honnêtement, ça
avait pas été publié avant la
publication du rapport. Enfin, je c'est
là où vous voyez espèce de ils font même
plus semblant de faire semblant. Enfin,
il y a il y a vraiment ce il y a
vraiment ce trucl où ils se disent pas
"Attendez, on va quand même passer pour
des cons." Euh ce communiqué de presse,
il y a x société de de communication
institutionnelle que le contribuat paye
pour défendre d'ailleurs la
communication officielle de madame ces
sociétéslà ont dû se réunir depuis des
jours en disant "Bon, qu'est-ce qu'on va
répondre au rapport de Charles Longue ?
Quand même, il faut réagir. Il y a
beaucoup de Français qui veulent le
lire. Il y a quand même des choses qui
qui sont révélées dans ce cadre là qui
peuvent nous mettre en difficulté. Il
faut préparer un community de presse.
Mais comment ces spin doctor, ces super
communiquants qui sont payés
probablement assez cher ne se sont pas
dit "On va essayer de pas avoir l'air de
pas avoir l'air trop con. On va attendre
à minima 3 ou 4 heur le temps au moins
que les gens se disent bon c'est bon ils
ont lu le rapport ils peuvent avoir la
légitimité de s'exprimer." Non non non.
Ils publient leur communiqué de presse
dans la minute ou une minute avant la
publication du rapport. Et le cornu
c'est pareil.
Le Cornu il est quoi ? Il premier
ministre, il a pas un service de
renseignement
qui lui a fourni votre rapport en
exclusivité. Il était déjà en train de
le de le déguster au petit-déjeuner à
4h50.
Non, ça ressemble à un mauvais SED Chat
GPT. Quand vous regardez le tweet très
long de le cornu, vous vous dites "OK,
le truc est tout droit sorti de de chat
GPT." C'est vraiment vous poser la
question basique que pensez du rapport
de Charles Loncle en l'attaquant sur
voilà qui avait pas lu le rapport
d'ailleurs
qui avait pas eu le rapport mais bon je
pense que vous faites un prompt assez
rapide vous avez exactement le tweet de
Le cornu sans avoir le le rapport et
sans mettre le nez dans ces 400 pages
c'est en tout cas ce à quoi ça ressemble
et je le regrette parce que Sébastien
Lecornu moi je suis ravi qu'il s'empare
de ce sujet-là je suis ravi qu'il tweet
et qu'il s'exprime dans les minutes qui
suivent la publication du rapport ça
montre un intérêt de l'exécutif
D'ailleurs, Catherine Pegar, nouvelle
ministre de la culture, a convoqué
Delphine Arnet et Sibil Veale dans les
heures qui ont précédé à la publication
du rapport pour les mettre autour de la
table et pour leur dire maintenant, il
va falloir mettre en place des réformes.
Donc, on voit aussi que cette commission
d'enquête en dépit des critiques a
permis de faire bouger les lignes. Et il
faut aussi saluer et féliciter le
pragmatisme de ces dirigeants, Finarnut
et Civil Veale et la ministre de la
culture qui se disent on peut pas être
sour à ces critiques et à toutes ces
révélations, mais de voir le premier
ministre qui dans un réflexe purement
politique partisan n'attend même pas de
lire vraiment le rapport pour exprimer
un certain nombre de pistes et dans le
tweet qui fait en fait c'est tiède il y
a même pas le début d'une piste de
recommandation pour dire en quoi il est
pas d'accord avec le rapport en quoi il
est d'accord Quelles sont les bonnes
recommandations qui pourraient être
mises en œuvre, lesquelles en fait ne
sont pas ne sont pas souhaitables pour
le public. Il y a même pas ça espèce de
de de mauvais tweet chat GPT où on
comprend pas vraiment. il nous dit en
fait il faut que tout change pour que
rien ne change. On tient l'audis public,
il doit se réformer mais on doit pas
l'attaquer, on doit pas le critiquer. À
la fin, on comprend rien. Et c'est
dommage parce que quand on fait un
travail si minutieux pendant 6 mois,
c'est à la fin pour donner de la matière
à débat, pour donner de la matière à
réflexion. Et moi, je serais ravi qu'on
m'attaque sur mes propositions, qu'on me
dise sur la 12e, 16e, 32e
recommandation, tu te trompes. Voilà
pourquoi je pense différemment. Voilà
pourquoi je pense que la fusion entre
France 2 et France 5 n'a pas lieu
d'être. Pourquoi on doit pas faire un
seul pôle de chaîne d'information en
continu à vocation internationale ?
Pourquoi on doit pas plafonner euh le
pourcentage le montant total contractuel
passé avec des sociétés de production ?
Pourquoi on doit pas ouvrir à un certain
nombre d'éditaux des des des
éditorialistes et des journalistes de la
presse écrite ? J'aimerais qu'on vienne
me contredire et qu'on vienne argumenter
sur le fond et sur mes recommandations.
Mais c'est même pas ça. On me dit il est
de l'extrême droite, il est dans le
groupe des Ripsotti. Son père a fait
passer des lois soi-disant en reprenant
les arguments d'al contre les Algériens,
ce qui est totalement faux. Il a eu une
plainte contre lui pour pris égal
d'intérêt, ce qui est totalement faux.
Et donc en fait son rapport n'est qu'un
n'est qu'une attaque de l'état de droit
et ne mérite même pas qu'on savez
comment on appelle la FP en Afrique ?
Non.
Agence France propagande.
Bah là ces dernières heures ça y a un
peu ressemblé. Ouais. Je vous avou
le le Qu'est-ce qui vous a le plus
choqué durant vos auditions de ce que
vous avez pu découvrir ? C'est quoi ?
C'est les des potentiels emplois
fictifs, des doubles pleintemps, c'est
des nuits d'hôtel de dingue, c'est des
primes contre silence.
Est-ce qu'il y a eu des articles 40 à la
suite de votre commission ?
Donc, il y a eu un article 40 que j'ai
déposé dans les plus brefs délais parce
que les faits étaient qu'on me
rapportait était tellement accablant que
j'avais peur d'en être complice en les
dénonçant pas. Donc la loi oblige
dans le cadre d'un article 40 toute
personne témoin de fait passibles de de
poursuite pénale de les dénoncer.
Prescription.
Oui, vous avez raison. Euh en fait, ce
sont des faits d'agression sexuelle
dénoncé par une ancienne employée de de
France Télévision qui sont produits au
début des années, enfin fin des années
2000, début des années 2010 qu'elle a
dénoncé auprès de sa direction.
C'est-à-dire ils sont lui a demandé de
quitter l'entreprise de ce terre. Ces
mêmes directeurs euh ont été depuis
promu chez France Tévision. Elle a dû
quitter l'entreprise, a euh reçu une
indemnité compensatoire et en échange,
elle a dû signer un protocole d'accord
qui imposait une clause de
confidentialité. C'est d'ailleurs ce que
a dénoncé ce qu'a dénoncé Jacques Cardos
dans le cadre d'une audition sous
serment où il expliqué il faudrait
s'intéresser à cette dizaine de millions
d'euros d'indemnité de départ qui
parfois achète le silence de victime ou
de témoins de fait d'agression ou de
violence sexuelle. Donc j'ai eu ce
témoignage de cette personne qui est
visiblement ébranlé par ce qui lui est
arrivé, qui aujourd'hui est clean à
s'exprimer à parler et qui a voulu
relayer ça. Donc elle m'a envoyait hein
les captures d'écran. Elle m'a envoyaé
les messages de victimes. Il y a
plusieurs victimes, notamment certains
mineurs qui euh lui ont écrit. Elle
avait dénoncé ses faits auprès de sa
direction. Donc elle m'a envoyé toutes
ces preuves-là sur ma boîte mail
publique. Donc encore une fois, voyez,
sur une boîte mail publique, vous
recevez énormément de contribution. Vos
collaborateurs doivent trier entre le
vrai, le faux et ce genre de fait. Si
vous les dénoncez pas, vous pouvez être
accusé de de complicité. Donc j'ai tout
de suite transmis ça à la procureur de
Paris. C'était lundi 13 avril où j'ai
fait un article 40. J'ai attendu la fin
de la rédaction de de mon rapport, la
présentation aussi des recommandations
et j'ai un certain nombre d'autres
articles 40 qui vont venir parce que
j'ai été témoin effectivement de faits
passibles de poursuite pénale, de la
prise illégale d'intérêt, des pactes de
corruption, des emplois fictifs
principalement, c'est les trois
principaux motifs qui seront euh enfin
qui feront l'objet de d'article 40. Donc
oui, il y a il y a eu beaucoup de de
révélations, j'en ai documenté un
certain nombre. Je me suis arrêté sur
Bernard et Lévi parce que j'étais
j'étais interrompu visiblement. Je je
mais non sur Bernardan et Lévi, je dis
pas que ça fera l'objet d'un article 40
parce que tout ça a été documenté. J'ai
pu interroger d'ailleurs é qui m'a dit
qu'en fait ils avaient contrôlé que ça
n'enfraignait aucune loi mais ça pose
question. Il est président du conseil de
surveillance d'Arté depuis 32 ans. Euh
la limite d'
Il est très bien. Il est très bien.
Alors il est probablement un formidable
président du conseil de surveillance
d'Arté qui est irremplaçable sur
l'appelle là non
sur les près de 70 millions de français.
Je pense que on ne pourra jamais trouver
de de personnes au talent et à la
compétence équivalente de celle de
Bernard Henry Levi. Et donc je pense que
jusqu'à la fin il devra rester
évidemment président du conseil de
surveillance de de d'Arté. [grognement]
faudra-t-il lui faire un hôtel de la
dévotion à l'entrée des studios d'Arté
et je crois que c'est déjà le cas euh et
c'est d'ailleurs tout l'objet de ses
révélations, c'est que il a donc déplacé
à deux reprises les statuts pour rester
euh en dépit de la limite d'âge atteinte
pour rester président du conseil de
surveillance, ce qui ne l'a pas empêché
de faire acheter ses propres
documentaires et films pour 750000 € sur
les 10 dernières années. Un peu plus de
10 dernières années.
750000 sur 10 années ?
Ouais. sur 10 ans de de films et de
documentaires qu'il a lui-même produit
qu'il a vendu à
soit ça ça fait quoi 70000 € par an ?
Ouais, peut-être que ça vous ça vous
choque pas et honnêtement qu'un
président
c'est une boutade
non qu'un président de conseil de
surveillance qui en plus un pouvoir
important parce que c'est lui notamment
avec le conseil de surveillance qui
nomme la direction de la chaîne. Donc
vous voyez vous avez un lien
Ouais. Changeons de sujet. Changeons de
sujet. Euh question euh non vas-y
continue.
Non et [grognement] puis non le dernier
point non le dernier point c'est euh il
il a il avait fait financer un
documentaire sur sa rénovation de villa
à Tanger. Il a une il a une villa à
Tanger. Il y a quelques années. Il avait
Bernard H Leville il avait fait filmer
pour France 5 donc il avait produit un
documentaire qui filmait la rénovation
de sa villa et il avait vendu ce
documentaire à France 5. Donc en fait,
il a remboursé d'une certaine façon la
rénovation de sa villa à Tanger en
mandatant Franc 5 de lui acheter son
documentaire qui filmait la rénovation
de sa villa donc on voit
vous avez des preuves de ça ?
Ah oui oui. Non mais tout ça est
parfaitement documenté. D'ailleurs,
Emcon Emric Caron m'a précédé. Voyez
Emer Caron pareil, il est pas de mon
camp. Je crois qu'il est plutôt du côté
de la France insoumise. Il avait
documenté ça. Je crois d'ailleurs qu'il
a fait un article 40. Il a saisi le
procureur avant la commission d'enquête
pour un fait comme ça. Mais voyez, il y
a une sorte de mélange des genres de
faire financer la rénovation de sa
baraque par le service public en faisant
un documentaire qu'on va vendre à France
5 en mettant en avant un architecte en
lui disant probablement je vais te
mettre en avant donc fais-moi un prix.
Je dis ça, je n'en sais rien par
la suputation. C'est la suspitation mais
en tout cas il y a bien un documentaire
qui a été vendu à France 5 pour filmer
la rénovation de la villa de Bernard
Henry Lévi qu'il a lui-même produit. Bon
tout ça est honnêtement assez étonnant
et euh sur des soupçons d'empla fictif,
il y en a un sur lequel je suis
allègrement revenu, c'est le cas de
monsieur Angacha. Alors monsieur Aacha,
c'est quand même assez dingue. Il est
directeur des opérations spéciales de
France Télévision.
Alors précaution oratoire euh il n'a pas
été encore jugé emploi fictif. Je dis
soupçon.
Je dis soupçon. Il y a une une enquête
qui a été euh qui était euh ouverte et
donc monsieur Engacha est directeur des
opérations spéciales de France
Télévision. Euh il se présente à
l'élection à la mairie de Paris avec
Annie Dalgo, sur la liste d'Annie Dalgo.
Et dans le cadre de cette campagne, il
précise à la presse si je suis élu
notamment si je suis élu maire adjoint,
je ferai j'adapterai mon rythme de
travail à mon nouveau mandat. Sachant
que quand vous êtes adjoint de la
première ville-de-Fance, c'est un temps
plein, ça vous prend beaucoup de temps.
Donc assumer des fonctions de direction
exigeante à la tête de la première
entreprise audiovisuelle français, ça
nécessite quand même à minima un
avenant. Donc il l'annonce, il est élu
maire adjoint Daner
à l'étranger. Il est surnommé, il est
surnommé d'ailleurs le ministre des
affaires étrangères d'Anidalgo. Donc qui
sillonne le monde pour la représenter
Anniealgo à l'étranger
à Paris.
Alors non pas dans Paris,
c'est Paris ou Annie Dalgot qui
représente à l'étranger ?
Alors non, il est adjoint à Paris,
adjoint maire adjoint à Paris Danny
Dalgo, mais il est chargé de la
représenter à l'étranger. Il est d'une
certaine façon
délégué pour la représentation des
affaires internationales d'Ango et de la
mairie de Paris. Donc il sillonne
beaucoup le le monde. On le voit
d'ailleurs sur ses réseaux sociaux,
il y a des miles,
il a probablement beaucoup de de miles.
Euh
les miles qu'on vous p est-ce que les
miles payés par la mairie de Paris vous
appartiennent ou pas ? Ça j'en sais
rien. Ça j'en sais rien.
Est-ce que les cadeaux qu'on achète avec
les miles
faudra qu'on crosse un peu.
Nous à l'assemblée non mais c'est une
bonne question. Nous à l'assemblée moi
je prends très peu l'avion. Euh pour
rentrer chez moi à à Montpellier. Je je
prends toujours le train pour un certain
nombre de de raisons. Mais on a
l'interdiction d'utiliser les miles
cumulés dans le cadre de nos
déplacements en avion payés par
l'Assemblée nationale. C'est la moindre
des choses. On peut pas utiliser un
miles, c'est parfaitement normal. Bon,
monsieur Engacha est élu adjoint Dani
Dalg à la mairie de Paris et là je me
rends compte en regardant les documents,
demandant un certain nombre
d'information à Franceision qu'il y a
aucun avenant qui a été fait depuis
alors qu'on arrive à la fin du mandat de
monsieur Engacha et de de Dan d'Andid
Dalgo, il y a aucun avant qui est fait.
Monsieur Angacha est payé plus de 100000
€ nets comme directeur des opérations
spéciales de France Télévision. Il a ce
temps plein, il est élu pour un autre
tempslin maire adjoint de la première
ville de France d'Ango. Il est payé
60000 € donc il cumule tout ça. C'est
c'est les Français qui payent. Faut
quand même pas se leurer. C'est 100 %
d'argent public.
Et donc c'est pas fini parce que là je
vous présent vous me diriez bon à la
limite France Télévision a fait preuve
d'un peu de de l'alxisme voilà
de mais mais c'est scandaleux déjà là le
cas est scandaleux mais on apprend qu'en
fait il y a pas un directeur des
opérations spéciales chez France
Télévision il y en a deux il y a deux
directeurs des opérations spéciales donc
le monde est grand
oui effectivement et puis les opérations
spéciales c'est quand même quelque chose
d'important chez France Tévision à
condition de savoir exactement ce que ça
recouvre puisque c'est un titre qui est
assez obscure. Et donc pour y voir un
peu plus clair sur cette bureaucratie
chez France les division, j'ai demandé à
monsieur Angé, son homologue aussi
directeur de spéciale de venir nous
détailler en commission d'enquête la
réalité, l'effectivité de leur mission.
Et même le monde qui n'est pas favorable
a convenu qu'à l'issue des 2h30
d'audition, on avait pas compris
grand-chose de la différence de mission
entre ces deux directeurs des opérations
spéciales. Seule différence, c'est qu'il
y en a un qui est rattaché à la
présidente de France Télévision,
monsieur Anga, et l'autre qui est
rattaché au numéro 2 de France
Télévision.
Bon, je je vois que à l'évidence, il y a
un problème. Surtout qu'on apprend dans
la presse que l'assistante de monsieur
Anga a fait un borout. Donc le burout,
j'ai appris ce que c'était. C'est
l'inverse du burnout. C'est quand vous
avez tellement pas de travail que vous
vous ennuyez, que vous mettez en arrêt
de travail parce que vous vous avez une
sorte de sentiment de déprime. Il y a
une dépression forte parce que vous
arrivez enfin vous ne bossez pas.
Utilité.
Voilà. Donc ça ça a été révélé par la
presse et euh le l'histoire n'était pas
terminée parce que on a pu voir à cette
occasion, moi j'ai demandé à Delphin
Arnut lorsqu'elle est venue en audition.
Je dis bon, monsieur Ang est l'un des
deux directeurs des opérations
spéciales, il est adjoint à la mairie de
Paris, il a pas eu d'avenant si vous
pouvez nous prouver qu'il effectue
clairement ses missions et quelles sont
les missions qu'il effectue qui
justifient d'ailleurs qu'il soit payé
100000 € net par an par les Français.
Elle dit "Vous savez, monsieur ANG, il
travaille beaucoup, c'est pas du tout un
emploi fictif, je tiens à l'affirmer, je
suis souserment, je vais vous le dire."
Monsieur Anga, par exemple s'est occupé
du téléton d'Elpineut sous serment. Son
audition, tout ça est retraçable.
Quelques jours après, on a monsieur en
audition qui prête serment. Je dis bon
bahon
c'était bien.
Alors le Téléton, on vous le doit. Merci
pour tout. En tout cas, Delphine Arnold
sous Sermon nous a expliqué que vous
étiez occupé du Téléton. Vous pouvez
nous dire ce que vous avez fait
effectivement. Et alors non pas du tout.
Je crois qu'il y a eu il y a une
confusion, il y a eu méprise. En fait,
je me suis pas du tout occupé du
Téléton.
Donc on a deux personnes sous serment
qui ont des positions contradictoires
sur un sujet quand même assez
fondamental, les soupçon d'effectivité
de mission d'un directeur des opérations
spéciales élu maire adjoint Danny Delgo
à la mairie de Paris qui est censé la
représenter dans ses affaires
internationales et qui sillonne le monde
pour la représenter qui n'a même pas
fait d'avenant avec France Télévision
pour essayer d'alléger et de d'adapter
son rythme de travail qui est toujours à
temps plein alors qu'il aurait dû à
minima ou 3/5e et qui nous dit non non
en fait la personne personne à qui je
réfère qui m' N + 1 DPIN Arnod vous a
dit de je m'occupais du Téléton en fait
non elle s'est trompé je m'occupe pas du
Téléton vous avez ça en plus de ça à
côté de lui il a un autre directeur des
opérations spéciales dont vous devenez
fou vous dites
Delfine elle s'était peut-être trompé de
nom
non non je
non
elle s'est pas trompé de nom parce que
elle a bien vu de j'insister sur le
profil de de monsieur Gacha elle l'avait
parfaitement en tête c'est d'ailleurs
son N-1 directement et à la fin elle est
revenue dans une dernière audition je
dis bon madame vous étiez sous serment
vous nous avez dit que monsieur c
s'était s'est occupé du Téléton. Il nous
a dit quelques jours après lui aussi
sous serment qu'il s'occupait pas du
Téléton. Dites-nous parce qu'il y en a
un des deux qui était sous serment qui a
menti. Elle me dit non effectivement je
me suis trompé. Monsieur Angacha s'est
pas occupé du Téléton. Bon voilà je vais
pas faire une procédure de par jour pour
ça. Et
donc il s'occupe de quoi lui ? Il faudra
lui demander, il faudra lui demander et
et c'est c'est tout le problème. Non
mais honnêtement, c'est tout le problème
parce que il y a deux directeurs des
opérations spéciales titre quand même
assez ronflant opération spéciale je à
la limite quand on bosse pour la DGSE,
quand on bosse pour des industries, des
entreprises d'armement
honorable contributeur non même pas.
Ouais non mais c'est ça mais bon là les
opérations spéciales et donc voilà. Bon,
c'est un cas parmi d'autres, mais pour
vous quand je parle d'assaignir les
pratiques pour revenir à ça, que vous
expliquez que le terme est fort
d'assainissement parce que ça renvoie un
vocabulaire peut-être
champ lexical,
un champ lexical un peu de de
on va curer les les écuries d'OGIAS, on
va assaignir les canalisations des
égouts. Euh ça ressemble un peu à ça,
non Ça ressemble un peu à ça, mais quand
vous êtes exposé à ce type de pratique
de conflit d'intérêt, de soupçon
d'emploi fictif, de personnes qui vous
disent pas vraiment la vérité, qui
ignorent l'effectivité d'émission, de
personnes qui sont payées 100000 € net
par an, 100000 € net par an, je pense
que on peut regarder, j'ai pas regardé
mais dans le dans l'échelle des salaires
à 100000 € nets par an, vous devez
honnêtement être dans le pourcent le
premier pour des Français qui gagnent le
plus. Delpine Arnut, elle gagne combien
? Elle gagne 400000 €.
Euh, [grognement] elle a d'autres
boulots à côté.
Alors, en fait, elle gagne 400000 €.
Euh,
j'ai j'ai peur de vous dire une bêtise.
Par moi ou par an ?
Non, parents non, parents quand même.
Mais euh non, ce qui est assez étonnant
d'ailleurs, c'était le motif de d'un
certain nombre de questions, c'est que
elle a perçu près de 70000 € de prime de
performance. Elle a perçu 98,5
% de sa prime de performance l'année
dernière. Et donc je lui ai posé des
questions parce que je lui ai dit
"Attendez, j'ai lu le rapport de la cour
des comptes qui est sortie il y a
quelques mois où on voit que
vous avez fait plonger la trésorerie
dans le rouge alors qu'elle était
abondée à hauteur de plusieurs dizaines
de millions d'euros."
Est-ce que je peux vous couper ? Quand
on l'a vu pendant la commission, elle
était venue avec ses petites pancartes
là. Vous vous rappelez du moment là ?
Vous pouvez m'expliquer un peu ça ?
moment mensonger, moment totalement
mensongé où on passe les 25 premières
minutes de cette audition qui est
importante pour laquelle j'ai des
dizaines de questions fondamentales à
lui poser. Je veux simplement rétablir
un point. Le point c'est que depuis des
semaines, je lis dans la presse les
arguments de finir notes qui sont
relayés sans même un checking de la part
des journalistes qui expliquent si il y
a eu un déficit cumulé par France
Télévision, c'est parce que les
dotations publiques attribuées à France
Télévision ont diminué.
C'est l'argument, c'est si on a mis les
comptes dans le rouge et que
l'entreprise se porte mal
financièrement, c'est parce que au fond
les Français contribuent moins. Donc
moi, c'est un argument qui est
important. J'ai voulu vérifier, j'ai
regardé, j'ai ouvert le rapport de la
Cour des comptes et dans ce rapport de
la Cour des comptes, je vois que entre
l'année 2015, année de prise de fonction
de Delphine Arnut, première année où
elle est présidente et l'année 2024, la
dernière année vérifiée par la Cour des
comptes dans le rapport, il y a une
augmentation de 136 millions d'euros. de
dotation publique.
Donc je ne comprends pas comment
Delphine Ernot et les dirigeants de
France Télévision et une bonne partie
des médias puisse relayer une telle
information qui est une fake news qui
est de dire les dotations publiques à
date validées par la Cour des comptes
ont diminué par rapport à la prise de
fonction de Delphine Airot. Donc je
démarre cette audition en lui disant
"Madame Anaut, est-ce que vous convenez
alors que je vous ai entendu plutôt dire
le contraire publiquement qu'entre 2015
et 2024 les dotations publiques ont
augmenté de 136 millions d'euros par an
? Enfin 136 millions d'euros." Et là
elle me dit "Non, non, monsieur le
rapporteur, ce que vous dites est faux.
Ce que vous dites est faux." Elle le dit
sous serment. Je dis "Mais attendez,
telle page du rapport de la Cour des
comptes, on voit x milliard en 2015.
telle page en 2024, on voit x milliard.
Je fais une soustraction, c'est pas très
difficile, ça fait 136 millions
d'augmentations. J'ai le rapport de la
Cour des comptes sous les yeux, je vous
le montre. Elle me dit non, monsieur le
rapporteur, ce que vous dites est un
mensonge. Et donc là, elle s'emporte.
Elle dit "Mais vous savez moi monsieur
le rapporteur, j'en ai marre de vos
mensonges, j'en ai marre de vos fake
news. Moi, ça fait 30 ans que gère des
entreprises, ça fait 30 ans que d'une
certaine façon, j'ai pas de leçons à
recevoir." Et elle nous sort une
pancarte avec des chiffres d'évolution
de la dotation publique qui indiquent
que la dotation publique a baissé entre
2015 et 2024. Et elle dit "Mais voyez,
ces chiffres, ils sont publics. Ces
chiffres, tout le monde peut les
consulter. Franceelévision.fr."
Ah, c'est de la source. Ah, ça c'est de
la source par rapport à la cour des
comptes, par rapport à des chiffres de
haut magistrat qui sont plongés quand
même dans les comptes pour la première
fois en 9 ans. Donc, ils avaient quand
même un petit peu de travail à réaliser,
de comparer les chiffres de la cour des
comptes factuels avéré au chiffres de la
direction de France Télévision sur le
site franévision.fr.
C'est hallucinant. Je vais même vous
vous dire mieux. Je suis allé sur le
site franévision.fr et j'ai vu quelque
chose de très grave. J'ai vu un
communiqué de presse qui date du 13 mars
2025. J'invite tous vos auditeurs à
aller taper communiqué de presse 13 mars
2025 France Télévision. Sur ce
communiqué de presse, vous pouvez voir
le titre du communiqué, peut-être le
ressortir mot pour mot pour la 9e année
consécutive France Télévision mais c'est
compte à l'équilibre. Et dans mot pour
mot, c'est le titre, il se félicite
d'une 9e année soi-disant à l'équilibre
des comptes de France Télévision. Et au
sein du comuniqué de presse, vous pouvez
voir que il loue, il se félicite. C'est
un exercice d'autocongratulation payé
par nos impôts dans un exercice
totalement fallacieux, pour ne pas dire
mensonger, où ils disent euh pilotage
dynamique de ressources, maîtrise des
dépenses, effort quasiment de rigueur
budgétaire, il conclu pour la 9e année,
c'est formidable, les comptes sont à
l'équilibre. 13 mars 2025, quelques
mois, quelques semaines seulement après,
les cours des comptes sont en rapport en
disant "Mais attendez, entre 2017 et
2024, il y a eu 81 millions d'euros de
déficit qui a été cumulé. Les comptes
sont dans le rouge. L'entreprise est
menacée de dissolution. Les capitaux
propres sont inférieurs à la moitié du
capital social. Pierre Moskovici, ancien
socialiste qu'on peut pas accuser de mon
camp, explique que la situation
financière de France Tévision est telle
qu'aucune autre entreprise ne pourrait
la soutenir. Bon, comment vous expliquer
que la communication institutionnelle
officielle de France Télévision, dont
tous les Français sont coactionnaires et
cofinanceurs puissent expliquer sur son
site internet qu'ils n'ont toujours pas
corrigé, ils n'ont toujours pas modifié
ou supprimé ce communiqué de presse ?
Comment vous pouvez
voir, justifier, expliquer qu'ils font
une telle communication financière aussi
fallacieuse qui donne l'impression que
depuis 9 ans, il y a une rigueur et que
les comptes chaque année sont à
l'équipe, qu'il y a pas de déficit au
fond qui a été cumulé alors que la Cour
des comptes dit strictement l'inverse.
Donc moi, c'est ce qui m'a vraiment
énervé parce que j'ai été accusé par la
direction de France Tévision, par un
certain nombre de médias complaisant
systématiquement de diffuser soi-disant
des fausses informations, de diffuser
des mensonges parce que je me référais
au chiffres de la Cour des courtes,
parce que je dénonçais ces communiqués
de presse totalement falacieux et
mensongés parce que j'ai osé à Delphine
Arnut, vous pouvez pas dire que les
dotations publiques ont baissé entre
2015 et 2024, c'est faux, elles ont
augmenté de 136 millions. Il y a une
espèce de de de chasse de repost payé
par nos impôts par ces dirigeants de
France Télévision qui ont essayé de
semer le trouble et de me disqualifier
en disant non, c'est le rapporteur qui m
et pas plus tard qu'aujourd'hui. France
Télévision a même mis ses moyens
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux à
disposition pour discréditer le rapport.
C'est pas simplement Delphine Ernote qui
à 7h58 avant même que le rapport soit
publié a fait un communiqué de presse
pour expliquer à quel point mon mon
rapport était mauvais alors que
visiblement lire 400 pages en 2 minutes
c'était impossible. C'est aussi la
communication officielle de France
Télévision sur ses propres réseaux
sociaux qui a publié des tweets pour
venir discréditer le rapport. Monsieur
Saint-Thou, j'ai l'impression que c'est
une sorte de référent, mais Monsieur
Saint-U qui m'a beaucoup critiqué dans
le cadre de la commission d'enquête
parce qu'on n'est pas d'accord sur un
certain nombre de constat et de
recommandations, lui-même a tweeté, il
appartient à la France insoumise en
disant c'est inacceptable qu'une
entreprise publique objet d'une
commission d'enquête mette ses moyens à
sa disposition payés par les Français
pour aller nier, pour aller attaquer,
pour aller discréditer le travail
parlementaire. C'est inacceptable. Donc
quand vous voyez cette pratique du
mensonge totalement officialisée,
totalement assumée, quand vous voyez les
moyens aussi de ces entreprise publique
que l'on paye qui servent aussi à
défendre les intérêts personnels de
quelques dirigeants qui n'ont que faire
de la sincérité de l'information et de
la vérité, vous posez vraiment des
questions sur les intérêts de ce système
qui se défend depuis de trop nombreuses
années.
J'ouvre une parenthèse. Vous avez le
numéro de Jérémy ?
Ouais, je l'ai. Ouais. Bon, vous lui
demanderez si vous pouvez nous le passer
comme ça on lui proposera de venir à
l'occase. Question : " Vous parliez de
prime de de performance, on a compris
que qui c'est qui donne le le la note
sur la prime de performance ?
C'est le conseil d'administration. On a
appris d'ailleurs qu'Emmanuel Grégoire,
nouveau maire de Paris, qui était au
conseil d'administration de France
Télévision. Donc, il y a un petit encart
d'ailleurs dans mon rapport qui montre
les liens entre la mairie de Paris et le
Parti socialiste, c'est des dirigeants
de France Télévision. On a parlé de
monsieur Engacha, mais on peut aussi
parler d'Emmanuel Grégoire. Emmanuel
Grégoire était donc membre du conseil
d'administration de France visision
avant d'être maire de Paris et on a vu
dans le compte-rendu sur le vote de la
prime de performance qu'il a été l'un
des seuls à exiger à demander
l'attribution de 100 % de la prime de
performance de madame Ana.
Il avait peut-être jugé que le travail
était bien fait. Ah ben quand vous
mettez les comptes dans le rouge, quand
vous cumulez 80 millions d'euros de
déficit, quand la trésorerie devient
négative, pour justifier une prime de
performance à hauteur de 100 %, c'est
quand même assez fort. Et
par 100 %.
Et je vais vous dire, elle a obtenu 98,5
%. Est-ce que vous savez pourquoi elle
n'a pas obtenu 100 % dans le
compte-rendu ? C'est parce que les
objectifs de réduction d'émission de gaz
à effet de serre de France Lévision
n'ont pas été atteints. Je C'est pas du
tout une blague.
C'est très très grave.
C'est très grave.
C'est très grave. Et c'est la raison
pour laquelle madame
sont passé au toilet de sèche
sanctionné.
Malheureusement, je ne crois pas. C'est
la raison pour laquelle madame Ernut n'a
pas 100 % de sa prime de performance.
Non, c'est c'est évidemment de la
dérision, mais quand vous voyez l'écart,
enfin quand vous voyez qu'on arrive à
attribuer à un dirigeant d'entreprise
publique qui crame autant la caisse, qui
incarne d'une certaine façon ce
sentiment d'irresponsabilité,
d'impunité, quand vous voyez que son
conseil d'administration est capable de
lui attribuer à une prime de performance
à ce niveau-là, vous dites qu'il y a un
énorme travail de refondation à faire.
Est-ce que vous avez crevé ? Est-ce que
pardon ? Est-ce que vous avez creusé
dans le détail ? J'allais dire crever
l'absè. Est-ce que vous avez creusé dans
le détail les autres pourquoi elle avit
peut-être 95 ? Elle était peut-être
contente parce que les employés étaient
contents. Euh, il y avait des gens qui
étaient heureux au travail, il y avait
moins de démission, je sais pas, il y
avait du cordon bleu à la cantine.
J'ai posé ces questions effectivement
parce que c'est vrai c'est une vraie
source d'interrogation. Comment elle
peut obtenir 9,5 % avec ses résultats
financiers pareil alors qu'elle a euh
des audiences de dingue peut-être ?
Alors non, même pas. Les audiences sont
sont en baisse. Elle avait fait un
cé la faute à YouTube.
Elle avait fait un grand projet. Non
mais alors pour le coup, on peut pas on
peut pas lui tenir rigueur. Les
audiences baissent pour l'ensemble des
chaînes de télévision effectivement.
Donc que les audiences d'âge de
de France Tévision, c'est l'une des
moyennes d'âge les plus élevées.
J'allais y venir. C'est au-delà de 60
ans. Att merde non mais c'est cette
histoire. Non, mais vous disiez sur ses
objectifs, elle avait dans ses objectifs
un rajunissement de l'audience qui était
un des objectifs fondamentaux qui
d'ailleurs je crois figuré aussi dans
les conditions d'attribution de la prime
de performance. Et depuis qu'elle a été
nommée en 2015, bon, les audiences ont
fait que que que
enfin vieillir, le terme est pas tout à
fait exact, mais en tout cas que reculer
en terme en terme d'âge. Alors que
pourtant, elle s'était dotée de moyens
importants. Elle avait doté notamment
France TV/ un montant important, très
beau.
C'est quoi ? France TV/ash/ash
France TV/ c'est la plateforme numérique
à destination des jeunes jeunes public.
Netflix pour France TV.
Ouais, c'est vraent le Netflix du pauvre
très militant qui est dire quoi ? très
militant.
Très militant, c'est parce que ça relait
par exemple une cagnotte pour le comité
justice pour Adama Traoré. Ça relaus qui
expliquent qu'il faut arrêter de dire
bonjour madame ou bonjour monsieur pour
éviter de mes gens et les personnes. Ça
relait des contenus qui euh relais des
thèses racialistes préoccupantes parce
que ça parle à l'envie de de privilège
blanc parce que ça déculpabilise et ça
vient normaliser l'usage de champignons
hallucinogène et ça explique que le
cannabis peut être un levier de relance
de l'économie. Enfin, il y a une
centaine de contenus délirants.
Ouais, ça s'adresse aux 15 35 ans. Ah,
et il y a même il y a eu des études
comme quoi le cannabis chez les jeunes,
c'était pas très bon pour le cerveau.
Voilà. Mais bon, ça ça le la part
scientifique dans ce genre de contenu,
j'ai l'impression que la destination des
jeunes, il préfèrent la dimension
militante que la dimension scientifique.
Alors que sur le service public, on
devrait faire davantage de place au
contenu scientifique. Notamment, je
pense à ces pas sorciers qui sont des
émissions magnifiques de transmission à
caractère pédagogique pour les jeunes,
mais bon, on préfère faire davantage de
place au contenu militant. Et le dernier
exemple, mais il y en a bien d'autres,
on pourrait y passer la soirée sur euh
France TV/, c'est euh des contenus qui
incitaient à consommer des contenus à
caractère pornographique euh transsexuel
alors qu'on s'adresse à un public
mineur. Donc euh ça peut être de la la
corruption de mineur.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez dit là ? Il y a
eu des publications sur France TV/ash
qu'il regrette d'ailleurs aujourd'hui,
même si Delphine Arnet explique qu'ils
assument tout. Euh les les directeurs
euh direct de France TV/ash en audition
expliqué qu'il regretta un certain
nombre de contenus. Je crois que
celui-ci le regrette mais il y en a eu
d'autres qui
attention on n'est pas là pour croire
non mais alors ils mettaient de l'eau de
l'eau dans leur vent. La Mern a assumé
les contenus de France CV slash. Eux ont
mis de l'eau dans leur vin en expliquant
que sur une certaine période, il y avait
peut-être eu un peu trop de
militantisme. Il avait dévoyé cette
mission euh notamment de de contenu qui
pouvaient intéresser les les jeunes
publics et notamment les mineurs. Et
donc oui, il y a eu des contenus qui
valorisaient ou qui faisaient la
promotion de contenu à caractère
pornographique euh de contly fan, de
pornographie transsexuelle. Et quand
j'ai interrogé ces personnes qui ont été
responsables de cette ligne éditoriale à
l'époque, ils m'ont expliqué oui en fait
euh pour les mineurs, comme il consomme
déjà du contenu pornographique, on se
disait que la pornographie transsexuelle
était une pornographie
plus éthique.
Mais non, mais il y a c'est interdit le
conduct pornographique pour les murs.
Pour les mineurs. Ouais. Et pourtant, on
a un
c'est combien ? C'est 75000 € d'amende,
30 ans de taux ou
pour la corruption de mineur. Ouais. Ça
doit être une peine assez élevée et
pourtant voilà on finance en service
public qui sur sa plateforme numérique à
destination des jeunes qui abondé à
hauteur de 17 ou 18 millions d'euros par
an. Sûr de ça ?
Je suis sûr de ça. Je suis sûr de ça. Je
vous enverrai toutes les captures
d'écran d'ailleurs pour certaines que
j'ai publié sur mes réseaux sociaux que
j'ai montré à Delphine Arnut et aux
dirigeants de de France Télévision. Bon,
ils assument d'une certaine façon que
ils ont des regrets. Ils ont des regrets
et c'est et c'est pas normal. Il y a eu
plus d'une centaine de contenus dénoncés
par des associations euh de vigilance
citoyenne qui ont expliqué, c'est
quelques exemple que je vous cite, mais
qui ont expliqué que c'était des
contenus anormaux pour le service
public.
Euh je passe un message à la communauté
qui est en direct, qui pose les
questions sur Twitter. Euh il y a
beaucoup de questions, il y en a au
moins 57 et on va pas lire toutes les 57
questions. Donc je vous demande de faire
de l'intelligence collaborative et de
liker les questions que vous avez envie
qu'on lise et qu'on pose à Charles à
l'oncle. Pendant que je pose ma dernière
question avant la question de la
communauté, [souffle coupé]
même que ça va être deux questions.
Est-ce que vous trouvez que sur certains
points vous avez merdé dans la
commission ? Vous aurez pu être meilleur
?
Je pense qu'on fait toujours des
erreurs.
Vous avez eu une conduite introspective
?
J'ai pas assez de recul aujourd'hui. Je
vous avoue que je suis encore dans le
rush du service à prévente de ce
rapport. Je je ferai cet exercice
nécessaire d'introspection. Vous savez,
le doute m'habite constamment, je pense
évidemment.
Le doute.
Le doute, ouais, le doute. Euh,
plutôt chrétien,
c'est ça. Et puis je je pu lire des
critiques, j'ai pu lire un certain
nombre aussi de messages. Je suis très
perméable et très sensible aussi à tout
ça, même si j'ai essayé de de me créer
une sorte de carapace et [grognement]
d'étoffer un peu ce ce cette peau pour
pour en être le plus insensible
possible. Mais oui, probablement que
j'ai dû faire des erreurs que j'ai dû en
faire aussi beaucoup. J'ai malgré tout
essayé de rester le plus
courtois, le plus posé, le plus calme
possible dans les questions que je
pouvais poser. Alors après, il y a eu
des auditions qui ont été très
médiatiques, celle de Patrick Cohen, de
Thomas Logran, on a parlé de Xavierel,
on a parlé de Nagi,
Patrick Sébastien. Patrick Sébastien ?
Oui, mais celle de Patrick Sébastien,
elle a été médiatique mais il y a pas eu
de il y a pas eu de clash, ce qu'on peut
appeler un clash, mais il y a
effectivement eu des auditions où il y a
eu des clashes euh Patrick Cohen qui
retourne systématiquement les questions
que je lui pose. Bon bah, je j'ai dû lui
rappeler qu'il était pas sur un plateau
de France 5 qui si c'était une
commission d'enquête et que la personne
qui posait la question c'était moi. Et
quand je revois l'extrait qui
aujourd'hui agrement diffusé où on me
dit bah regardez c'est un procureur,
c'est un inquisiteur, il rappelle il
rappelle à l'ordre Patrick Cohen et lui
dit que c'est pas Patricken de poser les
questions, c'est lui qui pose les
questions quand je revois
rétrospectivement l'extrait et il faut
voir le contexte tous les jeudis donc
déjà on avait tr ou qu jours par semaine
d'audition on démarrait à 9h du matin on
finissait souvent à 20h. On avait une
trentaine de minutes simplement à
l'heure du déjeuner pour pour faire une
pause. On avait enchaîné deux ou tr
jours de de d'audition. Donc en fait
vous arrivez l'audition de Patrick Cohen
l'audition de Thomas Land, elle venait
achever une semaine assez éprouvante.
Alors, je dis pas je trouve je compte
pas trouver des excuses, mais il y a
aussi un état de fatigue où quand pour
la 50 fois de la semaine, vous posez une
question, vous avez pas de réponse, on
part dans le décor, on vous retourne une
accusation, en fait à la fin vous pouvez
être un peu donc peut-être que mon
principal regret c'est
de pas avoir suffisamment
à chaque fois qu'un début d'agacement
pouvant être témoigné, pris un peu de
mesure, pris un peu de recul. et me dire
ce qui compte à la fin, c'est que il y
ait aucune perception d'alliement, il y
a aucune perception de de
partialité, il y a aucune perception de
d'intention de mettre en défaut la
personne qui est en face. Sur 250 heures
d'auditions, sur plus de 70 auditions,
c'est pas toujours évident. Mais oui, je
pense qu'il y a des moments, c'était à
refaire, je les referai différemment.
J'éviterai à tout prix les clashes parce
que ce que je regrette c'est que à la
fin on ne s'intéresse qu'à ces grands
moments euh de prise de bec. On
s'intéresse à Xavier Daniel qui se lève
et qui explique ceci estir que monsieur
le rapporteur, je suis pas un clown.
Alors ça ça passe, ça passe, ça passe.
Il avait prévu sa punchline et donc ça a
bien marché parce que ça passe
allègrement et donc tout le monde se dit
bon bah le le rapporteur c'est la politi
spectacle. Donc j'aurais à tout prix
évité et fait la plus grande précaution
pour queit le moins de clash possible.
Donc voilà, c'est peut-être un regret
que que j'ai.
Question Internet, votre objectif est-il
de rendre le service public neutre
virgule en donnant la parole à tout le
monde ? [raclement de gorge] Point
d'interrogation ou finalement tout cela
n'est-il qu'une histoire de paroisse et
le seul objectif est de transférer la
mane vers des gens que vous aimez. et je
lis entre les lignes. En gros, c'est
transférer ce qui part à gauche pour
transférer à droite juste avant les
élections présidentielles ou faire
perdre le le principal organe, je mets
entre guillemets et euh
c'est-à-dire le principal organe de la
gauche ou du centre gauche pour
influencer sur les élections
présidentielles ou d'être où dette le
rempart contre les chaînes privées.
Je comprends totalement les questions.
Pour vous donner un exemple, je me suis
largement intéressé à la société Banig.
Beniger, c'est une société qui est
détenue enfin qui est en tout cas
dirigée par Stéphane Courbi. Stéphane
Courbi, c'est un grand ami de Nicolas
Sarkozy. Je me suis prê Il a le droit
d'être amis avec Nicolas Sarkozy.
Oui, mais ils investissent, ils ont un
certain nombre d'investissements
communs, ils se connaissent très bien.
Je crois que monsieur Sarkozy est au
conseil d'administration de Stéphane
Courbi.
C'était peut-être des bons
investisseurs.
Oui, mais j'ai pas fait un j'ai pas fait
preuve de la totale transparence quand
je me suis présenté, mais politiquement
quand j'étais étudiant, j'étais
président des jeunes avec Nicolas
Sarkozii. Alors, j'adore l'homme en
quelle année ça ? C'était dans les
années 2010. Alors, j'adore le le la
bête politique qu'il est. J'ai un peu de
recul sur le bilan. Pour autant, je
garde une forme une vraie admiration
pour l'homme politique vraiment qu'il a
été.
C'est un écrivain extraordinaire.
Prolix.
Prolix et rapide. Très très rapide.
Je soupçonne une pointe de d'ironie de
votre part mais non, on peut pas lui
enlever on peut pas lui enlever en tout
cas un succès populaire et une capacité
de de rédaction beaucoup de les vieux.
Non, je j'ai l'impression quand vous
regardez les fils de vente dans les
librairies où il vient dédicacer ses
livres, c'est quand même assez assez
bon, je suis pas là pour être
moi, je préfère regarder sa déclaration
d'impôt mais
il gagne de l'argent un peu, non ?
Combien combien il a pris de million la
dernière fois là ? 14 l'année dernière
et euh
j'ai peur de dire une bêtise mais je
crois que c'est temps là.
Ouais ouais, il faut regarder le détail,
il y a des gros chèqus
mais tout ça pour dire que vous voyez
euh j'ai été proche un temps de Nicolas
Sarkozy et pourtant Stéphane Courbi qui
est considéré comme son meilleur ami, je
me suis intéressé en profondeur à sa
société de production dont d'ailleurs
Nagy est coactionnaire. Et vous voyez
s'il y a un ennemi viscéral visiblement
que je me suis fait à l'issue des
questions que j'ai posé, c'est Nag qui
m'en veut, qui m'a jeté en pâure sur ses
réseaux sociaux qui je pense va
continuer à essayer de de me diffamer et
de m'accabler. Et donc si j'avais
protégé les intérêts personnels des très
bons amis et même de Nicolas Sarkozy à
qui je dois quand même une forme
d'initiation politique, je ne me serai
jamais intéressé à Benig, je ne me
serais jamais intéressé à Stéphane
Courby, je ne me serais jamais intéressé
à NI, je ne me serais jamais intéressé à
Takis Scandilis qui pourtant a effectué
une navette que j'ai dénoncé qui était
directeur de la fiction de Beniger qui
se fait embaucher comme directeur
adjoint des antennes et des programmes
de France Télévision et qui ensuite
rebascule chez Banig tout ça en faisant
augmenter de façon très importante le
volume contractuel entre France
Télévision et cette société de
production. Je n'aurais jamais braqué ce
projecteur si j'avais cédé à la moindre
faiblesse d'amitié ou de proximité avec
des gens qui partagent mes idées ou avec
des gens en tout cas pour qui j'aurais
pu avoir une une allégece passée. Et à
tous ceux qui me disent aussi que je
pourrais être un émisère de Boloré. Ben
monsieur Boloré, vous voyez, il est
aussi actionnaire de Bigé. Il est
actionnaire alors actionnaire
minoritaire, il siège pas au conseil
d'administration, mais si j'avais été
soi-disant un émissaire de monsieur
Boloré, je me serais jamais intéressé à
nouveau ni à Banigé, ni à Nagi, ni à
Takis Scandellis, ni à Stéphane Courbi.
Je les aurais largement préservés et je
me serais intéressé à bien d'autres
animateurs producteurs, à bien d'autres
émissions, à bien d'autres contenus.
Donc encore une fois quand on c'est pas
du tout le sens de la question de la
personne qui qui vous la poser, elle est
légitime, mais quand on a pu me faire le
procès d'être un agent de la
privatisation, d'être un agent de
Bolloré, aujourd'hui on fait le procès
d'être un agent de l'ORTF.
Vous avez déjà rencontré Bolloré ?
Jamais.
Vous avez [raclement de gorge] des
copains qui connaissent Bolloré ?
Alors, j'ai des amis qui l'ont
rencontré. Effectivement,
rencontrer dans quelqu'un ? Un petit
dîner, une poignée de main, vernissage,
une remise de médailles. Comment ça se
passe
alors ? Euh,
Bretagne à la messe ?
Non, même pas. Même pas en
Bretagour d'un petit Queen
non même pas même pas en Bretagne mais
bon c'est des gens qui ont monté des
entreprises qui ont élargi ont
diversifié leur capital et les
investisseurs qui sont aujourd'hui au au
conseil d'administration de leurs
entreprises et qui ont eu des
discussions avec monsieur Boloré ou ses
représentants.
Ces gens-là ils vous ont appelé ?
Non ces gens-là ne m'ont pas appelé. Non
ces gens-là ne m'ont pas appelé et donc
je n'ai jamais rencontré monsieur
Boloré. D'ailleurs, la question lui a
été posée. Il était sous par une députée
socialiste qui était persuadé de tenir
un scoop complet en lui disant "Est-ce
que vous pouvez nous le dire ? Vous êtes
sous, vous avez déjà rencontré ou
échangé avec monsieur àoncle ? Jamais
changé le moindre message, jamais eu le
moindre appel, pas le moindre mail,
jamais la moindre rencontre et tout ça
est vérifiable.
Vous connaissez vous connaissez Nicolas
Sarkozy mieux que moi.
Alors ça Nicolas Sarkozi, je peux je
peux pas en dire autant. effectivement,
je le connais.
Ouais. [raclement de gorge]
Et je et je l'ai vu. Euh,
vous avez peut-être un téléphone avec un
nom genre Paul Bismut que on vous a
envoyé que des
D'accord. Il y a pas eu de
Et voyez, je suis au début de ma
carrière politique, sera d'ailleurs
peut-être pas très longue. Euh, on sait
jamais, il faut toujours se soumettre.
On a un mandat qui ne nous appartient
pas et c'est la décision des Français,
il faudra toujours la respecter. Mais je
peux vous dire très honnêtement, je ne
l'ai jamais rencontré, jamais écrit,
jamais appelé, jamais le moindre mail.
La première fois où j'ai où je l'ai vu,
où j'ai échangé avec lui, c'était quand
il est venu en audition dans le cadre de
la commission d'enquête. D'ailleurs,
quand la députée socialiste lui a posé
la question, je pense qu'elle était très
déçu parce qu'il a dit "Bah non,
première fois que je rencontre monsieur
à l'oncle, je crois qu'il a dit il a
l'air très efficace euh et sympathique.
Je crois que c'est les deux mots qu'il a
qu'il a donné." Et voilà. Mais bon, tout
ça pour dire les critiques que je peux
avoir. Émissaur de de monsieur Boloré.
Je me serais jamais intéressé à Banigé,
je me serais jamais intéressé à N, je me
serais jamais intéressé à tous ces
sujets-là.
agent de la privatisation. Depuis le
premier jour, j'ai toujours dit que je
tenais aux missions utiles de l'autel
public et que j'étais pas là pour
privatiser. Et tous ces gens-là
aujourd'hui se retrouvent un peu gros
gens comme devant. Alors expression un
peu un peu un peu étonnante. Ça fait 15
ans que j'ai pas employé cette
expression mais ça me fait plaisir de
l'employer. Mais il se retrouve gros
gens comme devant parce que dans les 400
pages de rapport il y a pas une fois le
terme en tout cas il y a pas une fois la
proposition de privatisation qui figure.
Et la troisème accusation de G c'est
c'est un agent il veut revenir à l'ORTF.
Donc il faudra choisir. Moi, je demande
à mes détracteurs de choisir. Est-ce que
je suis pour la privatisation et à
vendre le public à monsieur Boloré à des
milliardaire ou est-ce que je suis un
agent de l'ORTF qui veut encore plus
nationaliser et rendre ce service public
encore plus service public ? Et ce sont
les mêmes députés de gauche et
macronistes qui m'accusent des deux mots
qui me disent "Monsieur à l'oncle veut
revenir à l'ORTF et en même temps c'est
un agent de la privatisation." Je trouve
ça formidable. Il faudra m'expliquer ce
qui montre que je suis plutôt dans le
vrai parce que si je suis pour les deux,
si je suis visiblement peut-être dans
une position un peu plus consensuelle,
faudra m'expliquer comment c'est
possible de défendre l' RTF et d'être
agent de la privatisation.
Vous avez fait latin à l'école
jusqu'en euh première.
Formidable, ça vient de
pardon
formidable
non je formid pas mal pas trop loin. Ça
veut dire terrifiant.
Question internet. Alors euh il y a un
petit trollage mais on va on va le on va
le lire quand même. Pourquoi monsieur
Allonk n'a pas voulu auditionner
François alors qu'une demande a été
faite pourinterrogation ?
C'était un des profils idéals pour cette
commission d'enquête. Bon je pense que
Ellie vote UPR mais comme nous on écoute
toutes les questions et entend tout le
monde pose sa question et d'ailleurs
l'UPR a bien travaillé parce qu'ils ont
fait monter la question de l'UPR. Je
vous écoute. C'est de la structure F,
c'est pas bien les gars.
Non non, ça m'étonne vraiment pas parce
que j'ai reçu beaucoup de demandes et il
faut être très honnête, j'ai reçu
beaucoup de demandes de personnes qui me
disaient "Monsieur Asselino est
invisibilisé notamment sur les antennes
du service public." C'est pas normal.
Notamment parce que il défend une vision
notamment il défend le Frexit qui est
une opinion, une vision qui est trop peu
représentée sur les antennes du service
public alors que il y a quand même
beaucoup de Français qui s'accordent
pour défendre aussi ce sujet-là. Et
c'est vrai qu'il y a une
invisibilisation, qu'on soit d'accord ou
qu'on soit contre, il y a une
invisibilisation totale de cette défense
de la sortie de l'Union européenne.
Invisibilisation totale. Alors que je
pense que si on faisait un sondage, si
on consultait les Français, c'est pas le
fait de quelques milliers ou dizaines de
milliers de personnes qui de façon
sectaire parlent de FRIT et soutiennent
monsieur Assino. C'est bien plus large.
Donc effectivement qu'il y a un vrai
sujet de représentation, de pluralisme
et de représentativité de ces idées-là.
Euh j'ai reçu beaucoup de messages à cet
endroit et ça m'a inspiré d'ailleurs une
recommandation dans le cadre de de ce
rapport, c'est celle de créer une
plateforme pour donner la parole au
français. Que les Français qui sont tous
coactionnaires de leur audielle publique
soient vraiment codécisionnaires et que
à cet égard, exactement comme ce que
vous venez de faire, c'est-à-dire faites
vos propositions de questions sur
Twitter, votez pour en faire remonter
certaines comme ça ça me permettra de
mieux les sélectionner, de faire
exactement la même chose pour France
Télévision et Radio France. une
plateforme utilisée directement par les
Français avec un système de vote qui
ferait émerger un certain nombre de
préconisations.
Il faut faire gaffe aux opérations d'
structuring. Euh faites gaffe à
Non mais on pourrait avoir par exemple
une fois par mois, on pourrait avoir une
enquête, une investigation du thème du
choix des Français, une investigation de
cash investigation choisie par les
Français une fois par mois, une fois par
trimestre, un invité politique choisi
par les Français. Et là à ce titre là,
je pense que monsieur Aselino par
exemple serait davantage invité. C'est
pas très difficile puisque je crois
qu'il est quasiment jamais visité sur
les antennes du service public. Des
programmes à vocation culturelle, on
pourra avoir un secret d'histoire, le
thème du secret d'histoire choisi par
les français. On aurait des votes. Quel
est le prochain secret d'histoire ? Et
pas faire ça pour l'ensemble des
émissions parce que il y a une forme de
de de visibilité aussi à donner au aux
dirigeants de l'autel public. Mais on
pourrait faire cette plateforme sur les
propositions de programme et de contenu
aussi sur un certain nombre de de
vigilances de travail de vigilance parce
que les médiateurs et les comités
d'éthique sont peu connus, ont des
prérogatives qui sont parfois d'ailleurs
assez confondus et donc les Français ne
saisissent pas suffisamment les comités
d'éthique et les médiateurs. Je vais
avoir une plateforme unique pour Radio
France et France Télévision sur beaucoup
de téléphones de France via une
application où il permettraient de faire
leur recommandation à leur proposition.
Je crois que ça permettrait aussi que
demain les Français soient véritable
codécisionnaire de leur chaîne publique.
Question internet. Comment garantir que
les médias d'état restent indépendants
et ne deviennent pas des outils de
propagande du parti au pouvoir
d'interrogation en cas de privatisation.
Comment éviter qu'il ne fasse la
propagande des partis soutenus par
l'élite et qui on serait propriétaire ?
C'est aussi pourquoi, c'est aussi la
raison pour laquelle je crois un service
public audiovisuel que je suis pas euh
un ardent défenseur de la privatisation
parce que je crois, je vous donne un
exemple, la mission d'investigation, on
pourra jamais la confier à des intérêts
privés. Euh à quel moment vous allez
demander à une chaîne privée détenue par
des actionnaires quel qu'il soit, que ce
soit monsieur Pigas, que ce soit
monsieur Boloré, à quel moment euh vous
allez demander à une chaîne privée de
faire une investigation de façon
indépendante ? Il y a forcément un
moment où il y a des intérêts qui vont
être divergents.
Est-ce qu'on peut demander à Elise Lu
enquête sur le service public ?
Voilà, et c'est exactement la question
que je lui ai posé. Le service public
sonorerait notamment sa mission
d'investigation sonorerait à enquêter
sur les employeurs d'Éis UC. Élise Luca
sonorerait montrerait toute son
indépendance si elle réalisait une vraie
enquête notamment suite à cette
commission sur France Télévision. Et je
crois que si Sonia Mabrou dans le cadre
d'une émission cit sur quelle époque où
elle se retourne vers Éise Lu en lui
disant mais pourquoi est-ce que vous
faites pas une enquête sur Francevision
? Lu avec beaucoup d'appels, lui répond
"Non mais vous savez moi je connais
Franceision de l'intérieur, il y a aucun
motif en enquête, tout va très bien, il
y a rien à voir." Bon ça c'était avant
la commission d'enquête, je lui ai posé
la question, j'ai l'impression qu'elle a
un peu changé d'avis sur des motifs
d'enquête qui pourraient être légitimes,
mais je trouve que l'audiovisuel public
s'honorerait à faire preuve
d'indépendance. Donc à nouveau, si je
suis pas pour la privatisation, c'est
parce que je crois à cette indépendance
du service public à condition de
sanctuariser cette indépendance, à
condition de ne pas confier 1 milliard
d'euros par an sur les 3 milliards
d'euros de budget de France Télévision à
des sociétés de production privées qui
vont venir produire des émissions
d'information, de débat, d'opinion et de
politique du service public. de confier
des contrats à monsieur Pigas qui fait
la une de libération il y a quelques
mois expliquant qu'il mettra tous les
moyens dont il disposent y compris
médiatique pour lutter contre la droite
radicale pour faire avancer son agenda
politique. Tant qu'on préservera le
service public de ses intérêts
financiers, personnels et politiques. Là
honnêtement, on pourrait avoir un
service public fort et indépendant. Mais
je vous avoue qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas
le cas. Aujourd'hui, il y a des
ingérences notamment de société de
production privée, il faut lutter contre
ça. Il y a des ingérences politiques. On
l'a vu dans la nomination
étrangère
étrangère aussi. On l'a vu aussi dans la
nomination de Delphine Arnut en 2015 où
Franço Hollande est intervenue
directement alors que la loi ne le
permettait pas. Il y a eu des preuves de
ça ?
Oui, il y a eu des preuves. Un
témoignage sous serment de monsieur
Schramc qui était président du CSA en
2015 qui devant une commission d'enquête
a expliqué que François Hollande l'avait
appelé pour décommander deux candidats
sérieux concurrents de Delphine Arnut
alors qu'il n'en avait pas le droit. Les
les auditions du CSA parce que le CSA,
j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont des
réactions un peu selon si c'est la
pleine lune ou pas la pleine lune.
C'est tout le problème. Je vais vous
donner un exemple. Sur les 15 dernières
années, le CSA, je crois, attribué plus
de 8 millions d'euros d'amende au
groupe, enfin à C8 et CS. Euh 0 €
d'amende aux chaînes de l'audiel public.
Pendant les gilets jaunes, je crois que
le CSA, et je parle de tête, je demande
à me faire checker, les internautes vont
aller trouver ça. Je crois que le CSA
avait convoqué les patrons de presse,
les patrons des différentes chaînes de
télé pour dire "Bon les gars, on va se
calmer un peu sur les gilets jaunes là."
Non, vous avez pas entendu parler de ça
?
Alors, je vous avoue que je non, j'en ai
pas entendu parler mais peut-être que
c'est
et en même temps, le traitement qui a
été fait à l'époque, pas que sur le
service public des gilets jaunes, ce
retournement médiatique assez inoui en
quelques jours à peine qui a d'une
certaine façon criminalisé ces honnêtes
gens qui défilaient dans la rue, qui
pour la plupart sacrifient une partie de
leur temps, une partie aussi de leur
argent. de leur vie familiale, de leur
vie tout court pour aller manifester
pour des causes qui étaient quand même
relativement justes, de voir cette
crimin cette criminalisation qui a été à
l'œuvre euh de de de vouloir les faire
passer pour euh une bande de de de
personnes qui étaient en quête de
sédition et qui étaient des menaces de
la démocratie de voir ce traitement
médiatique qui a été appliqué. Je vous
avoue que je je l'ai vécu avec une
certaine circonscription. question. En
faisant un peu de prospective, les
médias audiovisuels, radio, télévision,
ont-ils un avenir dans le monde qui
vient ?
C'est une très bonne question. Euh et
d'ailleurs, c'est peut-être une leçon de
cette commission d'enquête. Si elle a
été euh autant commentée, autant
critiquée. Ceci parce que je crois que
c'est la première fois qu'on a introduit
un ingrédient qui déplaît fortement à
une petite élite, à un système et à une
représentation, c'est l'ingrédient de la
démocratie directe et que par
l'intermédiaire des réseaux sociaux, par
cette exposition assez cru des séquences
de ces auditions et de cette commission
d'enquête, on a supprimé les médians, on
a supprimé euh euh les médias en fait,
on a supprimé cette espèce
d'intermédiaire entre les faits et et la
perception directe que les Français
pouvaient pouvaient avoir. Donc je je
dis pas je veux pas théoriser la
commission d'enquête pour le plaisir de
venir théoriser ça. Mais je crois
qu'effectivement c'est un symptôme qui
signale beaucoup de l'évolution du
rapport à la consommation
informationnelle et médiatique de la
part des Français. cette surconsommation
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux, cette
désaffection notamment dans les
abonnements, la perte de vitesse totale
des abonnements euh de titre de presse.
Je crois que l'express par exemple,
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit récemment. J'ai
pas la preuve. Donc je un ami qui m'a
dit ça il y a 3 jours, je me permets de
de vous restituer ce chiffre là. En
2012, je crois que l'Express avait
450000 abonnés. Aujourd'hui, je crois
que l'Express en a plus que 70000
abonnés. Bon, l'Express n'échappe pas,
c'est un titre parmi d'autres, mais il y
a une désaffection totale, notamment des
abonnements pour des titres de presse et
au contraire un temps bien plus
conséquent passé par les Français sur
les réseaux sociaux. Donc, il y a une
désintermédiation de l'information qui
pour moi n'est pas un péril. Faut pas
avoir peur de la désintermédiation de
l'information. Il faut pas avoir peur
que les Français soient eux-mêmes les
témoins et même parfois les émetteurs
d'information à condition qu'ils sont
encadrés à condition aussi que par
exemple des notes qui signalent qu'on a
un certain nombre de fausses
informations qui sont diffusées. Mais
effectivement la question est légitime
parce que je crois que ça touche au rôle
central des médias qui devront s'adapter
à cette désintermédiation, qui devront
s'adapter à cette démocratie directe qui
est en train de naître qui je crois n'a
pas fini aussi de progresser et je crois
que c'est aussi pour le meilleur pour la
démocratie.
Allez, dernière question d'internet.
Bonjour, vous parlez d'un milliard
d'économie annuelle sur les 4 milliards
annuels alloués. Oui, non.
Oui. Euh pas fini, j'ai pas fini. jusque
il y a combien de zé 1 milliard ?
Il y a combien de zéos à 1 milliard ? Il
y en a euh neuf.
Très bien. Comment le Figaro et valeur
actuelle ont-ils eu accès au rapport en
avant-première ? Avez-vous des contacts
particuliers avec eux ? Alors, je sais
pas si c'est une supputation ou
Non, c'est pas une supputation. La
personne a parfaitement raison.
Je n'ai envoyé mon rapport à personne,
mais vraiment à personne une fois que le
vote avait alors queil y a eu des
fuites. Il y a un certain nombre de
médias d'ailleurs qui ont révélé que les
fuites proviendraient d'une députée
socialiste parce que cette députée
socialiste visiblement ne savait pas que
dans les propriétés d'un document Word,
on pouvait savoir qui avait cré le
document et qui l'avait modifié. les
méta
les métadonnées, les fameuses
métadonnées. Donc euh
je vous conseille je vous conseille les
métadonnées euh sur l'entrée des USA euh
dans la guerre en Irak avec les armes de
destruction massif de tout le bordel.
Enfin, c'est pas piqué des hanons.
OK.
Et euh et effectivement donc dans ces
métadonnées, ça a traduit les fuites
avant même le vote du rapport d'une
députée socialiste. C'est sortie dans
les médias. Moi, je j'ai vraiment fait
le choix d'une grande vigilance et de
n'envoyer mon rapport à personne.
Effectivement, dans les heures, dans les
toutes dernières heures qui ont précédé
non pas le vote du rapport parce que
c'était parfaitement interdit, mais la
publication, il y avait tellement de
fausses informations qui circulaient
allègrement depuis 10 jours. Par
exemple, je voulais supprimer le Tour de
France, Roland Garos et les cination
alors que je dis tout l'inverse.
J'explique au contraire qu'il faut
sanctuariser ces grandes compétitions
qui font l'exception sportive française
et au contraire le service public à
vocation à continuer à les diffuser. Je
voyais des fake news sur il veut revenir
à l' RTF et il veut que le président de
la République nomme directement sans
contrepouvoir les présidents de groupe
d'autis public alors que j'explique que
il faut qu'il y ait un vote à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat pour
que ce soit plus pluraliste, transparent
et démocratique. Il y avait tellement de
fausses informations qui circulaient où
les médias ne prenaient même pas la
peine de m'appeler en me disant "On a eu
cette suite là, est-ce qu'elle est vrai
? Qu'est-ce que vous répondez ?" Il la
mettait textuellement, il continue à la
mettre textuellement au présent de
l'indicatif sans même faire preuve de la
moindre de odéontologie. J'étais
tellement exaspéré par ces mensonges et
je voyais, je lisais les commentaires,
les gens disaient "Mais c'est dingue, il
veut ça, il veut s'attaquer au sport, il
veut s'attaquer à Roland Garos, il veut
s'attaquer au Tour de France, il veut
que le président de la République nomme
directement les patrons d'entreprise
publique." Ce type est un dictateur en
puissance. Je voyais ça depuis 10 jours
sur tous les commentaires de ces
articles. Je me disais "Mais c'est
complètement fou, on est en train de me
diffamer, on est en train de salir ces 6
mois de travail et commission
d'enquête."
Donc dans les dernières heures, c'était
avant-hier pour préparer l'atterrissage
du rapport et rétablir quelques vérité,
j'ai effectivement confié au Figaro et à
valeur actuelle effectivement euh mes
réponses sur ces contrevérités et donc
je leur ai exposé un certain nombre de
recommandations qui figuraient bien dans
le rapport. Donc, il y a eu un top 10
des recommandations euh euh écrites par
le Figaro pour répondre notamment à ces
mensonges. Mais en aucun cas, j'ai
envoyé le rapport à qui que ce soit. Et
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle
j'insiste autant de voir Delphine Ern
qui à 7h58 ce matin fait un tweet, un
comuniqué de presse pour expliquer tout
le mal qu'elle pense du rapport alors
qu'il n'a jamais fuité, que personne
n'en a eu connaissance et qu'il venait à
peine où il n'avait même pas encore été
publié. Je vous avoue que ça me dépasse.
Est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
C'est une très bonne question. Déjà, je
vais commencer par les auteurs. Moi, il
y a trois auteurs qui m'ont qui m'ont
bouleversé au-delà de me bouleverser qui
m'accompagne vraiment au quotidien. Un
d'ailleurs qui m'a pas ménagé, c'est un
prononcour récent qui est un génie
linguistique immense qui saisit
d'ailleurs très bien les réalités
sociologiques françaises.
Bernard Henry.
Non, non, mais alors il m'a vraiment
défoncé sur les réseaux sociaux. Ah oui,
lui
euh il m'a croqué de façon quand même
assez mais avec un verbe et une plume
parfaitement assérrée. Je n'enlèverai
rien au mot qu'il a pu écrire mais il
m'atteigne énormément. C'est horrible.
Il a même repris une caricature de
Domier où je suis représenté de façon
maléfique, horrible sur la caricature de
Domier pour illustrer son penflet. Mais
je le trouve néanmoins, je n'ai aucun
euh aucune critique et je lui en veux
pas parce qu'il a un talent immense,
c'est Nicolas Mathieu
qui est très fort. Je vous invite
d'ailleurs à vous abonner à son compte
Instagram parce que vous verrez ces
critiques horribles qu'il a pu faire de
moi et en même temps, vous pourrez lire
aussi euh les différents textes
magnifiques de poésie qui ne raconte
mieux que personne le sentiment
amoureux. Je vous invite d'ailleurs à
lire aussi son dernier sa dernière
correspondance qu'il a publié qui
s'appelle Le ciel est ouvert qui est
pour moi le plus beau livre qui parle
d'amour qui de façon absolument
universelle parle de ce sentiment qui
même à 45 ans après plusieurs divorces
plusieurs séparations. Pe encore vous
rattraper alors vous avez l'impression
d'être d'être un enfant donc
comment on dit le titre en anglais le
ciel est ouvert.
Je sais pas Sky is open. C'est un petit
clin d'œil à votre with the with the
beautiful French accent my friend.
Non non mon accent est horrible. On m'a
beaucoup on m'a beaucoup moqué pour moi.
De tris.
Donc voilà, Nicolas Mathieu, je vous le
conseille. son dernier recueil notamment
une correspondance qui raconte mieux que
personne le sentiment amoureux et c'est
fulgurant, c'est sublime
leurs enfants après eux c'est une porte
ouverte que je défonce qui est son
prigoncour qui est sublime qui dit
beaucoup aussi sur cette génération des
années 90 totalement déclassé
cette cette France paupérisée délaissée
méprisée cette France désindustrialisée
de haut fourneau qui a été abandonnée un
peu du jour au lendemain avec l'arrivée
d'immigrés qui euh ont essayé de d'être
à leur tâche, qui ont travaillé, qui ont
contribué et qui génération après
génération ont vu aussi une forme de de
séparation un peu des des populations.
Mais ce livre est magnifique. Le
deuxième auteur qui moi m'obsède euh et
pareil, ça va être une porte ouverte
enfoncée mais c'est évidemment Wellbeck.
Euh j'adore son rapport au quotidien.
J'ai même une petite anecdote à vous
révéler.
Vous avez le même coiffeur ?
J'espère pas. [rires] Je le prends comme
une critique table. Je
non, je je veux faire une petite
anecdote. Le jour de mon anniversaire,
c'était il y a 2 ans.
C'est quand ?
21 octobre.
Jour de mon anniversaire. On était un
lundi matin. Je je il y a une salle de
sport en bas de chez moi. C'est un keep
cool. À Paris, j'ai un petit appartement
qui est dans le 13e arrondissement euh
pas loin de de Glaciaire et je vais au
Kipol juste à côté. Donc salle plutôt
austère mais elle me plaît parce que bon
une salle de sport sont ce qui ce qui
compte c'est les machines et j'aperçois
un homme assez vieillissant plutôt
bedonnant qui qui absolument pas
l'archétype de la personne qu'on pourra
attendre dans une salle de sport et
vraiment pas. On est un lundi à 10h30 du
matin. Je le calcule pas trop. Je me
mets sur une machine lui et sur
exactement la même machine à côté de
moi. On pousse péniblement parce qu'on a
quand même pas un physique très
athlétique. Alors moi je m'en sors un
peu mieux que lui j'espère. Et donc on
pousse cette même machine et là nos
regards se croisent.
Michel Welbec, Michel Wellbec en tenue
de sport, petit short flashy, t-shirt
Nike, chaussures de sport Nike. Et là je
je je me réveille parce que il y a 20
minutes, j'étais encore dans les bras de
Morphe. Je me réveille, jour
d'anniversaire. Je me dis "OK, non mais
c'est bon, en fait, mon cerveau est en
train de délirer complètement, je suis
pas au keep cool glacière.
En présence de Michel Welbe, ça n'existe
pas. Le jour de mon anniversaire, ça
n'existe pas." Donc là, j'ai eu une
réaction complètement accablante où je
l'ai regardé en disant "Vous êtes Michel
Welbeck ?" Il me répond, on avait
l'impression d'être dans un film de
Nikou Talaso, enfin je sais pas si vous
l'avez vu. Et il me répond, il me dit
"Oui, je suis Michel Welbeck très gêné
parce qu'il se dit "C'est la 15e fois de
la semaine qu'il y a un gars un peu
bizarre qui vient me voir, un peu un peu
timide." Voilà. Et donc là, j'ai fini
par lui dire cette phrase confondante
aussi que tout le monde doit lui sortir.
Je lui dis "J'ai tout lu de vous. Je
suis fan de vous. Merci pour ce que vous
faites. Je pense que j'ai fait le pire
des effets.
Là, il a rajouté 5 kg de chaque côté
et donc non et donc après il s un petit
peu intéressé à ce que je pouvais faire.
Il s'intéressé beaucoup à Lunel puisque
moi je suis élu dans l'héros et j'ai
Lunel notamment dans ma circonscription.
Il connaissait Lunel. Bon
malheureusement par sa triste réputation
qui est d'ailleurs un peu galvodé d'être
la capitale de des djihadistes. En 2014,
c'est la ville en France qui envoyait le
plus de djihadistes en Syrie. Donc il
connaissait Lunel aussi. Et donc on a
beaucoup parlé de Lunel dans ces 20
minutes dans un keep cool en poussant
des poids. On a parlé de ça. Donc
c'était un vrai moment suspendu. Pardon
si je vous ai mis un tunnel, une
parenthèse mais tout ça pour dire que
j'ai une admiration immense pour Michel
Welbec. Et si vous n'avez rien lu de
Michel Welbec, je ne peux que vous
inciter à démarrer par particules
élémentaires
parce que c'est le livre probablement
qui traduit le mieux son esprit
tellement français. Et après le troisème
auteur et j'ai déjà été trop long, un
auteur fulgurant, c'est Emmanuel Carer
euh que j'adore que j'adore. J'ai lu
beaucoup de ses livres. Si vous voulez
pleurer et si vous voulez revivre
notamment les attentats tragiques qu'on
a pu connaître, il faut lire V13, mais
il faut avoir le cœur un peu accroché
parce que ça retrace tous les procès un
peu hors norme sur ces sur ces attentats
du 13 novembre. Si vous voulez euh vous
transporter dans un univers russe et
avoir notamment
espèce de quotidien euh aussi loufo qui
excentrique et 1000 vies dans une vie,
il faut lire euh Limonov. Limonov roman,
c'est même pas un roman ça. raconte la
vie de Limonov qui a à la fois été dans
les plus hautes sociétés russes, qui a
épousé une milliardaire, qui en même
temps a vécu à la rue à New York, qui a
dû se prostituer dans les rues new
yorkaaises pour s'en sortir, qui a été
enfermé dans les prisons de Poutine car
dissident, qui a monté des groupes
révolutionnaires extrêmement
inquiétants, qui a vendu des dizaines
voir des centaines de milliers de
livres, qui a une renommée
exceptionnelle, il a tout vécu, des
basfonds de l'existence humaine. au plus
hautes à la plus haute noblesse de la
reconnaissance sociale. Ce livre en
l'espace de 300 pages vous fait tout
vivre, vous transporte et vous donne une
force d'âme et de caractère, même si
Mononof est loin d'être un exemple et
vous ressortez de ça et vous vous dites
"Qu'est-ce que je peux faire au
quotidien pour être utile et pour vivre
intensément Donc voilà, c'est les trois
auteurs que je vous recommande avec ces
quelques livres que j'ai pu euh
Avant de vous poser notre dernière
question, euh on on demande à notre
communauté de nous soutenir sur Tipi,
euh de partager nos vidéos, de
s'abonner, de mettre la petite cloche,
de suivre parce que des fois
l'algorithme YouTube, il nous pose un
petit peu des problèmes. On se demande
bien pourquoi. J'espère qu'il y a un
jour une commission d'inquiète
là-dessus. Dernière question, oubliez
pas de vous abonner les enfants.
Dernière question, un conseil pour les
jeunes générations, une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose d'impérissable.
dans l'idée de transmission.
Le seul conseil que je pourrais
peut-être donner, c'est celui. Je pense
que notre génération et je m'inclus,
même si j'ai 32 ans, je fais communion
avec ceux qui sont pas encore majeurs.
Je pense que notre génération est
condamnée au courage et je pense que
quand on a
la volonté de servir les intérêts du
pays, quand on a quand on se sent
éminemment français, quand on a envie de
défendre son pays et ses concitoyens,
quel que soit le motif d'engagement,
qu'il soit associatif, qu'il soit
professionnel, qu'il soit politique,
quand on a dans sa vie une fois
l'occasion de s'engager pour la défense
de son pays, il faut pas tergiverser. Et
je vous avoue que moi, j'ai eu des
fourmis dans les jambes pendant un
certain temps. J'étais comblé dans ma
vie d'entrepreneur passé. Il y a eu
beaucoup de réalisation. C'était
magnifique. Mais il y a quelque chose
qui me manquait. Et tous les matins, je
me levais en me disant poursuivre et
défendre des intérêts commerciaux, ce
sera toujours d'une certaine façon un
peu plus, c'est ce que je me disais,
c'est pas la vérité, mais je me disais
ce sera toujours un peu plus vulgaire
que de pouvoir s'engager quel que soit
l'échelle pour son pays. Donc le seul
conseil que je pourrais donner, que ce
soit un motif associatif, un motif
professionnel, un motif politique, le
jour où vous avez une occasion de vous
aligner avec une ambition, un destin, un
dessin supérieur qui vous dépasse et qui
fait que le soir vous couchez avec le
sentiment de devoir accompli, le matin,
vous vous levez avec une excitation
parce que vous avez l'impression de
participer à une entreprise commune qui
laissera une trace mais au nom d'un bien
commun, au nom aussi d'une poursuite de
défense d'intérêt français. Je crois que
c'est le la plus grande des
recommandations, c'est celle quel que
soit son expression, qu'on tienne un
podcast, qu'on soit engagé en politique,
qu'on défende une cause associative,
qu'on monte une entreprise pour soutenir
des causes françaises ou des causes
économiques. Derrière ce qui compte,
c'est la place qu'on pourra humblement
euh occuper pour défendre des intérêts
supérieurs et surtout pour défendre la
France parce que c'est un pays qui
mérite tellement plus que des
chamailleries individuelles. Voilà,
c'est le seul petit conseil peut-être
fort banal que je pourrais donner mais
que j'ai vécu moi il y a 2 ans quand
j'ai dû prendre la décision en même pas
24 he le lendemain de la dissolution. On
avait 24 heures pour se décider de
savoir si on se présentait ou pas comme
candidat aux élections législatives.
J'avais une entreprise à abandonner.
J'avais près de 150 personnes que
j'avais recruté et formé personnellement
qui formaient une vraie famille. Je
savais que l'étiquette politique pour
laquelle j'allais m'engager allait être
une une forme de disqualification euh
advitam eternam. Ça allait être une mort
sociale mondaine et professionnelle. Je
savais que c'était un aller sans retour.
Je savais que mes actionnaires m'en
voudraient au point qu'il ne
m'accepteraiit pas si je perdais. J'ai
pris ce risque là. Je ne le regrette
pas. Peut-être que ça durera pas très
longtemps. Peut-être que dans un an, à
la faveur d'une autre dissolution, je
serai battu et ce sera le choix des
électeurs. Il faudra euh il faudra le
respecter. Mais si vous avez une
occasion une fois dans votre vie de
défendre ce dessin supérieur, il faut
pas hésiter.
Charles à l'oncle. Merci.
[musique]